Warum ist München wie Berlin? München ist ganz woanders und ich habe aufmerksam,
es geht ja nicht anders, Markus Söder zugehört, München ist nicht wie Berlin,
lautet die eigentliche These?
Ja ja natürlich, ich weiß um diese These und bin natürlich auch mit einer gewissen
Erwartung dorthin gefahren und München ist schön,
ich war dort drei Tage in der Oper, das war auch großartig, aber der Verkehr
ist eine Katastrophe in München.
Ich stand Ewigkeiten im Stau für Strecken von zweieinhalb Kilometer.
Mit dem Taxi bin ich gefahren.
Ich kann sagen, es ist so furchtbar, dass wir...
Wie viel Taxi kosten hast du für Ursache?
Zu viele. Also weil die Taxi Uhr ja sich fröhlich weiterdreht.
Die Uber-Uhr ja nicht.
Die Taxifahrer ist es aber auch nicht toll. Also die Taxifahrer verdienen ja
ganz schlecht, wenn sie die ganze Zeit im Stau stehen.
Die waren auch nur am Schimpfen. Ein Taxifahrer sagte mir, ich kann es nicht
überprüfen, aber er sagte mir, Es seien ca.
130 Straßen in München gesperrt, zugleich wird auch noch die U-Bahn renoviert,
an vielen Stationen ist nur Schienenersatzverkehr, d.h.
Man kann nicht einfach umsteigen und mit der U-Bahn fahren. Und ich habe etwas
erlebt, was ich in hunderten Opernbesuchen noch nie erlebt habe.
Publikum war nicht rechtzeitig.
Lohengrin musste verspätet anfangen, weil die Musiker noch nicht alle da waren.
Und so sah ich, wie ein Herr vom Schlagwerk dann nach 15 Minuten noch reingesprungen kam.
Er hatte ein Polohemd an, sich aber noch die Fliege umgebunden und den Frack
übergezogen und ist da reingehuscht und dann wurde gespielt.
Es wurde die Overtüre noch nicht in voller Besetzung gespielt.
Also da war noch nicht alles da. Und dann kamen aber zum Beginn,
also nach der Overtüre kamen dann Musiker. Das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Ich will nur sagen, es ist eine Katastrophe in München. Jetzt werden natürlich
manche CSU-Wähler sagen, ja aber München wird ja auch SPD regiert.
Aber das, so einfach kann man es sich nicht machen.
So einfach kann man es sich nicht machen und ich finde es also eine katastrophe
und würde auch hier noch mal das gleich nutzen nicht nur ein rent gegen münchen
sondern auch noch mal sagen ich bin jetzt absolut gegen die aktionen der letzten
generationen also mir ist es noch mal so.
Weil es nach oben drauf kommt. Es ist völlig unnötig,
es ist völlig idiotisch, denn du hast dich selbst hier schon beklagt in Frankfurt,
als wir ewig im Stau standen, wo wir auch nur ein paar Kilometer weg wollten,
nur da fuhr dann sonst nichts hin und man musste mit dem Auto dahin und du hast
dich schon bitter beklagt. Man wird.
Diesen Aktionen niemals irgendjemand auf seine Seite ziehen können.
Ich habe noch mal in den letzten Wochen mit ganz vielen Leuten über die letzte
Generation gesprochen und ich bin ja nur umgeben von Menschen,
die an den Klimawandel glauben, auch entsprechend wählen.
Also da sind ja keine Leute von AfD, noch nicht mal CDU oder so dabei.
Und ich habe nicht eine einzige Person die sagt, das sind aber tolle Proteste,
ist gut, dass die das machen. In Koblenz gab es das auch, da wurde auch was
blockiert. Geht auch in der Regel wenig vor und zurück.
Ich halte es für die dümmste Aktion. Und ich halte es auch für ... ...
Eigentlich sehr hochnäsig gegenüber den Leuten, die tatsächlich,
wie zum Beispiel dieser Taxifahrer, darauf angewiesen ist, von A nach B zu kommen.
Und dass man glaubt, Ohne auch noch konkret zu formulieren, was man denn will.
Dass man damit irgendwas erreicht, außer Leute gegen sich aufbringen.
Ich halte das für falsch und ausschlaggebend für das, was ich hier jetzt gerade ausführe.
Dass ich mit einer Person telefoniert habe, die organisiert.
Oder ist dabei, ist da in so Organisationsprozessen, ich will sie jetzt nicht
mit Namen nennen, weil ich gar nicht weiß, ob sie das will.
Klimabewegung, Klimaprotest und Arbeiterbewegung und Arbeiterprotest zusammenzubringen.
Und sie hat mir gesagt, es ist seit es die letzte Generation gibt,
schwieriger geworden, diese zusammenzubringen,
weil Postleute, Lkw-Fahrer, was weiß ich,
wenn die Klimabewegung hören, inzwischen denken, ach,
das sind ja die, die jetzt kürzlich dafür gesorgt haben, dass ich drei Stunden
später Feierabend hatte und da müssen jetzt wahnsinnig viel Aufklärungsarbeit
leisten, damit haben wir nichts zu tun, das wollen wir auch nicht.
Uns geht es darum, die soziale Situation zu verbessern und dazu gehört auch
das Klima zu verbessern.
Vielleicht könnte ja die letzte Generation in einem letzten großen Akt alle
Aktionen abblasen, sodass die Leute, die im Stau stehen, wenn sie den Impuls
haben, ah Klimakleber, Straßenverkehr.
Ja, das wäre doch eine Lösung. Gut, ist natürlich gut, wenn das dann trotzdem
gut über die Bühne ging in München. Wir haben auf Instagram gesehen,
du hast einen Vortrag gehalten, der mit sehr viel Applaus zu Tristan und Isolde, oder?
Ja, Einführungsvortrag zu Tristan und Isolde, das ist ja meine Lieblingsoper.
Und hast du es auch geschafft, dem Anspruch gerecht zu werden,
Leuten, die einen Einführungsvortrag wollen, mehr zu bieten,
als die Geschichte, die im Vorfeld von der Volontäre nochmal… Die habe ich gar nicht erzählt.
Die habe ich im Prinzip gar nicht erzählt, also nur angerissen ganz kurz.
Es ging mehr darum, inwieweit Wagner mit seiner Komposition auch wichtig wurde für den Film,
für die Filmmusik und welche Gedankenräume sich auftun bei dieser Musik und
das eigentlich ja in der Handlung nicht das entscheidende zu finden ist,
also im Sinne von Aktion.
Es passiert ja gar nicht viel in Tristan und Isolde, sondern es ist ja ein Kammerspiel
und Diskurs, Drama und ich hoffe, dass ich das vermitteln konnte.
So ist das ja mit der Oper, was uns ja zum Film bringt.
Ja.
Oppenheimer.
Wir waren im Kino, nicht zusammen.
Wo hast du ihn gesehen?
Ich habe ihn in München gesehen.
Auf einer großen Leinwand.
Auf einer großen Leinwand, ja.
Auf einer sehr großen IMAX-Leinwand? Leider nein.
Aber schon auf einer ziemlich großen Leinwand.
Ich habe ihn auf einer sehr kleinen Leinwand gesehen. Das Kino hatte sieben
Reihen, a acht Sitze, aber ein bisschen voluminöser.
Und rechts und links, die Wände sind hier in Frankfurt als Bücherregale gestaltet.
Also man fühlt sich fast so ein bisschen wie zu Hause.
Es ist erstaunlich, aber du kriegst ja trotzdem tolle Technik.
Also die Leinwand ist ja dann trotzdem nicht riesengroß, aber so,
dass sie halt acht Leute, die nebeneinander sitzen, überspannt,
also so zehn, zwölf Meter werden es schon sein.
Und es war, ich kann es immer noch nicht ganz glauben, vielleicht sollte man
wirklich sein Leben einteilen, denn den Tag, bevor ich Obmaheimer sah und dann
danach. Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht mehr, wo sind die Maßstäbe?
Während immer alle, ja, braucht man noch Filmpreise oder wie und so weiter,
gibt's überhaupt noch Geld? Und wenn wir nachher Zeit haben,
können wir auch Clips hören, wie Disney jetzt das Fernsehgeschäft ausräumt und sowas.
Also ist eh alles in Bewegung. Und man fragt sich so, kann man nicht einfach
jetzt sagen, Obmaheimer war der Peak?
Klar geht's danach noch weiter. Aber das ist sozusagen der Höhepunkt des Kinos gewesen.
Gut ist, was Ansprüche sowohl ästhetischer als auch ...
Ökonomischer.
Ich würde es ja viel optimistischer sehen. Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Neustart,
der zeigt, man kann auch noch ganz anders Filme drehen, die nicht so aussehen
wie diese 0815 Produktionen von Netflix.
Man kann das Biopic, das ich nicht besonders liebe an sich als Genre,
weil es in der Regel konventionell und langweilig ist, völlig anders denken
und das tut Christopher Nolan hier.
Und man kann mit analoger Technik auch nochmal eine ganz andere Präsenz auf
der Leinwand produzieren, als es üblich ist jetzt mit diesen ganzen digitalen Aufnahmen.
Und ich finde auch, dass dieses ein Kino ist mit einer politischen Relevanz, wie man sie selten hat.
Also es läuft jetzt zugleich noch ein anderer Film, der heiß diskutiert wird.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du den schon gesehen hast. Barbie. Ich habe ihn schon gesehen,
ich werde mich dazu am Sonntag sehr ausführlich äußern, wo ich sage,
genau, das ist diese Pseudopolitik in Barbie und Oppenheimer macht Politik.
Also wir können anders als sonst jetzt ein bisschen ausführlicher über Oppenheimer sprechen,
also den Film und natürlich Geschichte drumherum, denn es droht nicht die Gefahr
wie sonst, dass irgendwie das erleben muss man selber und dann sollte man nicht
vorher sich informieren oder so, denn es gibt sehr illustre Beiträge.
Ich empfehle sowieso zu dem Film diese Reihen an Interviews,
üblicherweise immer Trash.
Also diese Gespräche mit dem Regisseur und dem Hauptdarsteller und so weiter.
Eigentlich feiern sich alle noch mal ab, wie toll sie das gemacht haben und
dass sie auch endlich mal zusammengearbeitet haben und so. Das ist ja diesmal
nicht so. Sondern Nolan hat ja wirklich eine Botschaft.
Und die möchte er vermitteln. Und ich glaube, das ist ein sehr interessantes Thema.
In dem Film ist es der eine Versuch, in den Interviews ist es der andere Versuch,
aber er bleibt trotzdem immer in diesem Ungefähren.
Er möchte dich nur so anstupsen in so eine Richtung, aber er hält jetzt keinen,
so wie er auch sagt, es ist kein Dokumentarfilm, hält dann auch keinen Vortrag zum Thema und so.
Und das Spoiler-Thema an sich wurde natürlich sowieso aufgegriffen.
Wir haben hier eine größere Runde,
Meet the Press, also MSNBC, größeres Fernsehen, wo der Moderator,
Chuck, irgendwas von sich aus nochmal auf die Spoiler-Thematik zu sprechen kommt
und Nolan eigentlich nur drüber lacht.
You know you receive the story that hopefully creates suspense,
hopefully creates surprise.
Es ist kein Doku Drama, also weder ein Dokumentarfilm, ein Sachfilm noch ein Spielfilm.
Also Spielfilm ist natürlich schon, aber jetzt nicht im Sinne von ein Drama.
Ist es nicht, sondern es ist ein Film, der sich sehr konkret...
Angelehnt hat an eine Biografie, die es gibt über Oppenheimer,
die materialreich ist, 600 Seiten und ein sehr, sehr dicker Anhang und das ist
eigentlich das Füllhorn.
Das Christopher Nolan hier verwendet und Christopher Nolan sagt aber hier etwas
ganz entscheidend ist, nämlich wir wissen, wie die Sache ausgeht,
also was Oppenheimer da macht, nämlich zwei Bomben werden gebaut.
Aber wie schaffe ich es eigentlich, wenn ich ja schon weiß, wie es ausgeht,
doch Spannung herzustellen?
Und das ist ja diese alberne Spoiler-Diskussion, die wir heute überall vorfinden,
dass, wenn über den neuen Marvel-Film geredet wird, die Leute schon fast nicht
mehr zu dem Film sagen, als das, was im Trailer zu sehen ist,
weil sie Angst haben, dass sie irgendjemanden verärgern.
Ja, weil diese ganzen Filme meist nur damit funktionieren, dass dann in der 150.
Minute noch der und der auftaucht und irgendwas rettet. Nein,
das ist natürlich eine ganz dämliche Art, Spannung herzustellen.
Das ist irgendein Überraschungseffekt. Ich kann jetzt auch hier einfach eine
Bombe hochgehen lassen, dann ist das eine Überraschung, aber das hat nichts mit Spannung zu tun.
Das Interessante ist ja eigentlich zu sehen, wenn ich weiß,
wie es ausgeht, schaffe ich es trotzdem, über die Form und über den Weg des
Erzählens und beides ist so hervorragend von Christopher Nolan umgesetzt,
dass man da sich nur verneigen kann.
Genau und das finde ich ja so interessant, dass hier,
also was hier uns nochmal vorgeführt wird, es gibt ja ein Buch und das betont
ja Nolan auch immer wieder,
er empfiehlt ja diesen Prometheus und Eigentlich könnte man ja sagen,
na gut, wer sich für die Sache interessiert, kann halt das Buch lesen,
aber es bleibt eben nicht bei der Buchempfehlung, sondern er entscheidet sich
ja ganz bewusst für das Medium Film, um das nochmal aufzugreifen.
Und dieser Mediensprung liegt natürlich irgendwie so nahe, wenn er denkt,
na ja, gut, er ist halt ein Regisseur und so weiter.
Aber man spürt doch die ganze Zeit, dass er ja mehr will. Also,
dass er auch hier sagt, okay, die Leute sollen ja was fühlen.
Wenn sie es nur verstehen wollen, kann man es im Buch nachlesen.
Aber hier geht es darum, was zu fühlen. Und das Fühlen ist dann auch wieder
nicht der Selbstzweck. Also nicht der Superhelden-Marvel-Kram,
der sich halt innerhalb des Films selbst sozusagen verbraucht.
Und man geht dann einfach raus und sagt, Vor einer Stunde habe ich mich aber
gut gefühlt, sondern hier geht es ja darum, dass es so nachwirkt.
Und dafür braucht man diese Protagonistensicht, die ihm da so wichtig war und
wahrscheinlich auch einfach im Buch nur so angelegt oder wie auch immer.
Ich kenne das Buch nicht, weiß nicht, wie es geschrieben ist,
aber ihm war ja sehr wichtig.
Journalistisch, historisch.
Ja, dann noch so ein Panorama wahrscheinlich. Das ist ein Panorama. Es geht darum,
dass man vor allem ganz viele Stimmen dort hört,
nämlich diese Autoren, die beiden haben mit etwa 100 Leuten gesprochen,
haben auch unglaublich viel die Archive durchforstet und bringen das nun zusammen,
setzen alles zusammen, damit wir ein möglichst vielstimmiges Bild von Oppenheimer erhalten.
Ja, dann ist es besonders interessant, denn wenn das Buch so angelegt ist,
so ein großes Panorama zu spannen, über verschiedene Biografien hinweg,
die sich dann irgendwie so kreuzen, dass dann eine Atombombe rauskommt,
am Ende geht es ja um ein weltbewegendes Ereignis.
Es ist ja auch verrückt, dass es eigentlich ein Kriegsfilm ist,
der in der friedlichsten Region abseits des Wetters überhaupt spielt.
Also man hätte den größten Safe Space irgendwo in der Wüste geschaffen,
um zu sagen, aber hier wird jetzt die entscheidende Schlacht des zweiten Weltkriegs
irgendwie, die dann auch, und das können wir nachher nochmal in dem Oppenheimer
Original Zitat hören, die dann nicht nur kriegsentscheidend,
sondern auch so weltläufendentscheidend irgendwie ist.
Die Zäsur wird da vorbereitet.
Und das kriegt man natürlich über ein Sachbuch gut vermittelt.
So und Nolans Stärke war irgendwie zu sehen, dass zum einen,
das ist natürlich seine Kenntnis als Filmemacher, wir brauchen so eine direkte
Identifikationsmasse,
am besten also eine Figur, an die wir uns dranhängen und dann auch nur eine,
in deren Augen wir so reinschlüpfen und das macht er dann auch bei der Entscheidung,
ist er jetzt eigentlich in schwarz-weiß oder in Farbe oder beides gedrehter Film und so.
Und das sozusagen in Parallelität mit dieser Weltentwicklung zu bringen.
Also eine Technik darzustellen, von der wir alle nicht wissen, wie sie funktioniert.
Aber gerade noch verstehen können, dass wir darüber immer Witze machen,
Quantenphysik, Raketentechnik oder was auch immer.
Das ist nicht zu verstehen. Und das dann trotzdem so runter transformieren,
dass man es nicht versteht, aber zumindest fühlen kann. Und eigentlich ist ja
das Fühlen sogar noch viel wichtiger, sagt dann Nolan. Bzw.
Man begreift es. Also verstehen nicht im Sinne von, dass ich jetzt weiß,
wie das tatsächlich funktioniert, also wie man so eine Bombe baut,
aber man begreift es, was es bedeutet.
Genau, also wir selber als Zuschauer des Films sind in demselben Paradox,
dass uns ja Nolan schon über Oppenheimer ...
Noch mal über die Bande eines Schauspielers im Trailer, also man musste nicht mal ins Kino gehen,
um diesen Satz, Sie werden es erst verstehen, wenn Sie es sehen,
Sie müssen es sehen, also diese kleine Kaskade, und hier sich für diese Sache,
also ein Film, der wirklich alle Menschen betrifft, in dem Falle jetzt gerade
acht Milliarden, das Verständnis darüber aufzuspannen, dass man so hart über
eine Ich-Perspektive geht, finde ich wirklich erstaunlich.
Ich glaube, hier kommt man sehr nah an diese, was von Luhmann immer so zitiert
wird, dieses Komplexität reduzieren und so weiter.
Das hat ja nur einen Sinn, um dann wieder Komplexität aufzubauen, aber eben gerichtet.
Ich glaube, hier kommt man sehr nah an diese, was von Luhmann immer so zitiert
wird, dieses Komplexität reduzieren und so weiter.
Das hat ja nur einen Sinn, um dann wieder Komplexität aufzubauen, aber eben gerichtet.
Und hier so eine ganze Weltentwicklung, einen ganzen Weltkrieg,
eine ganze Vorher-Nachher-Geschichte und so weiter. so auf diesen,
einen Fokus so reduzieren, um dann wieder die ganze Welt verstehbar zu machen.
Also einmal so ein Bottleneck aufzumachen.
Es bleibt nicht dabei, das ist ja das Problem bei vielen Biopics,
dass man hineinkriecht in eine Person und dann aber nur noch das Persönliche irgendwann hat.
Wir sehen dann nur noch den Blick durchs Schlüsselloch, der mich aber nicht
weiterführt. Mich interessiert ja nicht, ob Mozart, Beethoven oder sonst wer
zu Hause Zahnschmerzen hatten oder sonst was. wo sie Pass pro Toto wirken.
Hier haben wir das bei Oppenheimer, dass wir zwar den privaten Blick bekommen,
dass wir seinen Blick bekommen, aber dann weist es darüber hinaus.
Dass er das schafft, ist auch das, was er als Neues hineinbringt.
Das ist etwas, was die Biografie nicht tut. Das versucht sie auch gar nicht.
Aber Oppenheimer als Film funktioniert völlig anders.
Ja, und wenn man drin sitzt Und sich dabei erwischt, wie man so ein bisschen
mitfiebert, dass die Bombe ja wohl hoffentlich funktioniert,
so nach zwei Stunden Film.
Ist ja auch erstaunlich. Also wir werden auf ganz besondere Weise irgendwie verwickelt.
I'm just curious for you, sir.
I have to envision you have audience in your mind, you've thought about maybe
what they would say after they leave the cinema and start talking about it.
What questions do you hope they're asking?
Das ist seine Geschichte, aber es gibt auch Raum für die Zuschauer,
sie dort hinzunehmen, wo sie wollen.
Und ich denke, das ist auch interessant.
Ist es ein Ort, an den Sie hoffen, dass sie gehen? eine sehr,
sehr, sehr gute Antwort kommt, finde ich.
Es lässt Resonanzen, interessante Fragen, Art und Weise, wie man mit unseren
eigenen Leben interagiert, und wie wir unsere Leben leben, und worüber wir uns
kümmern und kümmern. Aber nein, ich will nicht zu spezifisch sein.
Ich will, es ist mehr, wie Killing schon sagte, ein emotionaler und intellektueller Ansatz.
Du hast die Forschung, die Geschichte, die Fakten der Geschichte,
aber du willst, dass die Zuschauer es spüren und sie mit einem Set von Sensationen
und Gefühlen verlassen.
Obwohl ich ja hier auch widersprechen würde,
es ist nicht nur so stark emotional, wie er sagt, sondern es ist aufgrund dieser
Artifizialität der Bildgestaltung auch die Möglichkeit gegeben,
das sehr abstrakt und auch wieder sehr kalt zu betrachten und sehr intellektuell
eigentlich diesen Film zu rezipieren.
Genau und das auf allen Ebenen bis hin zur Musik, die kann man ja auch wirklich
ganz intellektuell so im Sinne von,
das sind echte Instrumente, die nur so ein bisschen abgewandelt,
also ein bisschen Technik ist schon dabei, also Post-Production und so,
aber auf allen Ebenen kriegt man hier so ein sehr analoges Angebot zum drüber
nachdenken und ich habe jetzt aus seinen Worten hier auch mehr so rausgehört,
naja, wir können, also die Geschichte ist geschrieben und sie ist auch schon
aufgeschrieben und sie ist auch schon in verschiedenen Medien verarbeitet,
was wir hier noch mal machen können ist, neben dem sachlichen Verstehen,
so ein emotionales Resonanz einfach hervorzurufen.
Damit verlagern wir aber die, was machen wir aus dem Film?
Was will der Künstler sagen? Nee, was machst du denn aus dem Erleben?
Also so diese Aufgabenverlagerung auf den Zuschauer. Du musst selber wissen,
was du daraus machst. Und in der Hinsicht finde ich auch die ganze Diskussion darum.
Und wir hören heute jetzt auch diese Clips, weil ich denke, dass die Internet
Diskussion so ein bisschen abgedreht ist. Aber wenn man ein bisschen...
Möchtest du sie kurz rezipieren? Du sagst jetzt die Internetdiskussion. Ich denke nicht alle...
Ja, ich versuche sie gerade einzubetten.
Es gibt ja einige Glückliche, die diese Diskussion nicht verfolgen.
Ich sage mal so, wenn so ein Film im Angebot ist und man schaut ihn drei Stunden
und kommt danach aus dem Kino und twittert,
ja, schon wieder die Frauen nur in Stereotypen rollen und wo sind die Indigenen,
die vertrieben wurden in Los Alamos, als die Regierung kam und meinte,
sie müssen jetzt ein Manhattan-Projekt aufziehen.
Und was ist eigentlich mit den Japanern? Wieso sehen wir in dem Film keinen Japaner?
Dann sind das ja alles Sachen, die auch von dem Film hervorgerufen werden.
So wie Nolan wollte, dass da Sachen hervorgerufen werden. Ja, die Frage ist nur...
Sollte man tatsächlich die Diskussion vielleicht auch noch mal unterschiedlich
bewerten, je nachdem wie sie sich entwickeln. Also dass man manchen auch einfach
mal ein Stoppschild hinstellt und sagt, kann man drüber reden,
aber vielleicht nicht in dem Film.
Insbesondere, wenn es heißt, das ist ein Film über den Zweiten Weltkrieg,
aber man sieht gar keine Opfer. Ja, dann kann man ja halt Dunkirchen gucken.
Das ist ja auch ein Nolan-Film.
Dunkirk, Dunkirk 2017 oder 19 oder
wann er kam. Da sieht man den zweiten Weltkrieg in absoluter Dramatik.
Die Siegermächte, die späteren, verlieren 1940, ziehen sich da zurück.
Es ist schon gar keine Kriegsmittel mehr, mit denen sie sich da über den Teich
nach England retten und so weiter, sondern jeder versucht in seiner kleinen
Nussschale da irgendwie durchzukommen und Und das Angebot ist ja da,
in diese Richtung dann zu gehen.
Es ist völliger Nonsens. Man kann ja einen Film aus seiner Logik heraus kritisieren.
Aber ich kann ja nicht sagen, ich hätte gerne Hiroshima Monomura gesehen.
Den gibt es ja schon, den kann man sich ja ansehen. Der ist ja herausragend
gut. Aber dieser Film handelt ja von dem Manhattan-Projekt und dem Protagonisten
dieses Projekts. Das ist die Idee.
Und das ist kein Film, der auch noch mal da und da und dort hinblicken muss.
Aber das sind ja Leute, die nur noch im Kulturkampfmodus über solche Dinge nachdenken können.
Die können nur die Frage der Repräsentation stellen. Und wenn die Repräsentation
erfolgt ist, dann ist alles okay.
Dass dieser Film in seiner Aussage in irgendeiner Weise das Schicksal der Opfer
relativiert, Das kann man ja nicht behaupten.
Ganz im Gegenteil, dieser Film zeigt ja in viel stärkerem Maße die Tragweite
dieses Manhattan-Projekts und der danach folgenden Politik in einem viel brisanteren Diskurs,
als mal kurz zu zeigen, und hier sind Tote.
Das ist ja die Entscheidung von Christopher Nolan, zu sagen,
ich hole jetzt die Bombenexplosion zu Oppenheimer.
Also ich gehe in sein Inneres und lasse vor seinen Augen noch mal die Bombe,
aber hier, im Übrigen in einer Sporthalle, also wo noch mal so gesagt wird,
hier ist jetzt nur noch Anfeuern angesagt, nur noch Kriegslüchtern ein,
da lasse ich jetzt die Bombe vor seinem inneren Auge hochgehen.
Und das ist ja die Kunst des Films, mit den filmischen Mitteln etwas zu vermitteln,
was nicht einfach nur bei Wikipedia nachzulesen ist.
Weil sonst könnte man auch sagen, ich brauche den Film nicht, es gibt das Buch.
Aber das ist ja das Filmische, was erreicht werden muss.
Wenn Oppenheimer anspricht, wenn er dort beim Präsidenten ist,
bei Truman ist und anspricht, dass Los Alamos den Indigenen zurück,
den Indianern zurückgegeben werden soll.
Dann ist das so explizit gemacht. Was will man da?
Wenn gesagt wird, da sind zu wenig Frauenfiguren in der Biografie,
die ja an den Fakten sich ganz orientiert, ist es so, dass das Manhattan-Projekt
von den Wissenschaftlern rein männlich dominiert war?
Und dann gab es aber noch ein paar Frauen in Oppenheimers Leben,
vor allem zwei, diese kommen auch vor, aber in ihren Rollen jeweils.
Die waren nicht die heimlichen Beraterinnen oder sonst irgendwas.
Das kann man nicht im Nachhinein ... Das kann man machen, dann muss man einen
anderen Film erzählen. Man kann auch sagen, wir erzählen Oppenheimer und machen
das als Animationsfilm oder sonst was.
Das sind einfach hirnrissige Vorwürfe, die da gemacht werden.
Das sind Leute, die nicht mehr bereit sind, sich mit dem zu konfrontieren, was sie gesehen haben.
Nur noch gleichen Sie ganz auf der Leinwand ab mit Ihren Vorstellungen,
die Sie so haben von der Welt. Und diese Vorstellungen sind,
genehme gesagt, doch relativ schlicht.
Ja, das ist ganz erstaunlich. Wir haben ein Filmangebot, das uns ganz explizit
vor die Wahl stellt, uns jeden Einzelnen. Und das ist dann seinerseits auch
wieder so ein Fortgang der eigentlichen Welt jenseits des Films.
Entweder, oder nicht entweder, man kann sogar beides machen.
Das eine Angebot ist, okay, da sind Männer, die erleben den Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Wenn auch nur im Fernsehen und so weiter, aber sie wissen, das ist Zweiter Weltkrieg.
Und die Nazis, gegen die sie ganz konkret kämpfen, der Bau ist ja im Wettlauf
mit den Nazis, ist eigentlich schon gewonnen.
So, im Mai 45 ist eigentlich Berlin schon gefallen, und man hat sich schon die
Hand gegeben, hat sich in Torgau getroffen und so weiter. Eigentlich ist Europa
schon besiegt, der Ausgangsherd dieses Krieges.
Und zwei Monate später stehen sie vor der Entscheidung, wir drücken jetzt diesen
Knopf und entweder setzen wir damit die ganze Atmosphäre in Brand und zerstören
einfach jedes Leben. Ja.
Oder aber wir haben danach einfach ... Und da ist da schon die Frage,
braucht man sie überhaupt noch?
Ja.
Und dann hat man halt zwei gebaut. Und die Diskussion, die muss Nolan da wirklich
nicht führen. Da kann er sagen, mein Publikum ist klug genug.
Die Gegenhaftigkeit der beiden Atomwaffenabwürfe da im Krieg,
auch bis jetzt die einzigen innerhalb des Krieges. Also, es gab ja irgendwie 2.000,
Atomwaffenexplosionen seitdem, aber eben nur zweimal im Krieg.
Oder aber man sieht Los Alamos und denkt sich, ah, diese Hütte wurde doch gebaut,
wo ein Indigena vertrieben wurde. Dieses Einzelschicksal nimmt man sich dann
raus und geht in diese Richtung zu diskutieren.
Und das, was da aufgeworfen wird, ist ja immer, und das hören wir nachher noch mal bei Peter Zudeig,
wie man auch eine Nachrichtensendung eröffnen kann, nämlich mit der Frage,
okay, heute ist dieses und jenes passiert, aber eigentlich kocht gerade der
Atlantik 1,5 Grad heißer als sonst.
In welche Richtung gehe ich denn jetzt? Kümmer ich mich jetzt um das kleine
Detail irgendwie und so weiter, Ehegattensplitting füge ich die Diskussion,
weil das klingt wie ein Vorschlag, oder kümmere ich mich um den ganzen Atlantik,
also die halbe Biomasse der Welt?
So, und diese, äh, ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht zu viel über diese Idee der
Kettenreaktion, die Nolan da
verarbeitet, ne? Weil das sollte man ja wirklich im Film selbst erleben.
Aber diese Art der, okay, wir machen mal so einen ganz kleinen Hinweis,
und dann gucken wir mal, in welche Richtung das so geht. Und es ist aber alles
möglich, also wir schließen ja mal gar nichts aus.
Das finde ich so erstaunlich, wie treffsicher das bei mir jedenfalls Resonanz erzeugt hat.
Hier noch mal ein Clip abschließend zu diesem ersten kleinen Blog,
warum dieser Film, warum diese Ich-Perspektive, warum diese Reduktion auf Eigentlich
kriechen wir alle Oppenheimer selbst in den Kopf.
Es ist seltsam, das Wort Entertainment in Bezug auf eine so seriöse Geschichte
zu benutzen, aber Entertainment im Kino ist um die Beziehung zu einer Geschichte.
Und mein Job als Filmemacher ist es, den Publikum für diese sehr,
sehr dramatische Geschichte zu drängen.
Und ich denke, es stellt viele relevante und schwierige Fragen auf,
aber es gibt keine einfachen Antworten.
Reingemacht? Keine Ahnung. Es wird ja nichts erklärt. Ist auch gar nicht Thema dieses Films.
Außer in einem Fall. Es wird doch kurz darauf hingewiesen, dass Quantenphysik
irgendwie so was komisches ist.
Der Zustand ist so, aber auch so. Es ist so beides. Also man kann sich,
kann man selbst entscheiden. Keine Ahnung. Es hängt von der Beobachterperspektive
ab. Also alle diese Floskeln, die man so kennt über dieses quantenphysikalische
Zeug, was ja jetzt immer relevanter wird, wenn's so in die Computertechnik geht.
Aber man hat so den einen Zustand, aber auch den anderen. Und irgendwo dazwischen
ist eine verarbeitbare Masse für uns alle.
Und hier wird's jetzt richtig interessant. Denn ...
Wir haben jetzt grade wieder einen Atomwaffendiskurs. Weil Putin den brutalen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und so weiter und so fort, um's mal so zu sagen.
So.
Dann kommen immer sehr viele mit diesem, ja, Putin droht ja nur und das wollen
wir nicht so ernst nehmen.
Und wir haben aber so im Untergrund dann, naja, das sind ja trotzdem Atomwaffen.
Also auch jeder, der sagt, man soll es mal nicht so ernst nehmen und der Putin
droht ja nur, weiß ja, am Ende geht es ja trotzdem um Atomwaffen.
Also wir haben eigentlich gerade einen Atomwaffendiskurs.
Und was Nolan wollte, ist einen Atomwaffendiskurs führen ohne Krieg.
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir beides. Jetzt haben wir einen durch den Krieg und einen ohne
Krieg durch den Film. So, und diese...
Doppelhaftigkeit, dass immer mehrere Zustände da sind. Eigentlich sollten wir
jetzt ganz zivil anhand des Oppenheimer-Films über, es liegt 80 Jahre,
70 Jahre zurück, und so weiter über Atomwaffen, aber jetzt plötzlich wird es wieder so präsent.
Und dann dieses, wir haben einen Atomwaffendiskurs in dem Film,
aber uns wird gar nichts Technisches erklärt.
Wir sollen es so fühlen, und wir wissen ja, worum es geht, und wir haben schon
mal einen Atompilz gesehen, und wir wissen aber gar nicht, worum geht es dann so.
Richtig zuspitzt sagen kann, dieser Film ist ein Medienereignis für uns als
Zuschauer, genauso wie die echte Atombombe damals auch.
Die war ja nicht für uns bestimmt, sondern wir sollten im Fernsehen sehen, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Ja. So leidvoll das ist für die Japaner, die es wirklich getroffen hat,
war es eine Botschaft an die ganze Welt, die medial vermittelt ist,
das ist jetzt da, kann eingesetzt werden.
Ihr seid alle betroffen und sei es als Zuschauer.
Und diese Doppelartigkeit, also dass wir einen Film haben, der eigentlich so
wichtig ist wie die Atombombe selbst, weil einfach beides auf einer Ebene fast
ein Medienereignis ist.
Das beschreibt Nolan hier mal und auf dieser Bühne, auf der er hier sitzt,
sitzt auch neben ihm zwei Stühle weiter dieser, ich hab seinen Namen leider vergessen,
dieser eine Physiker, den er auch sozusagen seinen besten Freunden zählt,
der Nobelpreisgewinner ist und mit ihm auch das Schwarze Loch damals ausgetüftelt
hat, wie das aussehen sollte, so ein Interstellar. Stella, und da sagt Nolan folgendes.
I think you captured this sense of...
Ah, es ist gar nicht die Bühnensituation, sondern es ist ja nochmal in dem Einzelgespräch,
also unglaublich viele Gespräche, mit so einem Professor, der ihn so ein bisschen
tiefergehende Fragen gestellt hat.
Hidden power in nature, which I think runs through a lot of your films,
it's in Stella as well of course, isn't it?
Yeah. That sense that there's a power there that's beautiful and perhaps comprehensible
and incomprehensible at the same time. Und ich denke, dass die Konferenz und
die Unkonferenz gleichzeitig ein großer Teil sind.
Warum beginne ich mit dem? Es ist so, dass ich mit meinem Freund Kip Thorne
im Interstellar-Projekt gearbeitet habe, der Nobelpreis-Weltmeister Physiker ist.
Wir haben uns gemeinsam dargestellt, dass der Prozess von Schriftlern und Künstlern
nicht so anders ist, wie der von Physikern. Er hat klargestellt,
dass die Intuition, das Gefühl, etwas zu verstehen, sehr wichtig ist für Physiker.
Wir wollen zeigen, am Anfang des Films und weitergehen, Wir wollen zeigen,
dass die Energie, die er visualisiert, auch in ihm drin ist.
Und es torturiert ihn zu einem gewissen Punkt. Er versucht, es in etwas Produktives
und Bedeutendes zu vermitteln und versucht, es zu verstehen.
Und das fühlte sich sehr relativ an.
Ich denke, jeder kann das verstehen.
So, und das ist natürlich wahnsinnig interessant, wenn er jetzt feststellt,
ah, da ist ein Physiker an meiner Seite, der versucht mit mir ein schwarzes Loch auszutüfteln.
Wir müssen es halt beide irgendwie fühlen. Und in dem Moment,
wo ich es visualisiere, verschaffe ich auch dem Physiker einen Verständnisfortschritt.
So wie er mir dabei half, mit seinen Zahlen und Daten zu verstehen,
wie es aussehen soll. Also dieses Bedingungsverhältnis von ästhetischer Komponente
und echter Physik oder eben Film und echte Atombombe.
Das ist ja in dem Film wahnsinnig interessant. Ich hab mich ja auch ...
Man erlebt ja wirklich mit, dass da Leute an etwas arbeiten und sie wissen nicht genau, was es ist.
Sie stellen da tausend Sensoren und Kameras auf und sind danach,
wie nachzulesen ist, überrascht, dass sie eigentlich nochmal ein Drittel stärker
war, als sie selber ausgerechnet haben und so weiter.
Und in dem Moment, wo die sich darauf vorbereiten, dass sie heute diesen Trinity-Test
machen, 5 Uhr 45 oder wann.
Und der eine schmiert sich komplett mit Sonnencreme ein und setzt sich eine
Brille auf und setzt sich noch in ein Auto und der andere stellt sich einfach
so hin und guckt sich das so an.
Also diese unterschiedlichen, selbst von Leuten, die es wirklich wissen,
diese unterschiedlichen Herangehensweise an, naja der Putin droht ja nur oder
nee, ich bringe dich jetzt mal echt in Sicherheit. mal echt in Sicherheit.
Ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Und das ist ja etwas, was das Kino ausmacht. In den Medienwissenschaften gibt
es ja da länger schon Diskussionen darüber, dass wir es eigentlich auch beim
Kino mit etwas Epistemischem zu tun haben.
Also nicht nur im Sinne von, es kann Wissen vermitteln im Sinne eines pädagogischen
Films, der etwas erklärt.
Das gibt es hier auch, diese Komponenten. Ein paar Dinge bekommen wir erklärt,
aber das Wissen auch vermittelt wird über Bildsprache beispielsweise.
Und dass dann selbst der Wissenschaftler, der im Neuen berät,
dadurch, dass er sehen kann, plötzlich eine Erkenntnis erhält,
zeigt, dass also der Film selbst nicht eine Wissenschaft ist,
aber durchaus Erkenntnisse produzieren kann.
Erkenntnisse, die die Wissenschaft nicht produzieren kann.
Oder antreiben kann. Im Sinne von, dass junge Leute in in diesen Film gehen
und sagen, ah, jetzt weiß ich, ich möchte YouTube-Star, Fußball-Star,
nächste Tailors wirft oder,
Astronaut werden. Ja, je nachdem. Also da geht es auf allen Ebenen.
Ist es jetzt ein Film über die Atombombe?
Hmm. Also wiederholt sich Geschichte. Bei der Atomwaffe war ja auch klar,
man hat eine Bombe gebaut, aber gleichzeitig hat man sie auch zivil nutzbar gemacht, also dual use.
Genau dasselbe droht ja mit Künstliche Intelligenz wieder und er verbindet sogar die beiden Themen.
Sie wollen einfach keine Verantwortung für das, was das Algorithmus macht.
Und wenn es um AI geht, ist das eine beängstigende Möglichkeit.
Nichtsdestotrotz, weil, wenn AI-Systeme in die Verteidigungs-Infrastruktur gehen,
werden sie letztendlich für nukleare Waffen verantwortlich sein.
Und wenn wir Leuten erlauben, zu sagen, dass das eine andere Entität ist,
als diejenige, die das Programmieren, das AI nutzen will, dann müssen wir uns
um die Verantwortung kümmern.
Wir müssen die Menschen für ihre Werkzeuge verantwortlich halten.
Ja, das war dann seine Frage, benutzen sie jetzt Computertechnik,
um die Filme besser zu machen.
Also diese Idee, also selten, eigentlich unerwartet, haben wir Nolan hier ganz
deutlich als Didaktiker gehört und so, der die Weltgeschichte ein bisschen mitschreiben möchte.
Atomwaffen gibt es. Künstliche Intelligenz kommt hinzu. Entwickler der Künstlichen
Intelligenz sprechen von dem Oppenheimer Moment.
Und er verknüpft das dann noch mal mit, ja, und selbst die Wehrtechnik selbst.
Und dann ist ja Atomwaffen sind da angebunden, könnte ja dann durchsetzt werden.
Durch Künstliche Intelligenz, muss nicht direkt der Trigger sein,
aber irgendwie ein Bedingungsverhältnis gibt's dann doch. Also da wird's knifflig.
Und seine eigentliche Aussage, da war ich auch überrascht, dass es so deutlich
war, er wollte uns wirklich einfach nochmal sagen, Atomwaffen sind gefährlich.
Nuklearwaffen sind eine extraordinär gefährliche Sache, die man im Haus liegen lassen kann.
Es ist nicht etwas, das wir vergessen sollten. Und es ist nicht etwas,
das wir leicht nehmen sollten.
Und eines der Dinge, die mich am meisten ängstlich macht, du redest von der
Angst, nach Hause zu kommen, aber was ich in den Medien höre,
sind reasonable Menschen, die über taktische nukleare Waffen sprechen,
als ob diese Distinktion gemacht werden könnte.
Und sie kann durch erste Politiker und Medien gemacht werden,
Das hat uns immediat warmt, dass es eine gewisse Größe von Nuklearwaffen gibt,
die akzeptabel sein könnte, anstatt die großen.
Davor hat Habermas in seinem Essay gewarnt. Er sagte, mit diesen taktischen
Nuklearwaffen kommt man dazu, dass man versucht, wieder in einen klassischen
Krieg einzutreten. Aber dann mit Nuklearwaffen, aber noch nicht die Superbombe.
Aber die dreut ja dann. Ich meine,
wer diesen Film gesehen hat und sich noch mal erinnert an unseren Diskurs jetzt
während des Krieges in der Ukraine,
wo laufend wiederholt wurde,
man sollte sich jetzt nicht ins Boxhorn jagen lassen, keine Angst haben und
man sollte auch ruhig mal nicht auf, also man sollte sich nicht von seiner Angst regieren lassen.
Wie war der Satz immer? Genau, wir dürfen uns nicht von unserer Angst leiten lassen.
Seitdem es dann die Atombombe gibt, ist die Angst real und sinnvoll,
sich von ihr leiten zu lassen.
Nicht nur und nicht permanent, aber zu glauben, man sagt, ja,
da lassen wir uns nicht mehr von der Angst leiten.
Also dann ist man ja noch schlimmer als die Leute, die sagen,
ist doch schönes Wetter, was geht mich der Klimawandel an?
Also das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist die reine Idiotie. Und ich meine,
ich habe, du weißt, ich vergesse ja leider nichts. Ich habe die Liste,
diese Leute, die das gesagt haben, im Kopf und kann ja noch in 50 Jahren ausspucken.
Aber da merkt man schon, dass das Leute sind, die jetzt auch den Film nicht verstanden haben.
Also die Atombombe ist...
Für uns, und Angst ist dann das Vehikel, ein Medienereignis,
sie darf nur im Fernsehen stattfinden.
Als Drohpotenzial. Wenn sie in echte Gewalt umschlägt, dann sind alle Ressourcen
verzerrt. Also, dann ist einfach, man weiß dann nicht genau,
was als Nächstes passiert.
Niemand kann einfach so eine Atombombe abwerfen in der Hoffnung.
Dann habe ich das lokal beim Problem erledigt. Die Sovjets, ich hab das auch
noch mal nachgelesen, das ist so irre, die haben 2000 Atomwaffen gezündet.
Aber nur 800 davon waren Atomtests.
Da fragt man sich, hä? Aber es sind nur noch 200 Atomsprengungen übrig.
Ja, die haben dann versucht, unterirdisch Geoengineering zu machen,
Räume freizusprengen, Flussläufe zu ändern, lauter so Zeug.
Und haben dann irgendwie festgestellt, ach so, wir haben uns hier alles verseucht,
und es klappert auch alles, und wir wussten gar nicht, also so genau kann man
es dann gar nicht steuern, was genau passiert und so.
Also es führt immer in die Irre und immer ins Drama.
Nun haben wir aber den Fall, dass zweimal Atombomben abgeworfen wurden auf Hiroshima und Nagasaki.
Diese Atombomben wurden ja gebaut, bevor der Trinity-Test erfolgte.
Also die waren dann einfach schon fertig, abtransportiert.
Die Forscher konnten auch lebwohl sagen irgendwie zu sich, haben das ganze Ding
da aufgelöst und wussten, zwei dieser Sachen sind jetzt einfach in der Welt
und obliegen der politischen Handhabe.
Und Oppenheimer wird 20 Jahre später, 1965, gefragt.
Was bedeutet denn jetzt eigentlich so insgesamt auch für Sie,
also wir krabbeln jetzt noch mal richtig rein in seinen Kopf,
sozusagen in so einem Fernsehinterview, was bedeutet jetzt dieser Atomwaffenabwurf?
Können Sie irgendwie damit leben? Das sind ja so die Fragen,
die man sich automatisch stellt, dass Sie damit verantwortlich sind,
so wie es auch im Film dargestellt wird, dass er da kurz beim Präsidenten sitzt
und so weiter und so fort.
Und seine Antwort fand ich so ein bisschen überraschend, aber zeigt wieder,
wie diese Menschen denken, sein können.
Und die besten Beweise, die sie dann hatten. An dieser Alternative war die Bombe ein enormer Relief.
Der Krieg begann 1939, es gab die Todesfälle von Tens von Millionen,
es gab Brutalität und Degradierung, die keinen Platz hatte, um sich selbst zu bewegen.
Die in der Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts keinen Platz hatte. Das Ende der Krieg
war durch diese Weise sicher kruell, war nicht leicht übernommen, But I am not.
Ich bin, wie heute, sicher, dass ein besseres Kurs eröffnet wird.
Ich habe keine sehr gute Antwort auf diese Frage.
Gab, über die man Oppenheimer nicht informierte, also zwischen Japan und den USA.
Und dass man tatsächlich dort mehr Wissen hatte in Washington,
als man dann preisgegeben hat, sodass also im Nachhinein das auch nochmal anders
bewertet werden müsste.
Aber gut, die Debatte können wir jetzt nicht hier ganz ausführen.
Aber wir sehen zumindest dieses Dilemma.
Und das ist es, was Nolan ja so perfekt kreiert,
das Dilemma, uns zu zeigen, auch in einer Schönheit, ja, es ist ja nicht ein
Film, der jetzt einfach sagt, seht her, wie schrecklich, sondern der hat ja
eine Faszination auch weiterhin für die Technik.
Denn im Prometheus steckt ja auch schon drin,
dass man da über sich hinausfäßt, also dass man etwas, etwas göttliches als
Wissenschaftler an sich hat und damit arbeitet Christopher Nolan,
zeigt da auch nochmal diese Verführbarkeit, denn das Kino ist eine Verführungskunst.
Und ich glaube, dass man genau solche Filme benötigt, eigentlich um in richtige
Debatten zu kommen. Gut, das muss man dann ignorieren, wenn Leute sich dem ganz
verschließen wollen und nur ihren Identitätszauber da aufführen, aber,
Ich denke, dass es eigentlich ein guter Anfang wäre, wenn man jetzt auch sagen muss,
ja, es gibt halt auch wenig, die so gute Filme machen können wie Nolan,
beziehungsweise er hat einen solchen Sonderstatus, dass er machen kann,
was er will und drehen kann, wie er es will, wenn man sich ansieht,
wie sonst so in Hollywood produziert wird, dann ist das natürlich weit ab von dem.
Ja, und da führt, ich glaube, dass diese Ausnahmeposition, die Nolan hat,
schwierig sein wird jetzt so.
Also man wird das nicht so einfach adoptieren können. Was ich aber glaube,
ist, dass man schon noch mal die Relevanz des Kinos herausgestellt hat mit diesem Film.
Ja, also da will ich noch mal kurz einen Satz zu verlieren. Allerdings nicht
so hoffnungsfroh wie du, sondern nur noch mal als so nachgeschobene Erkenntnis.
Man hätte es schon fast nicht mehr erwartet, aber irgendwie hat es die Zeit uns noch mal geschenkt.
Wir haben ja gerade diesen Streik, dem sich jetzt auch die Schauspieler angeschlossen haben.
Und dann haben wir so Kommentatoren wie Scott Galloway, die sagen,
naja, das ist eigentlich blöde, was da passiert.
Weil jetzt wird eine Kriegsfront zwischen den Studios und ihren Handarbeitern
sozusagen aufgemacht, ihren Handwerkern.
Dabei müssten die sich ja verbünden, um gegen die eigentliche Bedrohung,
also alles, was Kurzvideo, Algorithmus
getrieben, direkt auch in der Handfläche des Publikums abläuft.
Angefangen bei TikTok, aber jetzt mittlerweile ja überall. Instagram, YouTube und so.
Und hier sehen wir ja noch mal, dass ...
Entertainment, das so hart in diese TikTok-Richtung geht, uns noch mal echte
Qualität organisiert hat. Also, dass Organisation und Institution noch mal auf
einem Level uns gezeigt haben, was sie können.
Mit der Opel Maymay jetzt, meinst du?
Algorithmen und einfach nur das Internet so nicht kann,
denn ein Short-Video, also das ist einfach, das geht drei Sekunden und dann
kommt halt was Nächstes und man kann sich immer wieder drei Sekunden damit beschäftigen,
also hintereinander weg, so eine ewig lange Doom-Stroll-Skoll-Strecke füllen.
Aber da kommt man ja nicht nach drei Stunden raus und ist plötzlich wie bewegt
von Oppenheim oder so. Ja.
Und meine Befürchtung ist ein bisschen, nur deswegen auch am Anfang mein Spruch
dazu, dass das wirklich das letzte Aufbäumen dieser organisierten, guten Bergchen,
Zeit war. Ja, also das ist jetzt einfach, Nolan ist der Einzige,
der es kann und er hat sich hier selbst übertroffen.
Nun, es gibt natürlich auch andere gute Regisseure und das Problem ist aber,
dass sie in dieser Weise nicht wahrgenommen werden. Das ist ja auch das Ding,
dass Christopher Nolan, wie auch dieser Barbie-Film, ein Marketing hatten,
wie das selten der Fall war.
Und dadurch kann man eine solche Relevanz produzieren, dass alle Leute,
die sich sonst vielleicht eher abgeschreckt fühlten von dem Thema Oppenheimer,
sich in den Kinosaal stürzen.
Man muss nur dann im Kinosaal auch überzeugen. Und das tut ja Oppenheimer.
Also ich saß dort mit Leuten, wo ich jetzt mal sagen würde, die hätten auch
ganz gut in Fast & Furious Teil 17 gehen können. Und trotzdem sitzen sie dort,
schweigen drei Stunden lang, sind hochgespannt und inhalieren diesen Film.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es viele sehr gute Filme gibt, die aber so gut wie
nicht zu sehen sind beziehungsweise nicht einen solchen Hype auslösen.
Also die gute Kunst findet ja nach wie vor statt. Die Sache ist nur,
dass ihr keine Aufmerksamkeit zuteil wird, da wir durch zum Beispiel dann diese
sozialen Medien abgelenkt sind.
Oder auch durch ganz viel Produktion an Serien, an Filmen, die stattfindet, die nicht gut ist.
Also es wird einfach so viel Schrott produziert und ja, dieser Streik da,
glaube ich auch, dass der am Ende nicht zu dem führen wird, was eigentlich gewünscht wäre.
Man muss es, glaube ich, sehr differenziert betrachten, insofern als wir hier
zum einen Leute haben, die zu prekären Verhältnissen für den Film arbeiten und
höhere Löhne haben wollen.
Und dann gibt es noch mal Stars, die gerne eine bessere Vergütung hätten und
da würde ich auch nochmal unterscheiden wollen zwischen den Leuten,
die aufgrund ihrer Originalität, was immer das dann sein mag,
so großes Publikum anziehen, dass sie alle ins Kino bekommen oder ob wir es
einfach mit guten Schauspielern zu tun haben.
Jetzt ist das so dahingesagt, einfach gute Schauspieler.
Aber ich will mal ein Beispiel bringen, Dirty Dancing, da kennen wir die beiden
Hauptdarsteller und die tragen den Film, da spielen noch ganz viele andere mit.
Aber wären die durch andere ersetzt worden, hätte der Film wahrscheinlich auch funktioniert.
Und das bedeutet, dass wir es da bei diesen Schauspielern mit Stars zum einen zu tun haben,
die werden in einer Weise honoriert, die ist nicht berechenbar mit hat so und
so viel stunden gearbeitet und dann gibt es die anderen die.
Zur Masse dazugehören, die es braucht. Also ohne die kannst du kannst nicht
einen Film mit nur zwei Stars drehen.
Aber die können nicht in dieser Weise entlohnt werden. Das ist halt ein ein
ein völlig ein sehr ungerechte Welt. Also das Show-Business ist eine sehr sehr ungerechte Welt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man damit erfolgreich sein wird,
dass man damit unter den Studios ein bisschen mehr abverlangt,
finde ich nicht schlecht, aber ich glaube auch, dass wir, dass der Zeitpunkt
nicht besonders gut gewählt ist, weil gerade alle ziemlich in der Krise sind.
Ja, der Werbemarkt schrumpft.
Netflix hat zwar noch ein Plus, aber wenn man sich das genauer ansieht,
dann ist das nicht besonders erquicklich.
Und wenn man mal davon absieht, dass die jetzt gerade noch mal sehr viel dazu
gewonnen haben dadurch,
dass sie nicht mehr es so einfach möglich machen, dass man sich das so aufteilen
kann, ja, dann wird also die Wachstumsprognose für die nächsten Jahre vielleicht
nicht so rosig aussehen und dann gibt es diese Content-Flut.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man abends sagt, ach schade, die streiken,
jetzt ist ja im Fernsehen gar nichts mehr drin, sondern es wird ja ohne Ende
gesendet, wir schaffen es gar nicht alles.
Und man hat halt jetzt diese, ja nicht eine Finanzkrise, aber eine gewissermaßen rezessive Zeit.
Wahrscheinlich wäre dieser Protest vor fünf Jahren wesentlich erfolgreicher geworden.
Ja, es ist irre, was gerade passiert. Deswegen letzte Frage zu Oppenheimer.
Wie hat dir Josh Hartnett gefallen?
Ja lange nicht gesehen.
Wirklich lange nicht gesehen. Ich habe natürlich Pearl Harbor im Hinterkopf,
wo er diesen Jüngling spielt und jetzt
dieser überzeugende Professor der Oppenheimer auch nochmal zur und so.
Das war eine richtig große Überraschung und ich habe es erst auch gar nicht
gemerkt. Und das ist das Erstaunliche, wir sehen so viele Stars.
Das ist ja bei Herbert Donnie Jr. auch, dass ihm ganz viele sagen,
auch in den Gesprächen, ich habe
das erst gar nicht, dann habe ich erst gesehen, ah ja das sind ja sie.
Und das ist aber, das zeigt was Christopher Nolan macht,
denn diese Stars sind ja eigentlich in diesen, was sie für Bilder auf die Leinwand bringen,
so überdeterminiert, dass du ja gar nicht mit denen,
ja du kannst ja gar nicht mit denen arbeiten, also sind ja manche einfach dadurch,
dass sie so auf Rollen abonniert sind,
tot für alles andere und du musst schon ein herausragend guter Regisseur sein,
um dann solche Gesichter, die wie Logos eigentlich sonst funktionieren,
nochmal in einen anderen Kontext zu setzen, ohne dass es stört,
ohne dass man sagt, ach, das ist doch hier der.
Robert Downey Jr., die haben sehr viele Witze darüber gemacht in diesen Gesprächen,
ich fand das auch wahnsinnig amüsant, kennt man ja eigentlich nur als Iron Man,
der hat ja zehn Jahre lang nur Marvel Filme gedreht und immer nur in der Iron Man Rolle.
Und die Regiehinweise von Nolan waren dann immer nur, wir reduzieren dich mal.
Also nicht dieses Iron-Man-artige, ich bin Iron Man und so weiter,
bis in die Mimik hinein, sondern, nee, wir reduzieren das jetzt.
Du nimmst mal ganz viel raus aus dem Spiel. Und dann klatscht er so in die Hände,
als ihm dann der eine BBC-Reporter sagt, ich hab das erst gar nicht verstanden, dass Sie das sind.
Hat er sich auch wieder sehr geehrt gefühlt als Schauspieler.
Also in der Sicht, schaut euch das unbedingt an.
Wir werden ihn auf deutsch aber noch mal sehen, irgendwo ist er ja noch nur
versteckt zu sein. Sehr gut, Empfehlung hiermit.
Wir wollen ganz kurz ankündigen, dass wir im Salon uns nicht an die Abmachung
halten und nur ein Buch lesen und ein kurzes Buch lesen, sondern wir lesen zwei
Bücher und eines ist davon sehr lang, eines ist sehr kurz.
Wir haben es in dem Teaser schon angekündigt, wollen es aber hier noch mal für
alle sagen. Wir gehen auf die Gamescom im August und müssen uns natürlich natürlich
vorbereiten, welchen Realitäten wir dort begegnen bzw. wie unsere Realität erweitert wird und...
Ich hatte gedacht, man müsste eigentlich mal dieses Buch von David J.
Chalmers lesen, Realität plus virtuelle Welten und die Probleme der Philosophie.
Und ich schaute dann so nach und war dann auch bei Amazon, hab mir angesehen,
wie das da präsentiert wird.
Und dann fand ich in den Kritiken unten eine sehr ausführliche Kritik,
die nicht zufrieden war mit diesem Buch, die das sehr gut dargelegt hat.
Auch noch mal der Verweis darauf, dass die Süddeutschen und die FAZ sehr unkritisch
mit diesem Buch umgegangen sind. Und dass das doch verrückte transhumanistische
Ideologie sei, die da propagiert wird.
Und dann war aber noch der Verweis am Ende dieser Kritik, ich hab selbst ein
Buch geschrieben, ich bin auch Experte.
Ich bin Neurowissenschaftler und Psychotherapeut, Joachim Bauer.
Und dieses Buch, das bei Heine erschienen ist, dieses Buch, das bei Heinen erschienen
ist, wie KI und virtuelle Welten von uns Besitz ergreifen und die Menschlichkeit
bedrohen, ist auch zeitgleich erschienen.
Deswegen werden wir auch beide miteinander besprechen, in Kontrast setzen und
wollen schauen, wo es uns hinführt, welche Position wir eher annehmen oder ob
wir noch mal eine dritte entwickeln wollen.
Genau, wir hatten es euch ja schon mal angekündigt. Währenddessen ist in der
Podcast-Welt auch noch mal kurz aufgegriffen worden, Das ist auch noch mal kurz
aufgegriffen worden, also das Realität Plus Buch, dieser Long-Term-Mission und
so weiter und so fort. Ich will nur kurz 10 Sekunden von Jeff Chavez,
oder wir spielen zwei Clips, da einige 30 Sekunden.
Jeff Chavez äußert sich mal zu den Lesern dieses Realität Plus Buch,
also die ganzen Silicon Valley Leute, die uns Elon Musk und Sam Altman und so
weiter in diese Richtung abdriften.
In der New York Times gibt es aber eine tolle Art von Artikeln.
Der Titel lautet, dass in der heißen weißen Mitte des A.I.-Dümerismus,
entsprechend, dass alle, die bei Anthropic arbeiten, überzeugt sind,
dass das A.I.-Apokalypse gerade um die Ecke ist. Das sind Langzeitbetriebe.
Das sind Langzeitbetriebe.
Und ich bin froh, dass Kevin Roos letztendlich darüber zu schreiben beginnt.
Es gibt mehr Leute, mit denen er gesprochen hätten, aber er beginnt letztendlich,
zu erkennen, dass diese Leute Kult-Mitglieder sind.
Also da wurde so ein Kult begründet und Jeff Jarvis bringt das hier nochmal auf den Punkt.
Aber diese AI-Jungs, diese Langfristigen, schrecken mich.
Schrecken mich viel mehr als AI. die RDE bald verbrennt oder sonst was tut,
wäre es vielleicht besser, sich doch mal hochzuladen mit seinem Bewusstsein.
Joachim Bauer würde sagen, nee, wir haben auch noch einen Körper oder ein Leib,
das müssen wir auch noch diskutieren.
Jedenfalls, wer das miterleben will,
wie wir über dieses Buch ausführlich sprechen, kann den Salon buchen.
Wer das nicht hören will, aber den Podcast unterstützen will,
kann auch den Salon buchen, denn das ist die einzige Möglichkeit,
wie man diesen Podcast unterstützen kann.
Der Salon ist buchbar über Steady, das ist die von uns präferierte und empfohlene Variante.
Man kann uns über die Steady Seite finden, man kann auch auf neue20er.de gehen und uns finden.
Man kann auch über Spotify ganz einfach zu Steady kommen. Dort ist ein Button
und dann wird alles ganz leicht.
Also das heißt, ohne nur, wer bei Steady Buch kann überall hören,
sowieso in seinem eigenen Podcatcher, aber auch bei Spotify,
also wir wollen ja nicht allzu sehr, dass die Leute jetzt nur über Spotify ihre
Podcasts hören, weil da hängen ja auch so ein paar Probleme dran,
aber es ist trotzdem, die Wege sind alle offen, also man kann auch in Spotify
die Steady Abos alle übrigens hören, also unseren auch.
Und wer bei Apple ist und es bequem haben möchte und jetzt nicht extra zu Steady
rüberwandern will, kann auch über Apple sofort den Podcast buchen, also den Salon buchen.
Und dann gibt es auch noch für diejenigen, die bei Patreon schon sind,
die Möglichkeit, das über Patreon zu buchen, aber wir würden empfehlen,
dass jetzt nicht extra jemand ein Patreon-Konto anlegt, sondern dann lieber zu steady geht,
das ist ein Berliner Unternehmen, das sich auch sehr gut um uns kümmert,
beziehungsweise sagen wir eher, es muss nicht sich um uns kümmern,
weil es eigentlich keine Probleme gibt und wenn es aber Probleme gibt beim RSS-Feed
oder so, kann man sich direkt dann steady wenden und dann helfen die einem sehr schnell weiter.
Also vielen Dank, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert.
So ist es.
Dann springen wir zum Krieg, springen wir erst ganz kurz in dieses Thema Streumunition
hinein. Wir hören ganz kurz den Bundespräsidenten.
Was Streumunition angeht, müssen Sie verstehen, ich bin da befangen.
Ich war derjenige, der für unser Land die Ächtung der Streumunition damals in
Oslo unterschrieben hat und deshalb finde ich, ist die deutsche Position nach
wie vor richtig, sich gegen Streumunition auszusprechen.
Sie kann in der gegenwärtigen Situation der USA nicht in den Arm fallen.
Das ist ja wohl das albernste Statement, das wurde ja schon vielfach kritisiert.
Ich finde es auch, wenn man es immer wieder hört. Ich bin da befangen.
Ja, was denn? Wir haben halt eine Dings unterzeichnet, dass wir das ächten wollen.
Ja, Hans hat dann im Aufwärmen Podcast gesagt, es gibt ja keine Teilzeitächtung.
Und das ist ja das Prinzip von Ächtung, dass man da nicht plötzlich, ah, jetzt wo es...
Eigentlich habe ich was gegen Gabeln, außer wenn ich esse. Ja,
das ist doch Quatsch. Also da muss man konsequent sein oder nicht?
Befangenheit ist ja das völlig falsche Wort. Befangenheit ist ja,
wenn man da irgendwie so persönlich ein bisschen drin ist. So,
wissen Sie, ich habe da irgendwie drei Tanten im Krieg verloren an Streumunition,
deswegen bin ich befangen.
Befangen wäre, wenn ein Wahlkreis damals gehabt hätte, wo die hergestellt werden
und die suchen jetzt mal wieder ein Business oder so.
Ja, dann ist man befangen. Aber man ist ja nicht befangen, wenn man das gemacht
hat. Dann hat man das ja aus irgendeinem Grund, aus einem politischen oder moralischen einmal so getan.
Küppers-Busch kommentiert das sehr schön.
Ja, vielleicht müsste Frank-Walter Steinmeier mal in dieses Abkommen von Oslo
die Konvention, die er mit verhandelt und dann eben sozusagen beispielhaft für
die vielen Nationen, die sich dem anschlossen, unterschrieben hat.
Artikel 21, Absatz 2 der Oslo-Konvention.
Jeder Vertragsstaat bemüht sich nach besten Kräften, Staaten,
die nicht Vertragsstaaten dieses Übereinkommens sind, vom Einsatz von Streumunition abzubringen.
Es geht also nicht nur darum, dass wir das nicht haben und nicht einsetzen und
nicht weitergeben sollten, sondern auch ein missionarischer Ansatz,
eine globale Geltung der Ächtung von Streumunition.
Ja, und wie Steinmeier nun sagt, man kann ja den Amis nicht in den Arm fallen.
Das ist schon deutlich zu wenig.
Wenn in letzter Zeit so viel die Rede davon ist, dass Deutschland die Führung
übernehmen solle, dann besteht Führung offenbar daraus, dass man selbst wieder
besseres Wissen einfach abnickt, was die Amerikaner sagen.
Tja, und so lassen wir das mal stehen. Das genügt erst einmal.
Ich hatte ein Thread gesehen, bei Twitter hast du das auch gehabt,
wo der, ich glaube es war Pia Lamberti, die hat uns den Begriff Reaktanz erklärt.
Da ging es darum, dass sehr viele Leute irgendwie gegen Masken oder gegen Impfung
waren oder jetzt trotzdem den Klimawandel immer noch ignorieren wollen.
Und da gibt es wohl einen Begriff Reaktanz, dass man sich mit einem kindlichen Trotz dagegenstellt.
Und das ist sicherlich eine Beobachtung, die stimmt. Aber ...
Das gibt es auch zum Thema Sträuben-Hominid-Tumor.
Nein, nein. Aber ich will jetzt überleiten, ich stelle ja auch bei mir diesen kindlichen Trotz fest.
Nicht bei Impfungen, sondern dann, wenn mit mir gesprochen wird,
als sei ich ein kleines Kind. Dann muss ich ja auch trotzig reagieren.
Und das ist das große Problem im Übrigen vieler, die dann da ganz drauf angesprungen sind.
Und ich würde auch zum Teil Pia Lamberti zum Vorwurf machen, dass immer mit so einer,
Ja, paternalistischen Geste mit einem gesprochen wird, so als sei man selbst
noch nicht so ganz, noch nicht so weit.
Ich muss dann noch so mitkommen. Ich weiß nicht, so redet man vielleicht mit
sieben, acht, neunjährigen, aber die reagieren dann auch mitunter sehr,
sehr bockig oder trotzig, also mit Reaktanz.
Also muss man sich was Clevereres ausdenken, damit es funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich super interessant, weil gerade Pia Lamberti,
die hat ja mit Katharina Locke dieses Buch Verschwörungsmythen hier und da und
wie geht man eigentlich mit Fake News um?
Und da ist ja immer so diese Idee, Leute, die mit so Vorstellungen,
es gibt da noch im Hintergrund, im Latenten, im Verborgenen und den müsste man ja mal und so weiter.
Und die Antwort gerade über diese Reaktanzschiene ist ja dann genau dieselbe.
Die sind noch nicht genug aufgeklärt, den müssen wir noch mehr und so weiter,
bis sie dann diesen Dreh hinkriegen zu ... Nee, ist eigentlich diese Beziehungsgestaltung
selbst. Also man kann's nicht auf der Sachabschiene.
Und das haben sie ja im Buch eigentlich deutlich. Deswegen finde ich das erstaunlich,
dass dann auf Twitter es doch wieder umkippt in dieses didaktische Format.
Wenn du mit, äh, Opfern falschem Denken reden willst, dann mach es so, dass du ihnen ...
Und was soll das dann sein? Also waffengleich, ja, die haben ja eh schon die
Vorstellung, dass da noch was im Hintergrund, im Verborgenen und so weiter.
Dann bediene das doch und leg so natschig-mäßig irgendwie so noch eine Schippe
drauf oder was. Also verrückt.
Ja, und wenn man sich auch diesen Streumunitionen-Diskurs ansieht,
dann ist der nicht so geführt, als sei man an einer tatsächlichen Aufklärung interessiert.
Zum Beispiel hat die die die linken Vorsitzende Amira Mohammed Ali geschrieben.
Bei Twitter ist Streumunition jetzt Teil dieser wertebasierten Außenpolitik des Westens, fragt sie.
Und dann schreibt Carlo Marsala natürlich sofort darüber, da es Werten entspricht,
dass kein Land ein anderes vernichten darf, dass Menschen nicht von Aggressoren
gefoltert, nicht vergewaltigt und nicht deportiert werden dürfen und territoriale
Integrität und Souveränität ein schützenswerter Wert sind, könnte die Antwort Ja lauten. Also...
Er sagt, ja, die Russen wollen ja die Ukrainer vernichten. Das ist seine These.
Deswegen ist alles erlaubt, um dagegen vorzugehen. Aber dann,
und ich habe das zum Teil bei Funkredakteuren gelesen, die noch sagen,
ja, Napalm geht auch, wenn das den Aggressor zurückdrängt. Also man hat eine völlige Entgrenzung.
Oder man könnte mit Oppenheimer sagen, eine Kettenreaktion. Und es wird mit
Argumenten vorgebracht, die bei mir nur Reaktanz auslösen können.
Weil hier werde ich ja für dumm verkauft. Also das kann ich ja nicht ernst nehmen.
Also wenn man sich auf diesen Werte-Kanon-Wettlauf nach unten mit den Russen einlässt,
dann ist ja das russische Angebot seit gestern, dass man sogar Nothilfe-Essen
über die UN organisiert, mittlerweile mit einem Veto belegt.
Wenn im Niger oder so, oder anderen afrikanischen Ländern da Sachen drohen.
Und in diesen Wettlauf will man ja wirklich nicht einsteigen.
Also das verstehe ich gar nicht.
Ja, und Reaktanz kommt dann bei mir auch zum Tragen,
wenn Baerbock in Vilnius ist, beim NATO-Gipfel und nochmal gefragt wird,
wie sieht es dann aus mit Verhandlungen oder irgendetwas.
Weil das, was sie jeden Tag sich aufs Ähnlichste wünschen, ist Frieden.
Und das liegt aber allein in den Händen des russischen Präsidenten.
Dieser Krieg könnte morgen zu Ende sein, wenn der russische Präsident diese
brutalen Bombardierung einstellt und genau darüber wird jetzt in diesen Minuten,
in diesen Stunden auch mit dem ukrainischen Präsidenten natürlich gesprochen.
Dieser Gipfel ist zur Unterstützung der Ukraine da und das wird auch das Ergebnis dieses Gipfels sein.
Also Ergebnis ist schon vorweggenommen. Man spricht mit.
Selenskyj darüber, dass Putin aufhören soll, verstehe ich schon gar nicht.
Also wenn, da müsste man ja mit Putin darüber sprechen, dass Putin aufhört.
Aber Selenskyj würde ja wahrscheinlich auch sagen, er müsste aufhören.
Und zu sagen einfach, naja, der müsste ja nur aufhören.
Ich meine, das kann ich natürlich so sagen. Und ja, das wäre toll,
wenn er das machen würde, aber das ist auch so in den Wind gesagt.
Vor allem, wir wissen doch, warum Putin nicht aufhört, also was das auch für
ihn bedeuten würde und dadurch, das kann man ja einpreisen in die eigene Debattenführung
und dann einfach ehrlich damit umgehen.
Wir hören noch mal Küppersbusch zum Thema Verhandlungen.
Man kann sich nur noch mal auf der Hirnrinde zergehen lassen,
wie die deutsche Außenministerin ungefähr monatlich bekannt gibt,
mit dem Russen gibt es nichts zu verhandeln.
Ungefähr monatlich mit dem Russen verhandelt wird. Die Getreideabkommen und
die Gefangenenaustauschabkommen hat auch an ihrer Stadt der Menschenrechtsaktivist Erdogan verhandelt.
Und die bagen immerhin Hoffnung, sowohl, dass man überhaupt verhandeln kann,
was die Nahrungsmittel angeht, den Gefangenenaustausch und die Not im Krieg.
Es gibt nämlich Verhandlungen, aber es gibt nicht die Verhandlungen jetzt zum
Frieden hin, aber es wird schon miteinander gesprochen.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, gehen wir mal aus diesem Direktpolitischen raus und
lassen mal wieder jemand aus dem Militär zu Wort kommen.
Und zwar Markus Reisner ist allen, glaube ich, inzwischen bekannt.
Das ist der Oberst aus Österreich, der sehr, sehr gut erklären kann,
was sich im Krieg tut, wie da Frontverläufe sind.
Und er war in einem Podcast zu Gast, den ich vorher nicht kannte.
Der heißt Recht politisch von Ralf Jarnik.
Und dort gibt er ein ganz, ganz erstaunliches Interview.
Und dieser Podcast ist eine Stunde lang. Und alle Clips, die wir jetzt hören,
sind aus den ersten zehn Minuten. So dicht ist das.
Der Historiker hat oft die negative Angewohnheit, eine Dinge so zu erklären,
als wenn das damals bei dem stattfindenden Ereignis ist schon alles klar war,
warum das so geschehen ist, aber das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Wir werden erst in 15, 15 Jahren möglicherweise Aufklärung haben über viele
Dinge, die wir jetzt gar nicht wissen oder die im Hintergrund geschehen sind.
Damit beginnt er erst mal zu sagen, wir wissen ganz viel eigentlich nicht und
im Nachhinein klingt das immer so, als hätte man es gewusst,
ist aber nicht der Fall. Und jetzt kommen Parallelen. Wie ist denn das mit Verhandlungen?
Er, Reisner, hat ja immer wieder jetzt auch in Interviews gesagt,
es tut sich da relativ wenig.
Diese Offensive sorgt mal dafür, dass man ein Dorf gewonnen wird,
eins verloren wird, es geht paar Kilometer weiter, paar Kilometer zurück mit
extrem hohen Verlusten, das heißt mit sehr vielen toten Menschen.
Und er bringt jetzt erstmal das,
was wir auch schon von Mark Milley gehört haben, den ersten Weltkrieg.
Und wenn man jetzt den Konflikt betrachtet, dann sieht man, dass zwar Geschichte
sich nicht wiederholt, aber es sehr oft ähnlichen Mustern folgt.
Und wir sehen also auch in diesem
Konflikt immer wieder Parallelen zu Konflikten aus der Vergangenheit.
Und ich selbst versuche auch immer ein bisschen zur Erklärung einen Vergleich
mit dem ersten Weltkrieg anzustellen.
Nicht jetzt, weil die Rahmenbedingungen ähnliche waren, die waren natürlich
unterschiedlich, aber das Stimmungsbild damals war sehr ähnlich.
Also 1914 die Euphorie nach dem Schock des Kriegsausbruchs, wir schaffen das in kurzer Zeit.
1915 das Jahr der Ernüchterung, wo man gesehen hat, all die Annahmen die man
getroffen hat stimmen so nicht.
Und dann das Jahr 1916, das Jahr der elenden Offensiven, wo hunderttausende
gefallen sind, aber eigentlich kaum ist ein Durchbruch gekommen ist.
Und man weiß, dass damals schon eigentlich versucht worden ist die ersten Fühler
hinsichtlich von Friedensverhandlungen auszustrecken und dann hat dieser Krieg
noch einmal zwei Jahre gedauert.
Der Unterschied zwischen heute und damals von vor über 100 Jahren ist,
dass es die ganzen Regeln nicht gab.
Weshalb dieses unendliche Schlachten inklusive Chemiewaffen und so weiter und so fort.
Und während jetzt ja die Streumunition geliefert war, hatten wir gleichzeitig
die Nachrichtenlage, dass die Amerikaner ihre allerletzten Chemiewaffen vernichtet
haben. Und zwar zivil vernichtet und nicht einfach auf Kriegsgebiet verwendet.
Und das jetzt wieder aufzuweichen durch, eigentlich haben wir es schon geächtet,
aber und so weiter. Und selbst die Ächtung mit der Streumunition hat so schon
ein paar Kriege gedauert.
Also da könnte man ja auch sagen, da hat man also ernsthaft drüber nachgedacht.
Das ist so auch so ein Pragmatismus und so ein Praxis Erkenntnis.
Verfahren ist man dazu gekommen zu sagen, wir ächten es jetzt mal wirklich und
so weiter und so fort. Und dass man da jetzt auch auf dieser politischen Ebene
wieder so einen Zustand 1914, 15.
Naja, wenn uns die Regeln stören, räumen wir sie eben ab, weil es ist halt Krieg
und so. Das geht wirklich in die falsche Richtung.
Oder das Argument kommt dann, Stefan, du hast dich ja nie öffentlich gegen die
Verwendung von Streumunition seitens der Russen positioniert.
Und da würde ich sagen, naja, das muss man auch nicht, weil das ja ohnehin klar
ist, dass man dagegen ist. Also ich muss ja auch nicht jedes Mal den Podcast
hier beginnen und sagen, ich bin dagegen, was in Nordkorea passiert.
Deswegen, also das muss ich ja nicht jedes Mal nochmal unterstreichen.
Und das ist ja vollkommen klar, dass das Niveau, was Völkerrecht und all das
anbelangt, nach unten abgesenkt wird von Putin und zwar kontinuierlich.
Also, dass wir das Putin nicht durchgehen lassen können, zeigt ja,
dass wir diesen Krieg führen und es sind ja nun auch unsere Steuergelder und
alles, was dazugehört, was da mit im Einsatz ist.
Ja, ich war ganz verblüfft, dass Rudi Bachmann,
der ja Hardliner im Kurs ist, wir müssen die Ukraine unterstützen,
diesen Kurs nicht verlassen hat, aber plötzlich ein bisschen so klingt,
wie das, was wir auch schon mal gespielt hatten von Marina Weisband vor Monaten,
wo man sich fragte, was machen die USA eigentlich mit den Ukrainern da?
Und Rudi Bachmann, ich zitiere ihn jetzt mal hier wortwörtlich,
hat dann längeren Thread geschrieben und sagt, dass man auch dem Westen immer Vorwerfen wird.
Es ging ja auch darum, NATO-Mitgliedschaft und all das.
Es wird also immer Vorwerfen der Ukrainen, nie eine richtige Chance gegeben zu haben.
Legenden werden sich bilden, die nicht gut für das Standing des Westens sein werden.
Und jetzt kommt's, cooking the frog to me makes no sense.
Es verlängert nur das Leiden der Ukrainer.
Verstehe da auch die beiden Administration nicht mehr. Es sieht inzwischen fast
so aus, als sei sie, die Ukraine,
Also ob sie die Ukraine dazu benutzen, das russische Arsenal langsam abzuschleifen.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, das haben wir schon mal besprochen.
Das haben wir vor vielen Monaten so gesagt, aber manchmal brauchen Erkenntnisse
länger, weil es ist gut. Also ich will das jetzt gar nicht sarkastisch kommentieren,
sondern ich würde sagen, ich finde es erst mal sinnvoll, dass es erkannt wird.
Wir haben ja gerade so eine Situation, in der Twitter eh in so ein Schlachtfeld
verwandelt wird. Also Masala ganz vorn heran.
Rudi Bachmann ja eigentlich auch. Ja, natürlich. Wenn das aber bedeutet,
dass wir jetzt wenigstens auf Twitter so eine Art Diskurs oder Meinungsbeitrag mal lesen,
denn das sind ja auch Meinungen, die hat jetzt Weißmann da damals bei Hard Aber
Fair oder so oder Ilna gesagt.
Aber so richtig durchkommentiert haben wir das ja nicht jetzt auf irgendwelchen
Zeitungsseiten zum Beispiel.
Nee, leider nicht. Und auch dieser Threat ist dann nicht sonderlich erfolgreich.
Da kommt man natürlich mit Hurra, Patriotismus und so weiter.
Aber reden wir mal nicht über den Ersten Weltkrieg. Es gibt ja noch ganz andere
Kriege, in denen auch lange verhandelt wurde. Nochmal Reisner.
Und weil auch jetzt viele das Szenario von Nord- und Südkorea bringen,
auch hier ist ganz interessant.
Es hat zwei Jahre gedauert und 575 Verhandlungstage, um ein 40-seitiges Dokument
zu beschließen, das dann die Basis war für den Waffenstillstand,
der dann in Nord- und Südkorea eingenommen worden ist.
Das heißt, der Krieg wird vermutlich noch länger dauern.
Ja, und auch die Nord- und Südkorea-Lage hat jetzt ihr 70-jähriges Jubiläum
gefeiert, also in letzter Woche.
Das sind alles sehr langwierige Prozesse.
Ja, mit vielen, vielen Toten. Es geht aber noch viel länger.
Eine noch beunruhigendere Parallele ist ja Iran-Irak, da haben wir sogar acht Jahre.
Genau, das ist also auch ein gutes Beispiel, wo also beide Seiten,
auch aufgrund der nicht enden wollenden Unterstützung aus dem Hintergrund in der Lage waren,
diesen Abnutzungskrieg über lange Zeit zu führen und überzeugt waren,
sie können ihn gewinnen und dann es sehr lange gedauert hat,
bis dann wirklich die Abnutzung so groß war auf beiden Seiten,
dass man sich erzwungenermaßen hingesetzt hat und am Verhandlungstisch zumindest
ein gewisses Einkommen getroffen hat.
Also für Reisner ist das Thema Abnutzungsregel gar nicht mehr etwas,
was man in Frage stellen muss, sondern das verwendet man ja...
Ja, steht im Handbuch, Seite 3 schon.
Ja, und so heißt es dann auch weiter?
Die Herausforderung, die sich hier ergibt, ist, dass wir hier nicht nur einen Konflikt haben,
der regional begrenzt ist, wo also zwei Staaten gegeneinander kämpfen mit den
Ressourcen, die sie haben, sondern wir haben hier einen Konflikt,
der eigentlich eine Trennlinie zeigt zwischen dem, was wir immer mehr als auch
den globalen Norden und den globalen Süden bezeichnen.
Der Moderator stellt dann die richtige Frage.
Ein anderer Faktor, der dabei immer erwähnt wird, ist der Faktor Mensch.
Irgendwann gehen dann doch die Menschen aus. Und jetzt ganz plump Milchmädchenrechnung.
Die Ukraine hat einfach mehr als ein Drittel weniger, das heißt hier gehen die
Menschen unter anderen Stichen schneller aus als Russland, kann man diese plumpe Rechnung anstellen?
Nun, wenn man das jetzt wirklich herunterbricht, jetzt rein auf die Quantität
der verfügbaren Soldaten,
dann ist es natürlich korrekt zu sagen, dass auf der einen Seite 145 Millionen
Menschen mit einem gewissen Wehrpotenzial vorhanden sind und auf der anderen
Seite 35 Millionen Menschen, wenn man die Geflüchteten bereits wegrechnet,
mit einem gewissen Wehrpotenzial.
Und wenn beide Seiten immer bereit sind, dieses Wehrpotenzial an die Front zu
schicken, ist es eine reine numerische Rechnung, wie lange sich das ausgeht.
Diese reine numerische Rechnung ist natürlich heute eine sehr zynische,
wird einem dann überall vorgehalten, aber am Ende ist das eben die Realität auf dem...
So agieren ja die Politiker. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die sich sentimental irgendwo
hinsetzen und überlegen, was zu tun ist, sondern sie haben ja genau diese Zahlen vor Augen.
Das ist ja gerade das Scheußliche an einem Krieg, dass in dieser Weise über
Menschen nachgedacht wird, dass sie dann nur noch Beflügungsmasse sind.
Und weiter heißt es dann noch?
Es wird jetzt von verschiedenen Experten ins Feld gebracht, man kann das ja
nicht reiner der Quantität ausmachen, sondern man muss ja auch die Qualität hier ins Feld ziehen.
Also das ist dann im Prinzip der Umstand, dass man feststellt,
naja der ukrainische Soldat ist qualitativ ja hochwertiger aufgrund der besseren
Ausbildung, aufgrund vor allem der Moral als der russische Soldat.
Das ist natürlich ein Faktor, der eine Rolle spielen kann, aber auch hier ist
trotz alledem vorherrschend der Umstand, dass erst dann der Krieg zu Ende sein
wird, wenn eine der beiden Seiten nicht mehr bereit ist, diese Menschen,
und da sind sie ja, als Soldaten an die Front zu schicken.
Und das kann niemand sagen, wie lange man das bereit ist zu tun,
auch auf der ukrainischen Seite.
Zurzeit hat die Ukraine ganz klar gesagt, sie werden nicht aufhören und sie
werden weitermachen. Das heißt, sie werden immer neue Verbände aufstellen,
Soldaten gliedern, ausbilden und an die Front schicken.
Und das geht so lange weiter, wie die Demografie das erlaubt.
So lange geht das weiter. Er sagt nicht, das geht dann weiter,
das muss noch das und das erobert werden und dann ist der Krieg zu Ende,
sondern es geht eigentlich dann zu Ende, wenn die Demografie Grenzen setzt oder
man beschließt, jetzt nicht noch mehr Menschen.
Das bedeutet aber im Umkehrschluss auch, dass alle die sagen,
es muss jetzt die Ukraine gewinnen, sagen eigentlich auch, es müssen jetzt doch
nochmal sehr viele Menschen sterben.
Und dessen sollte man sich mal so ganz bewusst sein. Er macht das in dem in
dem ganzen Gespräch kommt er immer wieder darauf.
Und das ist ja hier kein Pazifist. Er ist zum Beispiel auch dafür,
dass Österreich sich mehr einbringt und auch sich erkenntlich zeigt,
was die NATO für Österreich tut und sowas. Also der ist ja jetzt hier nicht
eine Friedenstaube, die wir hören.
Aber heuristisch macht er echt das gute Angebot. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei
Oppenheimer, Nolan ist ja auch immer so beeindruckt, dass wo wir Materie sehen,
sehen die Physiker immer Energie und das ist aber nur so ein Istgleich dazwischen
und dann kann man da hin und her wendeln.
Und so ist das ja hier auch. Wir betonen immer, der Panzer fährt über ein Gebiet
und hat dann Kilometer erobert, aber eigentlich geht es nicht um Regionen,
sondern es geht um die Menschen.
Und das sind zwei Seiten der gleichen Gleichung und man muss einfach nur die
andere Seite mal in den Blick nehmen.
Und er sagt auch sehr schön dann mit den Panzern, mit einzelnen Dingen,
die geliefert wurden, warum die so wenig effektiv waren, warum das eigentlich
nur im Konzert mit anderen Dingen funktioniert hätte und so nicht funktionieren
konnte. Und er hat das sehr früh dann auch immer in seinen Videos herausgestellt.
Und das kann man also alles nochmal nachhören in diesem Podcast recht politisch.
Nur noch einen Clip, den habe ich tatsächlich jetzt aus dem Ende des Gesprächs.
Da wagt Reißner sich, meines Erachtens nochmal sehr weit hervor,
wenn er sagt wir können natürlich alle nur hoffen, trotz aller Themen,
dass dieser Konflikt nicht rasch ein Ende findet. Warum?
Egal wie er ausgeht, weil er aufgrund des Umstandes, dass er endet,
einfach das Sterben und Leiden aufhört. Das ist der Punkt.
Egal wie er endet. Also das finde ich schon ganz erstaunlich,
dass er da sogar so weit geht und das sagt...
Ein Schrecken ohne Ende oder ein Ende mit Schrecken.
Ja, kann man auch hier wieder stellen diese Frage. Ja, so viel zum Krieg von mir.
Sollen wir ein ebenso ernstes Thema uns zu Gemüte führen, das Thema Suizidhilfe.
Ja, wir können das so ein bisschen verkoppeln. Du redest jetzt über Suizidhilfe
und danach reden wir über Ernährungspolitik.
Nee, dann lass uns erst über Ernährungspolitik vielleicht reden.
Denn ich denke, ich versuche jetzt einfach, dass meine Argumentation besser
wird, in der Dramaturgie.
Wir reden über Ernährungspolitik jetzt, Stefan, damit wir dann den Staat hier
erst mal erleben, was er so vorhat oder was er dann jetzt nicht umsetzen kann.
Du musst erst mal erklären, ich habe es kaum verfolgt.
Ich habe immer wieder irgendwelche Kommentare in konservativen Zeitungen gelesen, Bevormundung etc.
Wollen wir nicht. Die Kinder sollen Zucker essen. Genau. Noch und nöcher.
Klingt zum Beispiel bei Markus Söder so.
Es soll also ein Verbot kommen von Süßigkeiten. Werbung mit der Begründung,
wir müssen die Kinder schützen vor Süßigkeiten.
Meine Grundsatzfrage, was Kinder essen, der entscheidet es eigentlich.
Wieso muss das Funktionäre entscheiden?
Warum dürfen die Eltern nicht in erster Linie entscheiden, was Kinder essen sollen?
Wir wollen da das Elternrecht an erster Stelle und nicht irgendwelche verhungerten
grünen Funktionäre, die den Eltern einreden, was sie essen, was sie bestellen
und was sie den Kindern kaufen dürfen, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde.
Verhungerte grüne Funktionäre.
Der Markus Söder hat diesen Clip von sich im Mai getwittert.
Er kommt aber vom politischen Aschermittwoch, das ist ja irgendwann im Februar
oder so. Und wir haben jetzt Juli.
Und jetzt im Juli stand ja Cem Özdemir wieder da, hat so ein Glas hochgehalten,
zwei Zuckerwürfel drin und meinte, das ist das, was wir den Kindern zu trinken
geben, wenn wir nicht darauf achten und so weiter. Und wir achten halt nicht
drauf und er möchte das ändern.
Wir haben also hier eine nicht vorhandene Entwicklung in einer politischen Diskussion,
die, und das ist jetzt die Frage,
Auch weilst du eben meintest, ich habe nichts davon verfolgt.
Ja, was denn verfolgt? Gibt es eigentlich eine Diskussion zum Thema Ernährung
und so weiter? Ja. Und da würde ich sagen, nee, jetzt gerade nicht.
Sondern jetzt haben wir nur noch, dass Jim Özdemir versucht,
Zuckerwerbung zu verbieten. Also nicht den Zucker selbst, sondern nur die Werbung
für den Zucker. Ja. Also, oder sagen wir mal so, Ernährungs- oder Nahrungsmittel,
in denen zu viel Zucker drin ist. Also nach...
Wie auch Zigarettenwerbung... Ja, einfach mal... Verboten ist,
ich weiß gar nicht wo überhaupt noch Zigarettenwerbung sein darf,
im Fernsehen jedenfalls nicht mehr, im Kino ist es auch stark eingeschränkt oder ganz verboten.
Also es ist extrem eingeschränkt.
Genau, also gibt's alles, wurde ausgeräumt, die Zigaretten sind aber noch da.
Und so geht's auch hier, also eigentlich wird gar nicht materiell auf dem Tisch
was verändert, es wird auch kein Verbot ausgesprochen, es ist auch keins geplante,
wie auch immer, sondern es geht nur um und so.
Und so. Und ich dachte mir, nachdem ich ja im Januar, Februar,
März immer darauf kam, ich würde gerne über Ernährung sprechen,
weil kam immer nicht dazu, dass wir jetzt in diesem Sommerloch einfach diesen
Sargnagel einschlagen.
Es wird keine funktionierende Ernährungspolitik geben.
Schon allein, haben wir ja bei Markus Sitter gehört, das wird dann auch wieder
interessant für mein Familienbuch,
weil einfach den Eltern plötzlich so das Elternrecht da angedichtet wird,
wo es, mag es geben, aber wo es dann plötzlich heißt, ja, das ist ja die Hoheit der Eltern.
Da soll ja der Staat sich gar nicht einmischen.
Und da stehen natürlich alle daneben und sagen, ja, Applaus,
ich möchte gerne selber entscheiden, wie ich mit meinen Kindern umgehe oder
was auch immer da getriggert wird.
Weshalb wir jetzt zurückblicken auf die Ernährungsdiskussion,
wie sie nämlich zum Jahresanfang im Bundestag stattfand, nachdem ja Özdemir
große Aufschläge gemacht hat, mit Tagungen in seinem Ministerium im Dezember.
60 Amtskollegen aus der ganzen Welt waren zugegen. Das haben wir ja alles gar
nicht so richtig mitbekommen. Es waren Kurzmeldungen in den Nachrichten.
Also der große Aufschlag war eigentlich da.
Also wir beginnen in dieser Zeit und hören uns Nina Wolf an, die von Is This Food?
Dings, da wumms, na, hören wir gleich. Die sich und die uns genug Anlass gibt,
die Dimension des Themas einfach mal, und zwar immer unter der Maßgabe,
dass jetzt aussortiert wurde, die Dimension des Themas zumindest mal zu verstehen.
Also, Östemir im Fernsehen zum Jahresende.
Schauen Sie, ich komme selber aus einer Arbeiterfamilie. Ernährungsminister
Cem Östemir wird persönlich, als er seinen Vorstoß im Frühstücksfernsehen vorstellt.
Ich weiß, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn die Schule eine Vormittagsschule ist von
Currywurst und von Pommes, so habe ich jahrelang gelebt.
So habe ich jahrelang gelegt. Ich bin betroffen, ich bin ihr,
ihr seid alle betroffen. Wir kennen das Phänomen alle. Und dann die Gegenseite damals.
Es geht erst mal um weniger Salz, weniger Zucker, weniger Fett,
mehr pflanzenbasierte Ernährung, damit Sie auch den Geschmack lieben lernen
von unseren großartigen Produkten und sich gleichzeitig noch gesund ernähren
und Spaß machen darf es auch.
Zum Beispiel dafür setze ich mich ein. Wenig Spaß verspürt bei dem Gedanken
Albert Stegemann, ernährungspolitischer Sprecher der Unionsbundestagsfraktion
und ausgebildeter Milchbauer.
Das haben wir schon mal thematisiert, als wir die Agrarwende oder Agrarpolitik,
die siebenjährige Planung da, hier reden immer Lobbyisten mitten im Bundestagsmandat.
Also in der Ernährungsbranche sitzen die im Bundestag, die müssen gar niemanden
lobbyieren, die sind selber, bilden die den Agrarausschuss und so weiter und
so fort. Also er ist selber einer dieser Milchbauer.
Da würde man sagen, ich bin befangen.
Da würde man eigentlich sagen, ich bin befangen. Wenn ich im Bundestag sitze
und die Tagesordnung im Agrarausschuss festlege, während ich in meinem Hauptberuf
Chef einer Molkerei mit Milliardenumsatz bin, bin ich befangen.
Es führt keinen Weg dran vorbei.
Sie werden gefragt als Bundestagsabgeordneter von der CDU. Sein Statement zum
Thema gesunde Ernährung ist wie folgt.
In der Analyse sei man sich einig, es sei erschreckend, wie stark das Übergewicht
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen wachse.
Mit verboten aber kommen wir mal nicht weiter, sondern mit Ernährungsbildung.
Also es geht am Ende darum zu verstehen,
was führt zu Übergewicht und ganz sicherlich dürfen wir auch das Thema Sport
nicht aus dem Auge verlieren,
weil nur durch eine vernünftige Kombination aus Bewegung, aus Sport und aus
Ernährungsbildung wird am Ende tatsächlich auch ein Ziel erreicht werden können,
um zu einer gesunderen Ernährung zu kommen.
Sport und Bildung. Also ich empfehle an der Stelle noch mal ...
Bei Thilo nachzuhören, der hatte vor ein paar Jahren den Allianz-Chef da,
Bäthe, der ihm noch mal sagte, ja klar, es gibt so die eine oder andere Ahnung,
die man so hat, aber wir haben es ja durchgerechnet. Wir versichern ja die Leute
mit privaten Krankenversicherungen und so weiter.
Und bei uns war dann der Tenor, Sport kann auch eine Rolle spielen,
aber Ernährung ist es eigentlich.
Also wenn wir die Leute versichern und die Versicherungshöhe und so weiter alles
mit denen klären, dann spielt Sport 5 Prozent eine Rolle und deren Ernährungsverhalten ergibt den Rest.
Also egal, das ist ja auch ein Ernährungskompass vom Basskast,
ich dachte, ich bin total sportlich, weil ich gehe doch immer joggen,
zack, Herzkasper und so weiter und dann, ah nee, die Ernährung war's.
Wenn ich abends eine Tüte Chips esse, habe ich eine Tüte Chips gegessen,
egal, was ich sonst noch in meinem Leben mache, also dann bin ich einfach verseucht.
Gut, Sie haben damals, Ende des Jahres, aus Anlass dieser Kontroverse mit Nina Wolf gesprochen.
Wir hören vier Clips davon, sie kennt sich, denke ich, aus und zeigt uns mal
die Tragweite Ernährungsproblems insgesamt, die politische Dimension und was
wir eigentlich machen könnten müssten.
Wir haben das Aufsetzen der Strategie sehr aufmerksam verfolgt und sehen,
dass jetzt erstmal positiv, dass ein grober Umriss der Strategie,
die ja erst noch erarbeitet werden muss, nun vorliegt.
Das ist aus unserer Sicht ein erster Aufschlag und man muss positiver vorheben,
dass dieser Aufschlag der Komplexität der Probleme gerecht wird,
die die Erzeugung von Lebensmitteln und auch unsere Ernährungsweise verursachen,
ob es ja das Klima ist oder die Biodiversität, Ernährungsarmut oder ernährungsbedingte
Krankheiten wie Adipositas, Diabetes oder einige Formen von Krebs.
Die Umstellung unserer Ernährung ist ein ganz wichtiger Schlüssel zur Lösung
vieler drängender Krisen.
Wer ist jetzt Nina Wolf?
Ich versuche es gerade noch mal rauszugoogeln, Foodwatch oder so,
einer dieser großen, die dann Fischereiexperten, Slow Food, irgendwas.
Ich finde es noch mal raus, in der Zeit, in der wir Clips hören,
Foodwatch, es könnte Foodwatch sein.
Also im Kosmos dieser politischen Beobachtung, die hier stattfindet,
wo man … Und sie koppelt das ja jetzt auch an die Krisen. An alle Krisen unserer Welt. An alle Krisen.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht nur die individuelle Krise, ich tue meinem Körper
was Böses an, sondern auch der Welt.
Da gibt es ja eh diese große Strömung der Planetary Health,
das finde ich ja alles immer sehr eingängig irgendwie, wenn man zu viel Fleisch
isst, hat man auch gleichzeitig zu viel Wasserverbrauch auf der Welt und dann
führt das eben zu dem einen oder anderen Versagen, dass man dann wieder politisch gerade biegen muss.
Nunja, die Beiräte der Regierung sitzen also da.
Es sind schon erhebliche Milliardenbeträge, die da in die Hand genommen werden müssten.
Aber es gibt ja auch Möglichkeiten, dieses Geld zu generieren,
beispielsweise durch eine neue Ausgestaltung des Steuersystems im Bereich der Lebensmittel,
in dem die Ziele der Strategie, nämlich für gesunde und nachhaltige Lebensmittel
zu sorgen, im Steuersystem sich abbilden.
Dass man ungesunde und nicht nachhaltige Lebensmittel einfach teurer macht und
dadurch Geld generiert.
Das hat der wissenschaftliche Beirat des Ministeriums alles sehr schön ausgerechnet.
Da gibt es gute Möglichkeiten, da müsste das Ministerium beziehungsweise die
Bundesregierung, und da liegt möglicherweise die Krux, da nochmal nachbessern.
Ja, ne Steuerform...
Die da irgendwie eingreift. Also wir sehen ja, wie weit Diskussionen gedeihen
zum Thema Ernährungssicherheit grundsätzlich.
Mehrwertsteuer im Supermarkt und so weiter. Das ist ja Null Bewegung,
wo alle Welt irgendwie in diese Richtung geht.
Nichts davon von der Bundesregierung. Also da ist schon mal kein Weg.
Wir hören also bei ihr einfach noch zu, dass sie nochmal diese Grundsätzlichkeit des Themas umrahmt.
Ein Genießen, ein Genuss ohne Verantwortung, das ist kein Genuss.
Und ja, die Grünen haben den Veggie Day, die SPD hat den Currywurstkomplex.
Das sind Debatten, die hatten wir in der Vergangenheit. Aber ich glaube,
das Gute tragen in die Gesellschaft hinein.
Worüber reden wir eigentlich? Das ist das Grundsatzthema unserer Zeit.
Ernährung, das ist so ein großer Hebel, mit dem wir viel bewirken können.
Und das muss allseits verstanden werden.
Eine Ernährungsstrategie muss dahin führen, dass Ernährung nicht mehr vom Geldbeutel
oder vom Bildungsgrad abhängt oder auch davon, in welchem Stadtteil Menschen leben.
Ein ungesunder Ernährungstil kostet den Staat so viel Geld, dass er das höchste
Interesse daran haben sollte, Lebensmittelpreise so zu gestalten,
dass Menschen damit auch.
Zurechtkommen Das ist ja so irre, also wir haben ja jetzt die Zahlen bekommen,
ein Viertel der Deutschen verdient weniger als 14 Euro im Monat.
Ich hab's gerade hier vor mir.
Also liegt quasi unter gewünschten Mindestlohn.
Also das heißt 9,3 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland von den knapp 40 Millionen,
die hier arbeiten, verdienen unter 14 Euro.
Das heißt, das ist gar nicht so wie das hier so anklingt. Da gibt es noch so
eine kleine Gruppe, um die müsste man sich noch mal eigens kümmern.
Ein Viertel dieser Leute hat einfach ganz, ganz wenig Geld.
Genau, die können sich nicht gesund ernähren und schädigen damit gleichzeitig
auch noch oder sich und also sich sowieso,
aber eben verursachen auch das Fortschreiten dieser ganzen politischen Problemlagen,
die wir da so haben insgesamt, ohne dass sie halt was dafür können. Ja.
Sie sind also aufgeklärt, darüber isst man ja auch nicht. Die Ernährungsindustrie
hält ja auch da den Deckel drauf.
Zucker und Fleisch, all das ist sehr billig. Das andere ist teurer und das hat
man ja jetzt auch bei der Inflation gesehen, dass gerade Obst,
Gemüse dann besonders einen Preisanstieg erlebt hat.
Das heißt also viele flüchten sich dann natürlich in noch günstigere Lebensmittel
und diese sind in der Regel nicht gesund und das ist der Punkt an dem wir stehen.
Also es ist doch in erster Linie mal, also wenn wir jetzt mal von den oberen
40 Prozent oder was absehen, ist es jetzt zunächst mal eine Frage der Kosten,
die man bereit ist auszugeben und gar nicht so eine Frage nur des Kulturwandels.
Genau. Wie viel Handlungsvermögen traut man sich dazu und wie viel Problembewusstsein?
Östermir, wie gesagt, damals zum Jahreswechsel hat diesen großen Aufschlag gemacht,
der wurde natürlich gleich begleitet.
In Berlin hat Bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Özdemir mehr als 60 Ressortkollegen
aus aller Welt empfangen. Bei der Konferenz ging es darum, wie die Nahrungsmittelproduktion
nachhaltig und krisenfest gesichert werden kann.
Die Teilnehmer besprachen unter anderem, wie sich die Agrarwirtschaft an die
Klimaerwärmung anpassen muss und wie eine gesunde Ernährung erschwinglich gemacht werden kann.
Özdemir betonte das Ziel, den Hunger weltweit bis 2030 zu beenden.
Parallel zur grünen Woche sind in der Hauptstadt Tausende Menschen für eine
umweltschonendere Agrarwirtschaft auf die Straße gegangen.
Es nahmen auch mehr als 50 Landwirte mit Traktoren an dem Protest teil.
Das Bündnis, zu dem auch Tier- und Klimaschützer gehören, fordert beispielsweise
faire Erzeugerpreise und mehr Ackerflächen für den Nahrungsmittelanbau.
Außerdem müsse das Insektensterben gestoppt werden.
Also alle leiden. Die Menschen, die das Essen leiden, Diejenigen,
die modern progressiv damit umgehen wollen, leiden, weil sie nicht entsprechend bezahlt werden.
Diejenigen, die es noch auf konventionelle Art und Weise machen,
leiden, weil sie da politisch unter Druck geraten usw.
Es ist einfach ein großes Durcheinander. Und kleiner Hinweis damals zu diesem Treffen.
Wir haben hier diese großen Bemühungen, aber die finden mittlerweile auch ohne
China und ohne Russland statt. Und Ukraine halt auch nur so peripher angegliedert.
Also ist eh die Frage, wie viel globales Handlungsvermögen es da gerade gibt.
Deutschland und die Europäische Union müssen endlich präsenter sein.
Wir dürfen das Feld nicht den autoritären Staaten überlassen,
die dort aktiv sind und durch ihre Investitionen versuchen, neue Abhängigkeiten zu schaffen.
Özdemir meint auch China, das nicht an der Konferenz teilnimmt.
Russland wurde gar nicht eingeladen.
Der Präsident der Ukraine wendet sich per Videobotschaft an die Agrarminister.
Sein Land war mal die Kornkammer Europas. Der Krieg habe die Exporte jetzt halbiert.
Es muss wieder Weizen auf fruchtbarem Boden geben. Keine Krater von Explosionen.
Das ist im Januar gewesen. Jetzt hat ja Russland dieses Getreideaufkommen wieder
aufgekündigt und macht gleichzeitig so einen Afrika-Gipfel, bei dem es verschiedenen
Ländern so und so viel, tausend Tonnen Getreide verspricht und das auch direkt liefert.
Das ist ja alles total verrückt, denn eigentlich denkt man ja,
na gut, wenn so ein Krieg passiert, wird die Saat nicht aufs Feld gebracht und
dann hat man also im Herbst zu wenig Weizen.
Nur irgendwie sind selbst bei so langfristigen und von der Natur abhängigen
Prozessen so viele Möglichkeiten plötzlich im Raum, dass wir ja gerade keinen
zu teuren Weizenpreis haben auf dem Weltmarkt.
Sondern das ist ja alles, also da ist ja gar kein Krieg mehr zu sehen irgendwie
in der Weißentwicklung. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz erstaunlich.
Ich wollte dem nochmal so ein bisschen nachgehen, aber man versteht das gar nicht.
Irgendwie scheint es dann doch, ja in der Ukraine gibt es diese schwarze Erde,
die ist halt so besonders, aber man kann wohl doch relativ zügig dann auch woanders
einfach für Weizen sorgen oder sonstig irgendwie die Prozesse der,
wie auch immer, Veredelung in Nahrungsmittel so umwandeln, dass es irgendwie
hinhaut. Also da geht es jedenfalls drunter und drüber.
Derzeit wird politisch gar nichts geregelt, in Deutschland wird Össemir da zertrümmert.
Wir gucken jetzt die Bundestagsdebatten zum Thema, die stattfanden,
als es noch im Raum stand. Also als der Bundestag noch getagt hat,
sagen wir mal so, jetzt ist ja eh Sommerpause und so weiter und so fort.
Nur um halt den Ton zu hören, wie das so ist, wenn so ein Thema,
das so wichtig ist, einfach zurückgelassen wird.
Einfach auf dem Feld verenden soll. Es ist wirklich verrückt.
Das ist wirklich verrückt. Also wir hören hier einen CDU-Antrag,
der aufgerufen wird am 18.01.
Die Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der CDU-CSU mit dem Titel Nahrungsmittelversorgung
sicherstellen, Selbstversorgungsgrad in Deutschland und Europa erhalten.
Für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39 Minuten vereinbart.
So, man diskutiert also, auftritt Karl Bär von den Grünen.
Er versucht irgendwie uns zu beeindrucken. Er dachte, ich mache mal hier sowas.
Für die 29er oder was?
Etwas verrücktes für die 29er.
Und für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das Wort Karl Bär.
Willst du was zu seiner Mode sagen?
Die Hose ist definitiv zu kurz.
Und die Socken sind zu weiß und die Schuhe sind zu glänzend und irgendwie passt
das alles nicht. Aber gut.
Sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin!
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, liebe Unionsfraktionen, ich finde das sehr spannend.
In dem Antrag benutzen Sie ja marxistisches Vokabular. Wenn man in die Ideengeschichte
schaut, bei Hegel, da sind es die großen Ideen, denen wirklich die objektive,
eigentliche Wirklichkeit zukommt.
Karl Marx kritisiert diesen Idealismus und er benutzt dafür das Wort Ideologie,
das Sie auch so gerne benutzen. Nach Marx spiegelt und verschleiert Ideologie
die Machtverhältnisse in der Gesellschaft.
Und dieser Antrag ist ein Lehrstück in Sachen Ideologie, der präsentiert uns
die Interessen der Agrarindustrie ganz ohne Rücksicht auf die Wirklichkeit.
Das ist doch schön hergeleitet.
Ja, aber es gehört da nicht hin.
Kann man nicht mehr machen?
Nee, das ist irgendwie...
Aber die Bundestagsdebatten sind alle so niveaulos. Ich bin immer froh,
wenn überhaupt mal noch ein großer Name genannt wird und richtig ausgesprochen wird.
Also wenn ein halbes Jahr vorher, wir haben es ja thematisiert, die EU-Agrarpolitik,
die gemeinsame Agrarpolitik, insbesondere durch die Ausschussarbeit im Deutschen
Bundestag so zerschossen wird, ein halbes Jahr später als Regierungspartei dann
irgendwie eine Hegelvorlesung zu halten über Ideologiekritik und so,
weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie...
Du willst jetzt direkt an die Zahlen rein und sagen...
Es gäbe doch hier konkrete politische Sachen, die man einfach mal aufgreifen kann und so.
Aber es ist ja auch so ein Spaßantrag jetzt einfach von der Union,
bei dem man eh weiß, der ist ja nur gestellt, damit man darüber redet.
Ja, aber die Gelegenheit kann man doch insbesondere dann nutzen.
Dass man sagt, vielen Dank liebe Opposition, dass ihr das Thema aufwirft,
wir reden gerne eine halbe Stunde drüber, aber dann nach unserer Maxime.
Und er hat nun mal Cem Özdemir als Chef und im Ministeramt.
Und dann sollte einfach egal sein, was in diesem CDU-Antrag steht,
sondern da muss man einfach zu seinem Thema reden.
Ich finde das irgendwie dafür, dass das am 18.01.
Stattfand hier und wir die Nachrichtenlage Cem Özdemir lädt 60 Amtskollegen
weltweit ein am 21.01. ist, also drei Tage später, kann man nicht dahin gehen
und sagen, ah, die CDU hat eine Antrage gestellt, dann rede ich jetzt zu Hegel.
Das passt einfach nicht.
Ich gehe auf den Antrag ein.
Zum Beispiel. Da muss man einfach die eigene Linie durchhalten.
Ich hatte hier in Frankfurt eine Diskussion mit Janine Wissler und sie erzählte,
dass es früher so war, dass man im hessischen Landtag, dass man immer viel Zeit hatte, um zu,
Antworten auch in der Opposition. Also das heißt, wenn der Bouffier 35 Minuten
spricht, dann kann man auch entsprechend lange antworten.
Und das waren dann immer sehr lange Reden, aber man konnte so viel sagen.
Und das ist jetzt in der Opposition natürlich sehr schwierig,
weil man dann im Bundestag nur vier Minuten hat.
Und dann habe ich zu ihr gesagt, na das ist doch toll, wenn man nicht mehr 35
Minuten sich mit Volker Bouffiers Argumenten auseinanderzusetzen,
sie sollte einfach ein 4-minütiges TikTok-Video machen für alle.
Die Gelegenheit wird ja häufig genutzt von den Parteien, von denen wir das nicht wollen.
Ja eben.
Wir springen ans Ende oder gegen Ende 15.1.
Renate Künast damals in Rage. Also sie hat so ein bisschen gemacht,
was der Bär hier nicht macht. Keine Ahnung, warum sie dann erst am Ende,
wo sie doch selber mal im Amt war.
Kupicki nutzt dann die Gelegenheit. Also man macht im Grunde so einen hübschen Moment da im Bundestag.
Was wir tun, ist Transparenz und Klarheit im Wettbewerb.
Der Umbau der Tierhaltung kommt, meine Damen und Herren, der Umbau der Tierhaltung wird kommen.
Auch wenn manche gerne so tun, als wollten sie den Umbau hier am Ende aber gar
nicht umsetzen. Ihre Verantwortung ist nicht zu meckern, sondern Zukunft herzustellen.
Ich bin schon so froh, Frau Kollegin Künast, dass Sie sich nicht festgeklebt haben im Pult.
Damit schließe ich die Aussprache.
Und das hat übrigens Methode, also wen ratet Renate Künast zum Thema Ernährung
im Bundestag ist sie immer die letzte Rednerin und so weiter,
so war das nämlich dann auch im Dezember.
Dass sie angeblich die Vorarbeit geleistet hätten an der Stelle.
Ich sag Ihnen mal, 16 Jahre Vorspiel sind nicht genug.
Es muss auch mal zum Äußersten kommen.
Aber die machen ja einfach so eine Karnevalssitzung.
Ja, so geht das die ganze Zeit. Also zwischendurch wird noch Geburtstag gefeiert.
Damen und Herren, liebe Kolleginnen, Renate Künast auch von uns aus,
natürlich herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag, gar keine Frage.
Ja, heute in der, vor allen Dingen in dieser Debatte, schaut wirklich die komplette
Agrar- und Ernährungswirtschaft nach Berlin.
Also er sagt, wir haben hier eine Debatte, bei der schaut die ganze Agrar- und
Ernährungswirtschaft nach Berlin, die ganze Agrar- und Ernährungswirtschaft.
Wir kennen ja verschiedene Branchen.
Es gibt so Spaßbranchen, man kauft sich vielleicht einmal alle zehn Jahre so
einen Fernseher für 1000 Euro oder alle drei Jahre ein neues Telefon für 800 oder sowas.
Fürs Essen geben wir konstant Geld aus, die ganze Zeit.
Unser Geld, das wir verdienen, geht einfach immer ins Essen.
Essen. Das ist absolut verlässliches Milliarden und Billionen Verschiebe und
so weiter. Und wenn er jetzt sagt, die gucken, was wir hier machen,
dann will man ja eigentlich, dass dem so ein bisschen entsprochen wird,
dass da auch was zu sehen gibt und so.
Aber nicht nur 17.900 Schweinehalter,
nein, das sind insgesamt 4,4 Millionen Beschäftigte in Agrar- und Ernährungswirtschaft
mit einem Gesamtumsatz von 186 Milliarden Euro und rund ein Viertel,
etwa 46 Milliarden Euro, er wirtschaftet alleine die Fleischwirtschaft.
Ja, und das ist so gut. Während die Anträge laufen, weniger Fleisch,
gesünder, weniger Wasserverbrauch, nicht so viel und so weiter,
auch weniger Leid der Tiere, feiert er einfach nur ab, wie groß das halt ist.
Dass man das ja implizit dann, das müssen wir erhalten. Also das wird gar nicht
in Frage gestellt, sondern nochmal insbesondere, also man könnte ja genau so
die Zahlen nennen und sagen, das ist zu groß. Ja, hier müssen wir mal ein Stoppschild
einführen. Aber nein, wird nicht gemacht.
Auch die AfD macht natürlich genau das, was sie immer macht.
Sie, und dass Sie unbelehrbar sind, das wusste man ja bereits,
haben ja die unerträgliche Ignoranz gegenüber allen Einwänden der Beteiligten auf der ganzen Welt.
Zeigt mir, welches Geist des Kindes sie in Wirklichkeit sind und wie sehr sie
unsere freiheitliche marktwirtschaftliche Demokratie verachten.
Mit uns ist es jedenfalls nicht zu machen, meine Damen und Herren.
Ja, besser hätte man es nicht parodieren können.
Man möchte die Demokratie nicht abschaffen, die Schweine müssen bleiben.
Also irgendwie so, das ist die Botschaft.
Und jetzt hatte ich hier am, also das war jetzt aus dem Dezember,
sechs Wochen später im Bundestag, 25.1.
Nachdem das eben ja 18.1. war.
Also die haben damals schon recht viel über Essen im Bundestag geredet.
Geht es zum Thema Höfesterben und wir haben ja eben schon gehört von der CDU,
es gibt so ganz viele Schweine und das ist ja auch ganz fantastisch.
Und jetzt ist man sich hier so ein bisschen unklar, worüber redet man eigentlich?
Frau Präsidentin, meine Damen und Herren, sehr verehrte Gäste hier im Haus,
die vielen bäuerlichen Familienbetriebe und Agrargenossenschaften in Deutschland
sind die Grundlage für die Versorgungssicherheit mit heimischen Lebensmitteln.
Gleichzeitig schützen sie unsere natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen,
pflegen unsere wunderschöne Kulturlandschaft.
Die Schweineställe pflegen unsere wunderschöne Kulturland.
Ja und wir wissen ja von diesen kleinen putzigen Höfen,
also das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja die Landfrauen und diese ganzen Sendungen,
die es gibt, wo dann abends auf irgendwelchen Höfen, in denen natürlich keine
Landwirtschaft in der Regel mehr betrieben wird oder vielleicht noch irgendwo
mal ein Käse hergestellt wird, aber da kann man nur einen Tourismus veranstalten.
Das Bild wird hier aufgezeichnet, was mit der Ernährung der deutschen Bevölkerung nichts zu tun hat.
Gar nichts. Also da könnte man sich ja Tönnies angucken, wie die Autobahn verstopft
ist mit LKWs, die die Schweine anliefern und so weiter und so fort.
Die Urlandschaft und sind unersetzlich für die regionale Identität.
Für uns als AfD steht fest, Heimat braucht Bauern.
Es ist deshalb umso dramatischer, dass jedes Jahr tausende landwirtschaftliche
Betriebe gezwungen sind, ihre Hoftore für immer zu schließen.
In den vergangenen 20 Jahren hat sich die Zahl der Höfe in Deutschland fast halbiert.
So, Höfe sterben wirft er also als Thema auf und wir bleiben ein bisschen bei
diesem Thema, wechseln nochmal zurück in den Dezember.
Künast hat damals schon angemerkt, ja was passiert eigentlich auf den Höfen,
Kulturlandschaft, irgendwie Heimat und so weiter.
Wir produzieren vieles für den Export, meine Damen und Herren,
die produzieren aber auch selbst mittlerweile.
Wir wissen über Problemlagen an der Stelle, 40 Prozent aller geschlachteten
Schweine weist Organbefunde, also Krankheiten aus, meine Damen und Herren, bei der Schlachtung.
Und die Realität in der Fleischindustrie auch bei uns ist im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes auch geschönt. Und dann sagen die Bauern, wir wissen ja,
dass es einen Rückgang der Betriebe gibt, vorne an bei den Schweinehaltern.
Sie sagen, wir wollen endlich verlässliche Linien haben, wohin wir uns ausrichten
sollen. Wir wollen eine Perspektive.
Und ich sage Ihnen, dieser Gesetzentwurf hier, den Cem Özdemir vorgelegt hat,
ist der Grundstein dafür etwas Neues zu bauen. So.
Also 40 Prozent der Schweine sind krank und die Höfe sterben noch,
was ja heißt, dadurch, dass wir so viele Schweine haben, das ist ja eine Konzentration
auf dem Markt, was sie da bemängeln, also dass die Höfe zu groß werden und so weiter und so fort.
Was ja nur bedeutet, dass in diesen, und ich korrelier jetzt mal Größe oder
Wachstum mit Industrialisierung,
also dass man dann umso besser noch organisiert, dass da jetzt keine Möglichkeit
ist irgendwie die Schweine dann aber gesund zu machen oder so,
also ja widerspricht Und da das immer so virulent war, in diesen ganzen Debatten,
hat man das Höfesterben eben am 25.01.
Dann konkret zum Thema gemacht.
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der AfD mit dem Titel Heimat braucht Bauern,
bäuerliche Familienbetriebe in Deutschland erhalten.
Für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39 Minuten vereinbart.
Ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort hat zuerst für die AfD-Fraktion Stefan Protschka.
So und diesen Ausschnitt haben wir ja eben gesehen, wie er das beklagt und schon
eine Woche vorher Frank Rink in der AfD, und da ging es noch nicht konkret um
Höfesterben, deswegen haben die wahrscheinlich nochmal diesen Antrag gemacht,
sagte auch ja ja die Höfesterben.
Meine Damen und Herren, bei Antritt der Regierung wurde hier verkündet, es soll besser werden.
Aber das Höfesterben geht umgebremst weiter und der Landwirtschaftsminister
befeuert dieses immer noch war.
Deutschland ist ein Grundstandort zur Lebensmittelproduktion und es ist schlichtweg dumm,
unsere hervorragenden landwirtschaftlichen Bedingungen nicht auszuschöpfen und
stattdessen den Preiskampf auf den Weltmärkten weiter zu befeuern,
indem wir unsere Flächen stilllegen und uns am Angebot des Weltmarkts bedienen müssen.
Meine Damen und Herren, stirbt der Bauer, stirbt das Land. Vielen Dank.
Also Heimat braucht Bauern, stirbt der Bauer, stirbt das Land.
Die AfD steuerte das also zu auf diesen von ihr eigens hervorgerufenen Antrag
dann, wir wollen ja mal zum Thema Höfesterben reden und so.
Und als sie dann am 25.1., nachdem das schon im Dezember und am 18.1.
Und so weiter immer wieder Thema war auf der AfD, dass die Höfe sterben,
steht dann Anna Monika Spallek von den Grünen am Rednerpult.
Rednerpult. Und das Interessanteste ist, ich habe mir die Zahlen mal angeguckt,
die AfD hat ja sehr alte Zahlen genannt von dem Höfesterben,
denn im letzten Jahr hat sich was geändert.
Das ist abgebremst und zwar massiv und wenn man auf die Bundesländer guckt in
der Statistabelle, in einzelnen, in vielen Bundesländern haben Betriebe zugenommen.
Gucken Sie sich die Zahlen an. Es ist so. Der Minister ist erfolgreich. Herzlichen Dank.
Jetzt gibt es nicht mal ein Höfesterben.
Aber kann das sein?
Keine Ahnung. Die guckt bei Statista, da nehme ich mal an, die hat bei Google
einfach die erste Seite Bild. Doch kein Höfesterben?
Also es gibt schon ein Höfesterben. Die Frage ist ja, wie möchte man Landwirtschaft organisieren?
Also reden wir jetzt davon, dass wir die schlimmste Massentierhaltung damit
koppeln wollen, das ist Heimat, das ist unsere Identität?
Oder geht es darum, dass man eine andere Landwirtschaft,
in Deutschland ermöglicht, die sowohl Tierleid verhindert oder minimiert,
als auch der klimatischen Bedingungen eher zuträglich als abträglich ist und
auch noch gleichzeitig Produkte bringt,
die hilfreich sein könnten in der, sagen wir, gesundheitlichen Entwicklung der Bevölkerung.
Genau, und da würde man ja sagen, das sind alles relevante Themen.
Wie viele Höfe, also auf wie viele Höfe sich das jetzt verteilt und dann einfach
gefühlt, ob es jetzt 10.000, 20.000, keine Ahnung, also so ist ja auch egal.
Also die werden, die veröden ja nicht einfach diese Landflüchten,
sondern Land ist ja wahnsinnig beliebt. Man kann darüber nachdenken,
ob das sinnvoll ist, dass diese ganzen Großkonzerne dieses Landgrabbing betreiben.
Und das sind ja dann nicht Agrarkonzerne, sondern sind ja ganz andere Konzerne,
die ihre Finger noch im Spiel haben.
Aber hier sind wir eigentlich in der Frage, gut, wie viel Wettbewerb soll sein?
Wann muss das Kartellamt einschreiten?
Das wäre dann eine Frage, die kartellrechtlich zu klären ist.
Na groß darf ein Hof sein, dass er zu dominant ist.
Haben wir ja, wie das in vielen Science-Fiction-Filmen oder Dystopien ist,
nur noch einen Konzern, dem gehören die Felder. Und der produziert auch gleich
die Produkte und verkauft sie im eigenen Supermarkt.
Ist das der Fall? Das glaube ich ist nicht der Punkt. Dass wir eine moderne
Landwirtschaft brauchen, eine industrialisierte, ist ja völlig klar.
Denn auch nur eine moderne Landwirtschaft kann eine klimafreundliche Landwirtschaft
dann in dem Sinne sein, also dass man versucht, möglichst effizient zu produzieren.
Und das, was die AfD ja hier einfach für ein Bild aufmacht, ist,
dass man noch zum Bauern jetzt geht und dort ein bisschen Fleisch bekommt,
eine Wurst und einen Käse und noch eine Kanne Milch mitnimmt.
Dass das nicht die Realität ist, aber schon so seit über 100 Jahren nicht mehr,
dürfte ja klar sein. Aber das ist im Übrigen, ich will jetzt nicht so einen
zu plumpen Nazi-Vergleich machen, aber ich will eine strukturelle Ähnlichkeit
zumindest darstellen, eben.
NS-Film, im Propaganda-Film, konnte man unglaublich oft sehen,
wie Bauern und Bäuerinnen mit der Sense dort stehen. Im Sonnenschein. Im Sonnenschein.
In diesen Filmen wurde immer dieses Der Bauer stirbt, der Bauer stirbt,
das Land und unsere Heimat.
Das wurde stark gemacht mit Bildern, die schon in den dreißiger Jahren nicht
mehr die Wirklichkeit abgebildet haben.
Jetzt sind wir im Jahr 2023, denn natürlich war auch schon unter Hitler die
Landwirtschaft sehr stark modernisiert.
Und man hat aber da schon immer das neunzehnte Jahrhundert aufgerufen. Und jetzt sind wir im 21.
Jahrhundert und immer noch ist das hier neunzehntes Jahrhundert.
So wie früher die Volksmusiksendungen waren.
Die AfD, der Versuch ist wahrscheinlich, den Begriff Höfesterben so an Daseinsvorsorge,
Ernährungssicherheit zu koppeln.
Was ja auch in den Neurechten-Diskursen passiert, also das haben wir ja auch,
diese Phänomene, die natürlich klein sind in der Dimension, dass sich in irgendwelchen
Dörfern, wo sonst keiner mehr hin will, sich Rechtsradikale ansiedeln.
Dort Höfe, bauen wieder irgendwelche alten Kartoffelarten oder was weiß ich
anpflanzen und dann so eine ursprüngliche Landwirtschaft dort machen,
aber immer mit dem rechten Vorzeichen und das ist ja dann immer so erstaunlich,
wenn es mal so Reportagen darüber gibt, wenn die Anwohner erst gar nicht merken,
was da passiert und die erst denken, ach das ist aber schön so ein Biohof und
plötzlich wundert man sich, warum die zwölf Kinder haben und die Mädchen laufen
alle mit Zöpfen und Röcken rum.
Genau. Ich habe hier so ein Tweet vom ZDF Görlitz. Staat fördert Zentrum für
Rechtes Anastasia, für Rechte Anastasia Bewegung. Das hatten wir ja thematisiert.
Da war so ein alter Hof, der renoviert werden sollte. Also hat die Familie einen
Antrag gestellt, hat 900.000 Euro bewilligt bekommen von Sachsen-Anhalt oder so.
Und dann stellte sich raus, ah ja, die haben da so eine Anastasia Family Gang,
so eine Clique nenne ich es mal, da einfach reingegründet. Ja,
genau. Also da geht so ganz viele Bilder einfach so durcheinander.
Für dieses Klientel wird da wahrscheinlich mal so eine Debatte im Bundestag veranstaltet.
Ja, genau. Gut, drei Clips zum Schluss. Und das ist jetzt interessant.
Also wir haben ja eben besprochen, dass Özdemir dieser Tage ...
Vor der Presse stand und dann sein Glas da in die Höhe gehalten hat und meinte
diese zwei Würfel Zucker, die lösen sich einfach ins Unsichtbare aus,
aber sind halt trotzdem drin.
Das wollen wir mal verbieten. Das ist dieser Tenor vom Februar damals.
Also wir haben hier null Entwicklung nirgendwo her. Wir haben Sommerpause.
Wir wissen auch, was nach der
Sommerpause passiert. Wir haben Haushaltsturbulenzen, wir haben Krieg usw.
Das hier war im Februar ein totes Thema, das ist jetzt ein totes Thema und das wird so auch bleiben.
Bundesernährungsminister Oestemir will Übergewicht bei Kindern bekämpfen.
Er plant ein Gesetz, das an Kinder gerichtete Werbung für ungesunde Lebensmittel
weitgehend verbieten soll.
Im Fernsehen und im Radio dürften solche Spots dann nur noch nachts laufen,
in sozialen Netzwerken gar nicht mehr.
Etwa 15 % der Kinder und Jugendlichen hierzulande seien übergewichtig,
begründet Özdemir die Initiative.
Es geht wirklich nur um die Werbung dafür. Das hat im Februar,
zumindest im heute-Journal, dazu geführt, dass sie einen ausführlicheren Bericht gemacht hatten.
Es kam ziemlich überraschend. Erst am Morgen lud der Minister zur Pressekonferenz.
Das Vorhaben wirkt Sprengstoff. Denn er möchte ein Werbeverbot von 6 bis 23
Uhr mit zu viel Zucker, Salz oder Fett, die gezielt Kinder ansprechen.
Sein Vorschlag, eine Kampfansage an die Industrie.
Gesetzliche Regelungen werden immer da nötig, wo freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen scheitern.
Fakt ist, die bisherigen freiwilligen Selbstverpflichtungen haben bei Schutz
der Kinder nachweislich versagt.
Nachweislich sind deutsche Kinder zu dick.
Wie wollen die das in den sozialen Medien handhaben? Klar, das soll auch irgendwie
damit gefasst werden, aber das würde ja eigentlich nur funktionieren,
wenn man ein Totalverbot macht.
Also man kann ja nicht einem TikToker sagen,
aber bitte erst nach 22 Uhr, denn wir wissen ja,
es ist immer da und mir scheint auch,
dass ein bisschen ihr übersehen, wir reden jetzt immer über diese Fernsehwerbung,
das ist so eine typische Rentnerrepublik Diskussion, also sitzen,
wer, wer, wer, wer unter 30, ich habe zum letzten Mal eine Fernsehwerbung gesehen,
ich sehe noch Werbung im Kino.
Wenn ich zu früh da bin, ich gehe meistens immer erst dann rein,
wenn die Träder schon laufen. Aber in der Social Media Blase ist es natürlich völlig anders.
Da gibt es ja Produkte, die nur wegen Social Media entstanden sind.
Also das heißt, das ist ja mittlerweile gängiges Modell von Startups,
wenn du irgendwelche Produkte hast, irgendein,
Ein Eis, das man, weiß ich nicht, auch zu einem Kuchen verbacken kann,
also die haben ja immer so komische Sachen, ja.
Kuchenteig, den man aber so löffeln kann.
Oder irgendwelche merkwürdigen anderen Lebensmittel, sehr süßes Zeug.
Das wird ja inzwischen alles gelauncht, dadurch, dass man Influencer engagiert
oder sie anfixt und sagt, hier ist was ganz, ganz Neues, ganz Tolles.
Und dann wird das viral gehen. Da gibt es ja mehrere Beispiele von Start-ups,
die irgendwie in dieses Rewe-Edeka-System reinkommen wollten.
Und das ist ja, wie wir wissen, sehr, sehr abgeschlossen.
Also das ist ja nicht so, dass du sagst, ich habe hier ein schönes Produkt,
nehmt das doch mal ins Sortiment auf. Und dann haben ja virale Kampagnen gefahren,
über TikTok vor allem und über Instagram.
Und haben dafür gesorgt, dass die jungen Leute in die Supermärkte gehen und
nach den Produkten fragen, die dann nicht da sind, bis dann Rewe und Co.
Irgendwann reagiert haben und sagt, ja, dann schickt uns mal dieses Eis oder
was das dann ist. Und da frage ich mich schon, wie man das einhegen will.
Auch Royal Donuts ist ja inzwischen auch eine Kette geworden.
Da hat auch der Gründer mal erzählt, wie er angefangen hat und wie er aber gar
nicht so Geld investieren konnte in Influencer Marketing, aber die Influencer waren dann da.
Einzelne haben sich dann damit fotografieren lassen mit diesen Donuts und dann
wurde das so eine virale Aktion und plötzlich gibt es dann eine riesen Kette Royal Donuts.
Aber das ist rein generiert über Social Media. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob Royal Donuts jemals im Fernsehen geworben hat. Ich würde fast behaupten nein.
Genau, Fernsehen ist der Alten Republik und...
Zum Abschluss dieses Themas, und das ist jetzt aktuell, Anna-Katharina hat mich
darauf hingewiesen, also uns beide über Twitter.
In Nature ist ein Artikel erschienen zum Thema Early-Onset-Cancer.
Also wir haben ja sowieso Krebs als das Top-Thema in der Medizin,
gerade durch die neuen mRNA-Techniken und so.
Und dieser Text behandelt jetzt explizit die Epidemie der frühen Krebsentwicklung
bei unter 50-jährigen Patienten Weltweit und schon im Teaser zählen sie auf drei Zeilen auf,
welche Krebsarten, also ich würde mal grob gegründet sagen alle.
Und der Text handelt davon, dass das wahrscheinlich am wahrscheinlichsten mit
unserer Ernährung zu tun hat, nämlich dem Processed Food.
Und da gibt es dann eine sehr schöne Sunday Times-Titellage mit einem Toastbrot
drauf, Ultra-Processed People.
Also warum uns das Essen so gesund macht. Jetzt zeige ich dir den Aktienkurs
von McDonald's die letzten 30 Jahre.
Der hat sich sehr positiv entwickelt.
Es beginnt bei null, 2012 oder so wird dann die 100 Dollar Marke durchschritten.
2020, 2018, 2019, 2020 scheint das hier so die 200 Dollar Marke zu sein.
Man sieht da so einen kleinen Pandemieknick.
Leute können nicht raus, aber der ist wirklich minimal.
Also der hat sich sofort erholt. Und du stößt jetzt aktuell erstmalig,
und das ist auch mit steigender Tendenz nach oben, die 300 Dollar Marke und
McDonalds ist ja nun Chiffre für Ultra Processed Food,
in billiger Art, also in der Hinsicht, wir sind hier wirklich weltweit bei so einem gigantisch,
riesigen Thema ökonomisch, biologisch und überhaupt ökologisch.
Jetzt lass uns das aber nochmal auf eine andere Ebene heben.
Ich hatte ja große Sorge vor diesem Thema, weil ich dachte, was wirst du uns
wieder alles für Vorwürfe hier machen, wie wir uns nicht bewegen oder tun und machen.
Ich gucke mal auf die Resonanz und dann greife ich das ja nochmal auf.
Ja, ja, dann guckst du, ob du nochmal provozieren kannst. Nein,
aber lass uns mal noch, wenn die schon so doof im Bundestag darüber reden,
nochmal so zwei Perspektiven benennen. Also Werbung, Klammer jetzt mal aus,
können Sie wegen mir machen, ist egal.
Die Sache ist ja einmal die der Kosten, die gesundes Essen mehr produzieren.
Das heißt, man muss sich ganz radikal dafür einsetzen, höhere Löhne,
höhere Zuschüsse vom Staat für die, die beispielsweise arbeitslos sind.
Und generell müsste man gesunde Lebensmittel steuerlich besser stellen.
Da könnte man zum Beispiel auch die Mehrwertsteuer wegnehmen und stattdessen
auf die ungesunden Lebensmittel die Mehrwertsteuer erhöhen. Wie man ja auch
bei vielen anderen Sachen eine erhöhte Mehrwertsteuer hat oder eine Sondersteuer.
Alkopops damals wurde auch zu einer Epidemie unter Jugendlichen.
Also hat man die viel stärker besteuert, wurden die teurer, wurden nicht mehr
gekauft. Also diese Möglichkeiten gibt es.
Und dann glaube ich aber ist noch eine Komponente entscheidend,
wenn wir über Nährung sprechen, die Zeit.
Wer hat zeit sich etwas gutes zu machen
und wer will sich auch die zeit dafür
nehmen ich sag dir ganz klar ich nicht aber ich
gehe jetzt nicht nur fast food aber ich gehe dann ins restaurant oder so aber
das ist ja auch schon wieder eine geldfrage wie oft kann man das auch machen
so das ist aber ich bin jetzt niemand der für sich ausführlich kochen würde
aber ich kenne immer leute die sehr gut kochen können und mit denen stelle ich mich natürlich gut.
Aber gut, das ist ja jetzt eine ganz individuelle Geschichte.
Aber generell ist das Zeitproblem eines, dass Leute haben, gerade wo zwei in
der Regel arbeiten gehen.
Und die Kinder müssten also erst einmal eine bessere Ernährung bekommen in der Schule.
Also die Kantinen müssten da besser sein. Aber es ist doch irgendwie verrückt,
dass wir hier zum Beispiel auch in Frankfurt sind,
Wo es ganz viele Leute gibt, die arbeiten gehen und die haben Kinder und gut,
die haben mal an der Schule gegessen, aber abends muss was gegessen werden.
Und oft reicht nicht die Zeit, vielleicht muss noch jemand zum Sport oder sonst
was, um jetzt was Vernünftiges zu machen.
Dann wird es halt irgendwas gepresstes, ja, hier aus deinem Artikel.
Dass es keine Einrichtungen gibt, also keine Stadtteilkantinen,
wo man immer auf einem vernünftigen Niveau einfache Dinge essen kann.
Das wäre eigentlich das.
Und zwar nicht im Sinne von Suppenküche, also wir geben hier noch was für die Armen und Obdachlosen,
sondern wirklich, dass man sagt,
hier gibt es für ganz wenig Geld zum Selbstkostenpreis etwas Einfaches,
Auswahl zwischen drei Gerichten wegen mir,
aber damit ist die Ernährung immer auf einem guten Niveau gewährleistet und
niemand muss sagen, wir haben keine Zeit, lass uns schnell zu McDonalds fahren
oder lass uns diese Tiefkühlpizzen und all das jetzt verschlingen.
Das wäre doch eigentlich die sinnvollste Struktur, zumindest für die bevölkerungsdichten Regionen.
Also das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Und ich glaube, auch wenn man ein bisschen
Crowdsourcing macht, kommt man auf viele gute Ideen.
Ich denke auch, dass wir, wir haben ja diesen einen Text, diese Spiegel Titel
Story damals im Februar gelesen,
als es auf Thema E so hochkochte, mit diesem Verweis,
was ich ja so interessant fand, auf diesen intergenerationale Pointe,
dass dann Boomer mit sehr viel Übergewicht für sich gesagt haben,
Okay, bei mir ist verloren, aber für meine Enkel kümmere ich mich noch mal drum.
Die wollen also, und jetzt die Frage, kann man ihnen ein Angebot machen?
Ich würde sagen, man müsste ihnen einfach zuhören.
Und Leute, die wissen, wie die Lieferketten und die Produktionswege sind,
die kommen dann schon auf Ideen, wenn sie diese Wünsche einmal hören.
Es gibt eine Antwort mit wieder quantenphysikalisch sozusagen zwei Wegen,
die gegeben werden können.
Bärbel Bas hat letzte Woche, ich habe keinen Clip davon, weil es absolut unergiebig
war, ein Bürgerrat eröffnet zum Thema Ernährung.
Super.
Ist natürlich ein Grabstein im Sinne von, wir haben ja gesehen,
was im Parlament dazu los ist, also wie sollte man dann, der Bürgerrat hat gesagt,
also gibt es dann in der Anhörung nochmal im Bundestag, wo die Ergebnisse vorgestellt
werden und es geht dazu nicht. Ist eine Beschwerdigungstherapie, ja.
So, aber da ist zumindest ein Forum, wo diese Wünsche mal vorgetragen werden
können und auch wenn sie in der Politik keinen Anklang finden,
können sie ja für uns mal dokumentiert werden, so dass wir zumindest durch argumentierte
und dann auch sozusagen in so einer semi-außerparlamentarischen Aktion verabschiedete
gute Wege und so weiter. Also ich werde das beobachten, was dabei rumkommt.
Ich fand das mal witzig, dass sie wieder festgestellt haben,
wäre vielleicht doch witzig gewesen, mal reinzuhören, aber das war so eine Bärbelbars eröffnet.
Die Ziehung, man hat 20.000 Leute angeschrieben, nachdem man vorher durch Zufall
aus den Melderegistern sich Daten schicken lassen hat, hat man 20.000 Briefe verschickt.
2000 liefen zurück. Dann haben sie festgestellt, da haben ja wieder mal nur
die Bildungsoberen usw.
Uns geantwortet, also müssten wir es wieder reingewichten.
Wieder manuell editorisch rein, um sozusagen die wenigen mit niedrigen Bildungsgraden
da ausführlich mit reinzunehmen.
Und dann gibt es da irgendwie drei oder vier Agenturen, alle mit so illustrigen
berlinerischen Namen, die dann sagen, ja, wir haben schon häufiger solche Auswahlprozesse
gemacht und so weiter, die sich dann so gegenseitig auf den Füßen stehen und
irgendwie sagen, wie man es noch besser macht.
Und sind der Meinung, dass sie das jetzt ganz zufällig ausgewählt haben,
obwohl man hätte sagen müssen, also wenn man es nach akademischen Standards macht.
Wenn da jemand nicht geantwortet hat, muss halt das Melderegister jemand neuen
schicken und dann muss man dem, bis sie halt geantwortet wird.
Da kann man ja nicht einfach sagen, ja wir haben uns 20.000 Briefe geschickt
und 2000 haben wir geantwortet, also machen wir es denen jetzt eine Zufallsgruppe,
weil es ist ja dann schon keine, gerade wenn man nochmal selber da editorisch reingewichtet und so.
Aber gut, es gibt jetzt diesen Bürgerrat zum Thema Ernährung.
Ich habe jetzt nicht genau verstanden, die betonen die ganze Zeit,
dass es der erste Bürgerrat ist, sondern sagt Bärbel Basel, das hat es ja auch
früher schon gegeben, also vielleicht vor 30, 40 Jahren oder so.
Aber in dieser modernen Form, wie die Ampel jetzt auch versteht,
dass man ein Fortschrittskoalition ist, gibt es jetzt einen Bürgerrat zum Thema
Ernährung, der jetzt anfängt zu beraten. 170 Leute oder so. Mal gucken,
ob man das begleiten kann.
Ich würde meine Hoffnung da eher wirklich auf die Regionalpolitik legen und
vielleicht hören uns manche zu und denken nochmal darüber nach.
Die Sache ist doch die, uns geht es doch allen darum, auch Zeit zu sparen.
Und das ist ja erstmal auch sinnvoll, dass man vielleicht die Zeit für für was anderes nutzt.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die kochen unglaublich gerne, aber kochen die wirklich auch
jeden Tag unglaublich gerne?
Naja, vielleicht dann nicht. Und wenn man sich anschaut,
wie ineffizient es eigentlich ist, dass jeder zu Hause sein eigenes Süppchen
kocht, Da kann man es mal genau so sagen, müsste doch einleuchtend sein,
dass es eine gute Alternative braucht zu dem, was wir tun.
Es gibt gute Restaurants und auch noch Fastfood.
Manches ist ja auch okay. Manches kann man ja auch mal schnell irgendwo essen.
Es ist ja nicht alles Gift, was man da bekommt. Aber dass man sagt,
es müsste so was sein, wo man mit der Familie gerade hingehen kann, weil man Hunger hat.
Dann ist das erledigt für diesen Abend. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel daran denke,
man hat eine Kartoffelsuppe mit ein paar Würstchen drin.
Wenn man die alleine sich machen würde, Ich tue jetzt so, als würde ich das
sonst machen, aber ich weiß in etwa, wie es geht.
Und wenn man bedenkt, was das für eine Zeit kostet, inklusive Abwasch,
und wie effizienzsteigernd es sein könnte, hätte man einen Ort,
wo es diese Kartoffelsuppe und wegen mir noch zwei andere Gerichte angeboten werden.
Und dann im Wechsel, dann ist das etwas, was den Alltag erleichtert,
günstig ist und auch gesund ist.
Es gibt ja einige Krankenhäuser, die eine sehr gute Kantine aufzuweisen haben,
was zur Folge hat, dass tatsächlich viele Leute, die nicht dort Patient sind,
mittags dort essen gehen.
Ist es für viele immer noch so ein bisschen, naja, gehe ich jetzt ins Krankenhaus
essen, das hat ja so ein Geschmäckle.
Aber da sieht man ja, es gibt offenbar eigentlich eine Nachfrage danach.
Und die kann aber nicht allein privatwirtschaftlich organisiert werden,
weil die Privatwirtschaft auf eine ganz andere Profitmaximierung aus ist,
als so etwas, wo sich hier im Kleinen etwas ergibt.
Zudem würde es sich vielleicht auch da noch das eine oder andere gemeinschaftliche
bilden, was auch nicht falsch wäre.
Ich mache jetzt eine ganz waghalsige Anmerkung, aber wir sind ja hier im Neuen Zwanziger Podcast.
Ich habe ja ein Buch über diese Art Community Küche oder Bäckereien geschrieben unter der Maßgabe,
wenn du im Alter feststellst, ich bin ja ganz schön allein, dort musst du,
also wir können ja das Angebot machen, Urlaub ist das Lebensende,
wozu gehört, nie wieder alleine essen, wenn du es nicht willst.
Dann sind wir zuhause, aber es gibt halt auch so eine Art Community Küche,
bezahlt wird dort Einkaufspreise.
Also das Essen kostet dann wirklich nur drei, vier Euro, was es halt auch im
Supermarkt einfach so kosten würde.
Und der eigentliche Beitrag ist, du bist halt montags dran mit Kochen für alle.
Also dass da einfach so eine Rotation drin ist und jeder weiß,
wie es in der Küche zugeht und nicht einfach nur als Gast kommt und so.
Aber wir wissen ja von Niklas Mark, dass man irgendwann angefangen hat,
im Zuge der Industrialisierung die Arbeiterschaft zu trennen in Kernfamilien,
um diese politischen Organisationsgefahren da rauszunehmen.
Und wir wissen aus diesen Kernfamilien, dass man dort auch nur die Frauen in
die Küche gestellt hat, die dann, wenn die Männer nur zum Essen,
also nicht mal mehr zum Kochen, sondern nur zum Essen dazu kamen,
gesagt hat, keine Politik am Küchentisch.
Wenn du mehrere Menschen gemeinsam essen lässt, besteht immer die Gefahr,
dass sie sich politisch organisieren. Denn da tauchen die Themen auf und so weiter.
Also es gab bisher große politische Anstrengungen.
Es ist nicht gewollt.
Weder die AfD noch die CDU noch die FDP wollen, dass sich da irgendjemand organisiert,
weil die werden sich wahrscheinlich nicht die Köpfe zermatern,
wie kriegen wir die Managerboni höher für die CEOs.
Und damit haben wir zum Ende nochmal markiert, wie groß das Thema Essen eigentlich ist.
Und wir kommen jetzt tatsächlich noch besser zu meinem Thema des Suizids,
denn was ein großes Problem ist, wie wir jetzt gleich hören werden,
ist selbstredend die Einsamkeit, ist, dass sich Alleingelassen fühlen.
Und wir müssen jetzt hier nicht einen großen Trigger machen.
Ich glaube, jeder weiß, dass es entsprechende Stellen gibt, an die man sich
wenden kann, dass man mit einem Wort, dass man googelt, sofort an Telefonnummern
kommt. Nummern kommt und der.
Weg hin zum Menschen, wenn man sich denen eröffnen kann, dann ist das schon ganz viel wert.
Aber wir sollten über dieses Thema diskutieren, weil es jetzt tatsächlich im
Juli im Bundestag Thema war.
Noch nicht mit einem abschließenden Entschluss.
Es gibt zwei Entwürfe, wie die Suizidhilfe organisiert werden soll in Deutschland.
Es gab ja das Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das reagiert werden muss,
dass es dem Einzelnen freistehen muss, sich das Leben zu nehmen und auch dabei
ärztliche Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Nicht nur ärztliche, sondern grundsätzliche Assistenz.
Grundsätzliche Assistenz. Da ist die Frage, wie weit soll die jetzt gehen?
Ich, um das gleich deutlich zu machen, bin gegen eine aktive Suizidhilfe.
Ich kann das jetzt für mich persönlich, aber das ist dann eine private Angelegenheit,
christlich begründen, das gehört jetzt eher hier nicht her. Du bist ausgetreten.
Ja, aber ich bin aus der Kirche ausgetreten, aber nicht aus dem Christentum
ausgetreten. Das kann man ja in dem Sinne gar nicht, man ist ja auch getauft.
Aber da ist klar, dass das Selbsttötungsverbot im Christentum,
im Übrigen in allen monotheistischen Religionen fest verankert.
Hast du gewusst, dass das korreliert mit dem Selbstbefriedigungsverbot?
Finde ich ganz interessant eigentlich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich kenne den Diskurs, ja.
Und das meine ich auch im Verweis auf, es geht auch um Erlösung dabei,
nicht immer nur um Leid und Beendung, sondern auch um Erlösung,
also etwas komplizierterer Diskurs.
Dann kann ich das mit Kant begründen, warum man eine Pflicht hat, das Leben zu leben.
Ich würde aber auch davon jetzt an dieser Stelle absehen, wir wollen jetzt hier
nicht in eine große philosophische Auseinandersetzung gehen.
Ich würde tatsächlich das Thema lieber dahin leiten, dass ich sage, wir müssen mal schauen.
Was wir eigentlich verursachen damit, wenn wir diese Sterbehilfe in dieser Weise
liberalisieren, beziehungsweise Suizidhilfe.
Man muss nämlich auch sagen, es geht jetzt hier nicht um Personen,
nur die in einem Endstadium auf einer Station sich befinden und sich nicht mehr
regen können oder sich noch regen können, Wir können aber sagen,
ich ertrage jetzt meine Schmerzen nicht mehr.
Bitte beendet das hier. Also darum geht es auch. Aber es geht auch tatsächlich
darum, dass jemand, der einen Suizidwunsch hat, den auch erfüllt bekommt.
Beziehungsweise dass er dabei eine Assistenz erfährt.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, die Ärzte, die dann beispielsweise ein Medikament
verschreiben würden, sind nicht verpflichtet dafür, das zu tun.
Es ist nicht so, wie sonst Ärzte verpflichtet sind zu helfen.
Man muss sagen, jeder Arzt muss das gewährleisten. Man sieht schon,
da gibt es eine Differenz.
Es ist nicht irgendeine medizinische Behandlung, wo man sonst einem Arzt ja
auch ... Man könnte ihn ja sonst verklagen und sagen, du hast aber die Pflicht,
mir zu helfen. Wir hören jetzt in diese Debatte rein.
Und zwar gab es da zwei Anträge. von Helling, Plahr und Künast,
also Renate Künast und Katrin Helling, Plahr, ich glaube SPD und dieser Entwurf ist der liberalere.
Wir hören jetzt hier mal kurz rein.
Erwachsene, die selbstbestimmt sterben möchten, können sich an einen Arzt ihres
Vertrauens wenden und dort die Verschreibung eines Medikaments erbitten.
Selbstverständlich ist niemand zur Hilfeleistung verpflichtet.
Ist der Arzt grundsätzlich bereit, obliegt es ihm, sich ein umfassendes Bild
davon zu machen, ob der Betroffene aus autonom gebildetem freiem Willen heraushandelt.
Durch die vorherige obligatorische Beratung in einer Beratungsstelle gewährleisten
wir ebenso Sicherheit wie durch das ärztliche Vier-Augen-Prinzip in bereits
existenziellen Leidenssituationen.
Hans-Dieter, es gibt ein Beratungsgespräch und dann soll daraufhin folgend dann
das Gespräch mit dem Arzt sein.
Das soll alles sehr schnell stattfinden können.
Anders sieht es der Vorschlag von Lars Castellucci vor. Es haben sich zwei Gruppen gebildet.
Beide Gruppen sind für eine Suizidhilfe, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht das vorsieht.
Diese Gruppe um Castellucci sieht das anders.
Hier wird gesagt, das Gericht hat nicht nur die Selbstbestimmung stark gemacht.
Gleichzeitig hat uns das Gericht mitgegeben,
dass wir nicht einfach diese Selbstbestimmung voraussetzen können.
Es hat gesagt, dass wir als Gesetzgeber, dafür Sorge zu tragen haben,
dass sie sich bei dem Entschluss, assistierten Suizid zu wirklich um eine freie Entscheidung handeln.
Mit unserem Gesetzentwurf eröffnen wir erstmals Ärztinnen und Ärzten die Möglichkeit,
ein todbringendes Mittel für einen assistierten Suizid zu verschreiben.
Und wir definieren ein Schutzkonzept, das diesen freien Willen der Menschen
in den Mittelpunkt stellt.
Wer organisiert, regelmäßig Suizidhilfe anbietet und sich nicht an das Schutzkonzept
hält, Er erkennt nach unserem Entwurf die Konsequenzen. Er macht sich strafbar.
Kasseluschi will das auch mit ins Strafrecht überführen. Dass man nicht da einen
Missbrauch hat, der am Ende nicht geahndet werden kann.
Das ist sicherlich eine Hemmschwelle.
Das macht das Ganze komplizierter, als das die Gruppe um Künast-Helling-Plath
vorsieht. Aber er sagt, das sei entscheidend, Das sei entscheidend,
um auch diesen Schutz zu gewährleisten.
Weiter sagt er ...
Niemand in diesem Land soll sich überflüssig fühlen. Niemand in diesem Land
soll sich gedrängt fühlen in einen assistierten Suizid hinein,
weil andere Hilfe nicht erreichbar ist.
Bin ich im Alter oder in Krankheit gut versorgt?
Kann ich mir das alles noch leisten?
Das sind doch Fragen, die hinter Suizidgedanken stecken.
Die sozialen Fragen blitzen hier auf.
Dieses Kanada Beispiel besprochen.
Dazu kommen wir gleich ausführlich.
Okay, weil was man auch bei Castellucci im Hintergrund ist ja immer,
wir haben jetzt immer so, es war ja auch damals einer dieser Kläger,
der dann viel im Fernsehen war, der dieses Verfassungsgerichtsurteil hervorgerufen
oder provoziert hat mit diesem ich weiß jetzt medizinisch gesehen alle Diagnosen
sind geschrieben und unveränderbar,
meine Zeit läuft ab und ich will jetzt noch selbstbestimmt entscheiden,
wie es dann entsprechend weitergeht und so und dieses also das versteht man
dann immer und was er jetzt hier anmerkt ist ja dieses ja so rein gedrängt werden
Jemand soll frei entscheiden usw.
Wir haben bei der Pflege gerade die Diskussion und da hat auch der Laumann,
der ja so der CDA-Flügel da, der CDU und auch mal so ein kleines soziales Gewissen und er meint so,
ja mit der Pflege, das ist ja so, das ist ja nur ein Teil, Kasko und alles so
weiter, das ist ja keine Vollversicherung und da muss man so ein bisschen gucken,
inwieweit man damit kommt und es ist natürlich schon ein Problem,
dass sehr viele Erbe verpflegt wird.
Also das einfach und das ist das Ding, worüber die hier, dass die,
der junge Teil der Familie, den alten Teil der Familie aus dem Leben drängt,
anstatt noch sieben Jahre 100.000 Euro für Pflege auszugeben.
Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit handfesten Sachen zu tun.
Deswegen argumentiere ich so scharf.
Und das ist mein Punkt, also der dritte neben dem Christentum und Kant,
das ist für mich der Grund, dass ich sagen würde, besser nicht.
Aber wir gehen da mal weiter.
Mit Suizidgedanken ist es schwierig, wie die zu beurteilen sind.
Aber Suizidgedanken schwanken meist. Selbst bei denen, die Suizid begehen und
noch am Leben sind, weil er verfehlt ist, sagen hinterher 80,
90 Prozent, sie sind froh, dass sie es überlebt haben.
Und deshalb, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, was nicht geht,
ist einmal zu einer Beratungsstelle gehen, dort einen Beratungsschein bekommen,
dann sofort das Rezept ausgestellt zu bekommen. So kann man die Dauerhaftigkeit
von Suizidwünschen nicht feststellen.
Ja, was ich da mal raushöre, also, klar, Zeit kann viele Wunden heilen und so, diese Botschaft.
Aber wir reden hier wirklich von unter drei Monaten, ne?
Genau, und da muss man sich ja fragen, gerade bei so Beratungsgesprächen ...
Die kommen natürlich mit, mein Leben ist so und so, ich wähle lieber den Tod.
Und die Frage, kann man ja auch soziologisch so ein bisschen,
wenn man irgendein Paradox oder Problem nicht auflösen kann,
dann muss man es halt so austauschen.
Ja. Dann sagt man halt, okay, aber die, angenommen es wäre jetzt nicht mehr
Leben oder Tod, sondern dieses Leben oder jenes Leben, dass man dann schon mal
anfängt darüber nachzudenken, unter welchen Bedingungen könnte ich mir denn
doch wieder Leben vorstellen und so weiter und so fort.
Selbst mit Gröbsten Verletzungen durch Unfälle oder was auch immer,
was einen zuerst so Verzweiflung macht.
Das fand weder in der alten Republik Diskussionen so weit statt,
noch sonst irgendwie, weil man sich auch fragt, ja mit welchen Ressourcen wird
denn in so eine Diskussion reingegangen? Sie muss ja auch glaubhaft sein.
Wenn du so eine riesige Armutswelle hast und dann machst du aber staatlicherseits
oder wie auch immer so ein Angebot, da könnt ihr euch,
ein alternatives Leben abholen. Ihr müsst nur behaupten, ihr wärt suizidal.
Dann eröffnet das natürlich auch so ein paar...
Wir machen dieses Tor wirklich zur Hölle gleich auf. Wir hören mal gerade hier
Renate Künast, die da wirklich sehr hemmsärmelig auftritt.
Also die ganze Rede hören wir nicht. Das fand ich ziemlich unseriös.
Aber wir hören jetzt mal so einen Auszug.
In meinem ersten Beruf bin ich Sozialarbeiterin mit dem Schwerpunkt Psychiatrie-Strafverzüger.
Ich hatte viel mit Suizid, viel mit Menschen mit psychischen Belastungen, Erkrankungen zu tun.
Sorry, aber auch Sozialarbeiterinnen und Sozialarbeiter, Psychologen,
die in solchen Bereichen arbeiten, können feststellen, ob jemand eine Störung
hat, meine Damen und Herren, nicht frei verantwortlich ist. Ich bitte Sie ...
Das ist diese Frage der Freiverantwortlichkeit.
Da sagst du, die können das auch alle Sozialarbeiter. Also denen mutet man das
auch dann zu, mit darüber zu entscheiden.
Ja, die haben natürlich da eine Expertise drin.
Aber man muss sagen, zu einer Diagnose gehört auch eine Prognose.
Bei vielen psychischen Krankheiten heißt es einfach, okay, wir haben es jetzt
diagnostiziert, aber ja, was willst du machen?
Ja, ich habe mich ein bisschen gescheut, das zu tun, aber ich mache es jetzt
trotzdem, weil wir ja hier alle schon groß sind. Wir sind alle erwachsen und
wir können uns mit Argumenten auseinandersetzen, ohne dass wir die sonstigen
Positionen der Person teilen.
Und zwar hören wir jetzt einige Clips von Beatrix von Storch.
Sie ist die Einzige, die, also es gibt noch jemand, der für die AfD spricht,
das ist aber nicht besonders erheblich, aber sie ist die Einzige,
die also ganz klar sich gegen eine aktive Suizidhilfe ausspricht.
Und ich würde jetzt mal darum bitten, dass wir auf die Argumente hören und mal
kurz ausklammern, dass hier jemand von der AfD spricht.
Der ansonsten die Sonne verklagen will.
Genau, wir lassen nämlich jetzt gleich mal den Boomerang noch mal zu ihr zurückfallen.
Also ich will jetzt nicht hier sagen, guck mal, ich hätte jetzt nicht getwittert,
da hat aber Beatrice von Storch aber mal recht oder so, sondern wir gucken uns
mal diese Argumentation an, wir werfen den Boomerang mal zur AfD zurück.
Also wir können es ja so anteasern, ich kenne die Clips ja auch nicht,
aber wir können ihr mal kurz zuhören zum Thema assistierter Tod für Deutsche,
während wir gleichzeitig wissen, dass ihr total egal ist, wer so Mittelmeer verstößt.
Genau diese Rahmenung können wir vorab machen. Mir geht es um was anderes.
Aber diese Rahmenung können wir vorab machen.
Was von der AfD hochgehalten wird als Schutz vor dem Leben, gilt für Sie als Deutsche.
Das gilt nicht für die anderen. Sonst würde man nicht über Flüchtlinge reden
und eine solche Politik einfordern.
Das ist schon verlogen an sich. Aber trotzdem können wir uns auf die Argumente konzentrieren.
Zu einem Akt persönlicher Autonomie zu erklären, führt uns nach meiner festen
Überzeugung auf einen einen entsetzlichen Tödlichen.
Die Niederlande sind diesen Weg vor uns gegangen, das Ergebnis ist verheerend. 2021 7.666,
Tote durch assistierten Suizid und dort überwiegend durch Tötung auf Verlangen.
Das sind viereinhalb Prozent aller Sterbefälle dort, zehn Prozent mehr als im
letzten Jahr, zehnmal mehr als Verkehrstote.
Hochgerechnet auf Deutschland wären das 34.000, dreimal mehr als zurzeit.
Es sind schon mal ganz erhebliche Zahlen, die auch stimmen.
Ja, und da wir aber jetzt schon auf dem Track sind, sozusagen den Raum nochmal
zu markieren, wer spricht und was wird gesagt, will ich jetzt auch nochmal sagen.
Diese Beschäftigung mit der Alten Republik, also mit den Zahlen,
es ist fast wie so ein bisschen bei Oppenheimer, man baut das so zusammen und
am Ende wird es einen gigantischen Lichtblitz geben und das wird heißer als
die Sonne. Das glaube ich dir nicht. Doch, wird es geben. Das glaube ich dir
nicht. Doch, wird es geben. Ich zeige es dir.
Altenrepublik heißt, gerade für Deutschland, wir werden so viele,
so alte, so immobile, morbide oder wie das auch immer heißt,
multiple kranke Menschen mit Übergewicht, die sich jede Bordsteinkante hochschleppen,
die eine halbe Stunde für einen Kilometer bis zur Post brauchen und so weiter,
dass man hier, wenn sie sagt, das betrifft vier Prozent.
Die nicht mehr natürlich sterben. Also wir brauchen sowieso einen ganz anderen
Umgang mit Tod an sich. So sterben, lernen und so weiter, die Bücher sind geschrieben.
Ich weiß noch nicht, in welchem Ausmaß und so, aber ich glaube,
es wird wirklich sehr dramatisch die nächsten 20 Jahre. Und wenn wir es irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, so eine Quote bei vier Prozent, ich weiß nicht,
ob das ein humaner Weg ist, diese Zahl so klein zu halten.
Weil unter der Frage, wie umgehen mit Leid und überhaupt und so,
Menschen dadurch, dass jetzt kollektiv so viele alt werden, sehen die ja auch, wie andere alt werden.
Wir haben jetzt immer eine Generation gehabt, bei der noch relativ viele,
relativ lange mobil bleiben und so weiter.
Aber es müsste ja dann darum gehen, dass dieses Altern als eine Möglichkeit
angesehen wird, also dass nicht mehr Alter defizitär vorkommt.
Ja, aber wir haben bisher.
Also natürlich mindert das Alter in der Regel eine gewisse Lebensqualität insofern,
dass man nicht mehr so mobil ist oder gewisse Dinge nicht mehr kann.
Das ist ja definitiv so, aber dennoch ist das ja ein Leben, das gelebt werden
kann und auch genossen werden kann in anderer Weise, wie man auch mit 18 andere Dinge macht als mit 40.
Genau, da will ich gar nichts gegen sagen. Das ist alles genau so.
Ich will nur anmerken, wir haben bisher nur Erfahrung mit Leuten,
die an die natürliche Lebenserwartung stoßen und dann eben sterben,
die in der relevanten Zeit dafür ihres Lebens nicht mit Zucker überströmt wurden,
nicht jeden Meter mit dem Auto gefahren sind und so weiter.
Und jetzt kommt aber demnächst die Generation in das Alter, die einfach diese,
die nicht darauf vorbereitet sind, die letzten Jahre irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Also es wird wirklich sehr, und man wird es auch sehen, es wird wirklich kompliziert.
Als das Suizidhilfegesetz in den Niederlanden beschlossen wurde,
ging es um extreme Fälle, in denen Menschen schwerst krank waren,
ohne Überlebensperspektive.
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr nur um unheilbar Kranke. Es geht immer mehr auch um
körperlich gesunde Menschen, die noch ein langes Leben vor sich hätten,
die eigentlich Hilfe brauchen und suchen.
Also, man hat das erweitert. Und das ist etwas, was wir später bei Kanada erleben
können. Sie bezieht sich auf eine Studie der Kingston-Uni.
Stimmt, was sie da sagt? Manchmal ist mit der AfD und Studien so eine Sache.
Die Kingston-Universität hat eine Studie gemacht in den Niederlanden.
Dort werden Menschen mit geistiger Behinderung und Autismus legal getötet.
Die Studie hat 39 solcher Fälle aus 2012 bis 2021 aufgedeckt.
2021 aufgedeckt bei einer Stichprobe von 900 aus 60.000 Fällen.
Wenn man das auf Deutschland, auf die Gesamtzahl hochrechnet oder auf Deutschland
hochrechnet, dann wären das in Deutschland elfeinhalb tausend Menschen,
geistig Behinderte und Autisten.
Und sie bringt dann noch ein Beispiel.
Ein besonders trauriges Beispiel aus der Studie. Ein junger Mann in seinen 20er
Jahren, der den Grund für seinen Sterbewunsch benennt. Soziale Isolation.
Er wollte sterben, weil er einsam war.
Der Kreis potenziell Betroffener wird damit fast grenzenlos.
In Umfragen des sozioökonomischen Panels geben 42% der Deutschen an,
dass sie sich einsam fühlen.
Der niederländische Psychiater Dr. Bram Sitzu erklärt die Motivation der Menschen,
Assistenz beim Suizid zu suchen, ich zitiere, Sie glauben, dass dies das Ende
Ihrer Probleme und das Ende der Probleme Ihrer Familien sein wird.
Das heißt, Sie nehmen sich das Leben, weil Sie Ihrer Familie nicht zur Last
fallen wollen. Das ist schrecklich.
Wir hören Beatrix von Storch mit einem völlig anderen Ton. Ich hatte sie fast
nicht erkannt, ich hab's mir angesehen.
Aber wenn es mir so vorspielen würde, die sie gar nicht so stimmlich gleich erkennen.
Ich glaube, dass sie das da ernst meint in der Sache.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ihre katholische Prägung. Es passt nur nicht zu ihrer
Politik und es passt vor allem nicht dazu, wenn wir jetzt hören,
was sie sonst sagt. Sie spricht jetzt über den sozialen Druck.
Und wir wissen, welche Partei den sozialen Druck noch erheblich erhöhen würde.
Und zwar auf alle und dann noch mal im Speziellen auf Migranten und alle, die kommen könnten.
Wer stellt sich denn hier gegen jede Art von Umverteilung? Wer kämpft gegen
die Erbschaftsteuer, Vermögenssteuer des Teufels?
Wer nimmt überall das Geld raus? Wer versucht, hier ganz enge Grenzen zu ziehen?
Wer überhaupt noch als Freund infrage kommt?
Insofern eigenartig, was sie hier uns erzählt.
Die vorliegenden Gesetzentwürfe betonen, dass der Suizid aus freien Stücken
erfolgen soll. als autonome Entscheidung. Sie sehen also alle die Gefahr,
dass Menschen sich unter sozialem Druck das Leben nehmen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Sie das verhindern werden, keiner der Entwürfe.
Gegen sozialen Druck hilft keine auch doppelte Beratungspflicht und kein Vermerk
auf einem Beratungsschein.
Gerade Krisenzeiten wächst der Druck auf Alte und Kranke, nicht nur auf die, aber auf die besonders.
Und wir werden sehr viel mehr Alte und Kranke haben ohne Familien und sehr viel mehr Krise.
Die AfD hat kein Konzept, wie man mit diesem Problem umgeht.
Sie zählt weiter auf Pflegekrise und so was ein. Das habe ich nicht mitgebracht.
Sie hält eine soziale Rede. Sie müsste am Ende sagen, wir machen nichts in diese Richtung.
Wir könnten nur dafür sorgen, dass dann nicht die Sterbehilfe liberalisiert
wird. Und hier sehe ich das, deswegen habe ich die Clips mitgebracht.
Ich finde die Argumente, die sie bringt, absolut richtig.
Sie ist, diese Argumente werden vorgebracht, aber von der falschen Person.
Weil sie alles, was sie dort beschreibt, mit ihrer Politik verstärkt.
Und Leute dadurch, wenn nicht in den Selbstmord, dann in Situationen treibt,
die ganz furchtbar sind.
Jetzt müsste man aber eigentlich noch mal zu so einer Politik des Lebens kommen,
also von anderer Seite, von anderen Parteien, die eigentlich stark machen,
wir müssen da einen anderen Weg noch mal finden.
Vielleicht ist auch dieser Castellucci-Vorschlag noch zu liberal oder wie man
das ausdrücken will. Man kann das übrigens da nicht mit konservativ und liberal
oder so was gut machen, denn die Parteien haben alle, bis auf AfD,
haben alle zusammengearbeitet bei beiden Entwürfen.
Also wir hören hier ja Politiker von CSU bis Linke, die sich da zusammengeschlossen haben.
Aber dass man nochmal ganz klar sagt, wir müssen eigentlich erst über alle sozialen
Fragen und all das nochmal ganz neu reden, bevor man zu dem anderen kommt.
Von Storch sagt dann auch noch Folgendes.
Die durchschnittliche Wartezeit auf einen Therapieplatz für Menschen in einer
psychischen Notlage...
Was wird die Folge sein, wenn es angesichts der Krise in der Pflege und der
Gesundheitsvorsorge einfacher sein wird,
eine wohnortnahe, ergebnisoffene Suizidberatung zu bekommen als einen Pflege- oder Therapieplatz?
Auch die richtige Frage. Aber die AfD wird keine Antwort darauf geben.
Sie sagt nur, wir bleiben hier beim Verbot. Ich halte das Verbot für richtig,
weiß nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich würde mit meiner Position beim Bundesverfassungsgericht
nicht durchkommen. Aber zumindest ist hier aufgerufen, was zu tun ist.
Du bist schon vor drei Jahren, das ist alles schon geschriebene Geschichte,
mit einem grundsätzlichen Verbot nicht durchgekommen.
Wir werden jetzt mal sehen, was man damit öffnet, Tür und Tor,
nämlich für ganz, ganz schreckliche Dinge. Lassen wir erst noch die Debatte
ein bisschen weiterlaufen.
Kirsten Kappert-Gonther von den Grünen sagt folgendes.
Als Fachärztin für Psychiatrie und Psychotherapie habe ich viele suizidale Menschen begleitet.
Ich frage mich, wer von Ihnen würde heute nicht mehr leben?
Wäre der assistierte Suizid als vermeintliche einfache Lösung leichter zu erreichen
gewesen als Hilfe in Krisen und fürsorgliche Versorgung am Ende des Lebens?
Und darum habe ich ein großes Unbehagen bezüglich einer staatlich finanzierten
Suizidberatungs-Infrastruktur, wie sie von der anderen Gruppe vorgeschlagen wurde.
Das will ich auch noch mal deutlich machen. Das ist ein sehr gutes Argument,
nämlich dieses staatlich finanzierte auch herauszuheben.
Ich will niemanden als Individuum absprechen, das steht mir auch gar nicht zu,
irgendwas zu beurteilen.
Ich glaube aber, wo man tatsächlich eine staatliche Infrastruktur schafft,
begibt der Staat sich auf einen Weg, der,
ja nicht nur aufs glatte Eis führt, sondern der wirklich schwierig werden kann.
Und wenn man das mal dann hoch skaliert, du hast uns das ja alles in alten republik aufgeschlüsselt,
wohin wir schlittern und wenn man sieht, wie wenig Menschen verdienen,
wenn wir sehen, dass wir jetzt in der Rezession schlittern und die meisten Wirtschaftsjournalisten
noch nicht mal willens sind auszusprechen, woran das liegt und dann sagen,
jetzt brauchen wir aber auch mal Bürokratieabbau oder mehr Zukunftsoptimismus.
Dann sehe ich da sehr, sehr viel auf uns zukommen und wir müssen auch diese
doch ganz anderen Beispielen in den Blick nehmen, jetzt hier Stefan Pilsinger von der CSU.
Das Beispiel des US-Amerikaners Kevin Hines.
Den jungen Mann, der an einer bipolaren Störung und schweren Depressionen leidet,
hatte plötzlich ein starkes Gefühl ergriffen, jetzt sterben zu wollen.
Er sprang von der Golden Gate Bridge in San Francisco und überlebte im Gegensatz
zu 99 Prozent der anderen gesprungenen Personen.
Er erzählt selbst, dass er noch im freien Fall tief bereut habe, gesprungen zu sein.
Drei Jahre lang war Kevin Hines nach seinem Suizidversuch in Krankenhäusern
und einer geschlossenen Psychiatrie.
Dort heilten nicht nur die gebrochenen Wirbeln und Beckenknochen,
er fand auch einen Weg, Weg, sich mit Medikamenten und einem regelmäßigen Tagesablauf zu stabilisieren.
Er hat sich mit seiner Krankheit intensiv auseinandergesetzt und setzt sich
selbst zum Ziel, anderen Menschen mit ähnlichen Problemen und Symptomen zu helfen.
Seither engagiert sich Kevin Hines im Bereich der Suizidprävention.
Wäre Kevin Hines von einem Sterbehilfeverein das schnelle Ende in harmonischer
Atmosphäre mit einer schmerzfreien Pille angeboten worden, hätten er dies vielleicht
in dieser Ausnahmesituation angenommen.
Also dieses Beispiel ist doch sehr gut, denn ich würde grundsätzlich erst mal
sagen, vielleicht helfen uns nicht bei allen politischen Diskussionen immer
diese krassen Einzelfälle so weiter.
Aber in dem Fall haben wir es ja wirklich mit einem erheblichen Einzelfall zu
tun, weil dadurch, dass alle anderen gestorben sind, ja, ich sag 99 Prozent
der anderen Fälle sind gestorben, also da kann man schon mal dadurch das erst
so salopp Runde davon ausgehen, 99 Leute sind gestorben, einer hat überlebt.
Und der eine schildert nun, was wir dann automatisch unterstellen auch für die anderen.
Und das Szenario, was er schildert, ist ja, ich habe mich ganz schwer getan
und immer dazu tendiert, ich möchte sterben.
Solange er diese Entscheidung noch hatte. Und in dem Moment,
wo er gesprungen ist und er sich selbst die Entscheidungshoheit genommen wird,
hat er es sofort bereut, weil keine Alternative mehr da war.
Da liegt doch ein ganz großer Schlüssel drin, dass solange noch eine Alternative
denkbar ist, Rettung in Aussicht steht.
Und darüber kann man ja dann auch politisch handhaben, Denn wie kann denn diese Alternative aussehen?
Also, in dem Moment, wo über den Tod gesprochen wird, deswegen auch für alle,
die jetzt zuhören, so ein trübseliges Thema und so weiter, ist es eben nicht.
Denn in dem Moment, wo man von außerhalb oder auf der anderen Seite der Unterscheidung Leben-Tod,
nämlich vom Tod aus oder sogar im selbstgewählten Tod, darüber spricht,
redet man ja nicht nur über den Tod, sondern auch über das Leben.
Man kann ja die andere Seite der Entscheidung rausblenden.
Und in dem Moment eröffnet sich ja so viel, wie zum Beispiel unsere Kritik eben an der AfD.
Wenn die AfD so über den Tod redet, ja, dann muss sie auch anders über das Leben reden.
Und dann eröffnet sich da die politische Dimension. Wie?
Und an dem Beispiel, das er jetzt nannte, sieht man doch …,
Solange die Unterscheidung immer mit zwei Seiten da ist. Also nicht einfach
nur die Geschichte ist geschrieben und der Moment ist schon zu spät.
Er ist gesprungen und kann das nicht mehr ändern.
Solange die Entscheidung noch vor uns liegt, kann man eben auch noch entscheiden.
Solange fühlt man sich nachher im eigenen Haus und der eigenen Biografie und
so weiter. Und da sind doch so unglaublich viele Ansetzungspunkte.
Um es einfach politisch zu sagen, wenn die bei der AfD feststellen,
dass Einsamkeit der Treiber ist, ja können wir nichts gegen Einsamkeit tun,
eigentlich, dass sie dann das nicht sozusagen als Türöffner für die politische
Diskussion zumindest annehmen.
Wir tragen es ja nun von außen an sie heran. Rede doch so über das Leben,
wie ihr über den Tod reden wollt. Das kann man doch machen.
Aus der Taz, wenige Tage alt. In Berlin hatte sich 2021 ein Mann,
der wegen Eigenbedarfs nach 25 Jahren aus seiner Kreuzberger Wohnung geräumt
werden sollte, das Leben genommen.
Schon zuvor hatte er angekündigt, bevor ich hier Für bundesweite Schlagzeilen
sorgte auch der Fall von Rosemarie F.
Die schwerbehinderte Rentnerin war 2013 wegen Mietrückständen zwangsgeräumt worden.
Zwei Tage später in einer Kältehilfe-Einrichtung verstorben.
Wir sehen hier, wie die soziale Not Tod und Suizid produziert.
Wenn wir das jetzt mal diesen sozialen Kontext, wir können auch,
um auch mal Marx zu nehmen, sagen, Also wir können auch, um auch mal Marx zu
nehmen, sagen, das Sein bestimmt das Bewusstsein.
Dann finde ich es doch ganz erstaunlich, wenn man jetzt hier z.B.
Von der SPD, von dieser Henning-Plagg-Künast-Gruppe, Folgendes sagen hört.
Und wir können und dürfen nicht den Menschen vor der Ausübung seiner Freiheit
schützen. Und wir können und dürfen nicht, so schwer uns das fallen mag,
den Menschen vor sich selbst schützen. schützen. So.
Den Menschen dürfen wir nicht vor sich selbst schützen. Was macht der Staat laufend?
Er schützt die Bürger vor sich selbst. Er schützt die Bürger nicht nur für andere.
Man sagt nicht nur an der Tempolimit.
Klar, da würde man sagen, da schützen wir irgendwelche anderen Autofahrer oder die Umwelt.
Aber die Tatsache, dass man gewisse Zigaretten mit höherem Nikotin nicht mehr
importieren kann, ist ja nicht irgendein Schutz für andere.
Sondern man mutet mir als Objekt nicht zu, dass ich das mache.
Es gibt viele Orte, wo betreten verboten steht. Wo ich denke,
ist doch meine Entscheidung. Kann ich da mal raufgehen, wenn ich runterfalle?
Wir können auch ein libertäres Argument machen.
Warum nicht? Ich werde laufend bevormundet, dass ich mein Einkommen so und so versteuern muss.
Und kann nicht mal dann, außer über eine demokratische Konstruktion,
alle vier Jahre wählen, entscheiden, was mit dem Geld passiert.
Ich könnte ja jetzt auch sagen, ich will mit meinem Steuergeld keine Waffen
finanzieren und kann aber nichts dagegen machen.
Ich werde laufend bevormundet. Wir können darüber nachdenken,
wie weit kann die Bevormundung gehen und womit ist Bevormundung sinnvoll,
um den anderen zu schützen. Aber das Individuum wird in einem Staat auch bevormundet.
Stimmt, trotzdem kleine Gegenrede.
Bis hin zu Werbung, die verboten ist für irgendwelche Süßigkeiten.
Genau, aber da wird ja auf andere Art und Weise unterstellt,
dass der Staat da für dich eigentlich in deinem Sinne handelt.
Ja, aber das muss ich ja, das kann ich ja hier auch machen. Da kann ich sagen,
also eigentlich, es mag sein, dass du Suizidwünsche hast, aber ich als Staat
weiß es besser und lasse es.
Ja, ich würde trotzdem noch mal anmerken, Wir sind ja hier auf einem,
was die einfach den Akt der Handlung und so weiter angeht, oder auch die Art
der Möglichkeiten, die Variation, das Reichtum, wie man sich umbringen kann.
In so einem Bereich, wo der Staat, auch wenn er will, nicht rein regieren kann.
Ja.
Es ist ja was anderes, ich möchte mich töten, als ich möchte nach Berlin fahren.
Wenn ich nach Berlin fahre, brauche ich einfach Strecke, also Straße,
Zug oder was auch immer. Und da wird einfach reglementiert, wie ich mich da verhalte.
Die Alternative ist, ich fahre halt nicht nach Berlin, sondern bin einfach hier.
Das ist ja in dem Fall ein bisschen anders.
Die Art der Mitte.
Sind ja nicht vom Staat in diesem Maße.
Nee, das ist ja auch nicht die Sache. Aber eine Bevormundung ist ja laut Helge
Lindh, wenn nach dem Castellucci-Vorschlag man das unter strafrechtliche Konsequenzen stellt.
Wenn man außerdem mehr als dieses Minimalberatungskonstrukt haben möchte,
dass das schon etwas sei, wo der Staat zu sehr eingreift.
Und dem Individuum den Willen streitig macht.
Und da würde ich einfach sagen, weil wir machen das bei so vielen kleinen Dingen,
wird laufend das Individuum ...
Also wir können auch jetzt, denke an Corona, da gab es ja auch durchaus Maßnahmen,
die nur meinem Selbstschutz dienten, an die ich mich halten sollte.
Das war ja nicht immer nur auf das Ganze gesehen. Und da haben wir das auch akzeptiert.
Ich bin auch gar nicht, ich bin, ich will ja deutlich machen,
ich bin nicht gegen gewisse Bevormundungen.
Ich finde die durchaus sinnvoll. Ich bin ja nicht ein ultra Libertärer,
aber ich finde, dass es nicht richtig ist, so zu tun, als würde der Staat sich
ja sonst raushalten, das tut er laufend nicht.
Aber die Bevormundung, die hier zur Rede steht, ist auf die Assistenten gemünzt,
nicht auf diejenigen mit dem Suizidwunsch.
Es soll auf die Überschwappen, aber da weiß man ja, da ist die politische Handhabe ...
Nein, doch, doch, die Bevormundung meint, dass diese Castellucci-Gruppe ja viel
mehr Beratung vorsieht.
Also, dass das viel komplizierter wird, um am Ende, sag ich mal,
den Stempel zu bekommen.
Assistenz anzunehmen. Um diese Suizidhilfe zu bekommen. Und das wird jetzt hier
von der anderen Gruppe als Bevormundung angesehen. Wir hören noch jemand von der anderen Gruppe.
Es steht uns nicht zu, als Gesetzgeber, als Verbände und Kirchen,
als Staat und als Gesellschaft, Es steht uns nicht zu, über die Motive des Suizidwunsches zu urteilen.
Aber das machen wir doch laufend auch sonst. Wir urteilen doch auch bei einem Prozess über Motive.
Man muss doch auch hier über Motive. Da kann ich doch nicht sagen,
wenn da jemand sagt, ich habe eine Wohnungsnot, ist das dasselbe ein Motiv wie
jemand, der sagt, ich bin ganz schlimm krank und habe Angst vor den Schmerzen, die mir noch drohen.
Um das deutlich zu machen, ich will das hier nicht so absolut stellen.
Ich bin gegen diese aktive Sterbehilfe.
Ich würde auch sagen, dass man diese ganze Palliativmedizin viel mehr ausarbeiten sollte.
Denn das Sagen, zumindest Palliativmediziner, ist es in überwiegenden Fällen
möglich, schmerzfrei zu sterben mit Morphium et cetera.
Das ist auch was, was nicht genügend ausgebaut ist. Aber hier diese eigenartige
Willensfreiheit zu stark zu machen,
im Übrigen, wenn man sich das so anschaut, Im Übrigen, sowieso,
für mich hochinteressant, ich bin immer für die Willensfreiheit,
also hab das immer als Fakt angesehen.
Aber wir haben seit 25 Jahren einen Diskurs, der übrigens auch viel von Links-Progressiven
geführt wird, dass es Willensfreiheit gar nicht gibt. Aber jetzt plötzlich,
hier gibt es jetzt die Willensfreiheit, hier ist wieder alles klar.
Sonst haben wir einen Diskurs, dass wir die Leute natschen müssen,
dass wir dies und das, also dann nimmt man all die Leute nicht als freie Subjekte wahr.
Wir hatten einen Diskurs für die Impfpflicht, wo man das nicht gesehen hat.
Ich habe nichts gegen diese Bevormundung. Ich habe partiell mit der Impfpflicht sogar geliebäugelt.
Aber ich würde hier mal fragen, wie kann das sein, dass wir in solchen Notlagen
von einem freien Willen ausgehen können?
Das mag es nicht, ich will das nicht sagen. Aber wir haben durch diese Gegenbeispiele
erfahren, Na ja, das ist so eine Sache. Da finde ich gut, dass Katrin Vogler
von der Linken, die zu der anderen Gruppe gehört, Folgendes sagt.
Mir fehlt in der ganzen Debatte häufig ein realistischer Blick auf unsere Gesellschaft.
Manchmal wird versucht, ein Bild von Selbstbestimmung zu zeichnen,
das vollkommen losgelöst erscheint von gesellschaftlichen und sozialen Bedingungen,
von persönlichen Krisen und von dem Umfeld, in dem wir alle leben.
Die Lebenswelt und Menschenbild ist meiner Ansicht nach nicht besonders realistisch.
Es ist geprägt durch die Brille von wohl situierten Menschen mit hoher Bildung
und entsprechendem Selbstbewusstsein.
Ja und ich würde noch einen Clip direkt daran anschließen von Elisabeth Winkelmeier von der Union.
Ältere Frau mit dem teuren Heimplatz, der junge Mensch im Rollstuhl,
der auf Hilfe angewiesen ist.
Sie dürfen nicht darüber nachdenken müssen und sie sollten noch nicht mal zwingend
damit konfrontiert sein,
ob sie Kosten verursachen, ob sie jemandem zur Last fallen und der Suizid nicht
eine nachhaltige Lösung wäre.
Und da glaube ich, hat Beatrix von Storch recht, wenn sie sagt,
das ist im Prinzip jetzt schon gelaufen.
Also diese Konfrontation ist jetzt schon da. Und das ist ganz furchtbar.
Und das macht Winkelmeier hier noch mal sehr deutlich, dass man Selbstbestimmung
auch noch mal anders zu fassen hat.
Selbstbestimmung wahrt auch der oder die, die eine Krankheit annimmt,
die sich auf Hilfsbedürftigkeit einlässt.
Auch wer in allem auf Hilfe angewiesen ist, wahrt seine Würde.
Das ist bald seine Würde.
Das haben wir auch, so einen sehr verkürzten Diskurs, dass immer,
wenn ich alles machen kann ...
Das ist die liberale Freiheit. Ich steige in den Porsche und mache mir die Welt untertan.
Aber gerade die Vulnerabilität meint zu erkennen, dass man als Mensch mit Behinderung
immer auf Hilfe angewiesen ist. Also nie ganz alleine zurechtkommen wird.
Trotzdem bedeutet das nicht, in seiner Menschlichkeit dadurch minimiert ist.
Oder dass einem da Würde oder etwas fehlt.
Ich fand auch interessant, dass jemand von der FDP, wo ja die Freiheit auch
groß geschrieben wird, dann hier für uns nach Kanada blickt.
Das ist Benjamin-Straße, und dann gehen wir auch nach Kanada.
Dass Drucksituationen bei Menschen entstehen, die nicht auf der Sonnenseite
des Lebens stehen, ist keine irrationale Angst.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2018
wenn man in die Länder schaut, die den assistierten Suizid schon länger anbieten.
In Kanada, berichtet die Nachrichtenagentur AP, im August 2022 wurden Menschen
mit Behinderungen und Pflegebedürftigen mehrfach in den assistierten Suizid
getrieben, um die Kosten im Gesundheitswesen zu senken.
Einem Patienten mit einer fortschreitenden Gehirnerkrankung,
der mit einem Arzt über seine Langzeitpflege sprechen wollte,
hielt der Ethik-Doktor eine Klinik vor.
Jeder Tag im Krankenhaus koste über 1.500 Dollar.
Langzeitpflege sei nicht sein Job. Zitat, mein Job ist es, zu sehen,
ob Sie ein Interesse an Sterbehilfe haben. Zitat Ende. So der Ethikdirektor des Krankenhauses.
Und deswegen sieht auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht eine Gefahr für die Selbstbestimmung
des Einzelnen und hat die Tür zum Strafrecht nicht zugemacht.
Und ich würde diese Tür zum Strafrecht auch nicht zumachen, zumal wir jetzt
nach Kanada blicken und uns mal anhören, was da los ist.
Also seit 2016 gibt es dieses Gesetz zur aktiven Sterbehilfe,
das heißt genau Medical Assistance in Dying, MAID, oder M-A-I-D genannt.
Und wir hören jetzt von Global News.
Die Zahl der Fälle hat sich erhöht. 2021 wählten mehr als 10.000 Kanadier für
eine medizinische Hilfe. Das ist ein 32-Prozent-Aufstieg vom letzten Jahr.
Die Zahlen sind hier schneller aufgestiegen als in anderen Ländern,
in denen es legal ist, inklusive in den Niederlanden und Belgien.
Also diese extrem modernen Länder wie Kanada und so, also da würde man erstmal
kurz sagen, weltweit zivilisatorisch sehr fortschrittlich, so.
Dänemark auch, in Dänemark hat man ja jede zehnte Geburt assistiert mittlerweile.
Und wir kennen das aus Japan, das hatte mir Linmar geschickt als Idee,
so für die auch Altenrepublik.
In Japan ist die Tagezahl, ab wann man Frühchen rettet, viel geringer noch als
in Europa und so, weil man da
einfach so händeringend jedes Lebewesen braucht, das neu im Anmarsch ist.
Und das wäre eigentlich interessant mal so als sehr simple und vielleicht aussagekräftige Heuristik,
ob die Zahl der assistierten Todesfälle mit der Zahl der attestierten Geburten
irgendwie zusammenhängt im fortlauf der entwicklung auch technischer art natürlich,
oder auch zivilisatorischen Weiterentwicklung.
Und in Kanada ist es so, dass das auch einem Gerichtsbeschluss vorausging, dieses Gesetz.
Im Jahr 2015, ich zitiere jetzt hier aus dem Spectator,
stellte der oberste Gerichtshof Kanada 22 Jahre seiner eigenen Rechtsprechung auf den Kopf,
indem er das Verbot der Beihilfe zum Suizid als verfassungswidrig einstufte
und Befürchtungen, dass das Urteil einen Abstieg in die Tötung von Schwachen
einleiten könnte als anekdotische Beispiele ab.
Ein Jahr später verabschiedete dann das Parlament das Gesetz.
Allerdings nur für Menschen, die an einer unheilbaren Krankheit leiden und deren
natürlicher Tod vernünftigerweise vorhersehbar war. Oder vernünftiger,
ja, reasonably foreseeable war.
Es dauerte nur fünf Jahre, Jahre, bis der sprichwörtliche Abhang sichtbar wurde,
als das kanadische Parlament Bill C-7 verabschiedete.
Ein weitreichendes Euthanasie-Gesetz, mit dem das Erfordernis der vernünftigen
Vorhersehbarkeit aufgehoben wurde und das Erfordernis, dass der Zustand unheilbar
sein muss, auch aufgehoben wurde.
Solange jemand an einer Krankheit oder Behinderung leidet, die nicht unter Bedingungen
gelindert werden kann, die sie für akzeptabel halten.
Kann er nun kostenlos das in Anspruch nehmen, was euphemistisch als medizinische
Hilfe beim Sterben bezeichnet wird?
Schon bald entdeckten Kanadier aus dem ganzen Land, dass sie lieber leben würden,
aber zu arm sind, um ihren Zustand in einem akzeptablen Maße zu verbessern.
Nicht zufällig hat Kanada mit die niedrigsten Sozialausgaben aller Industrieländer
Palliativmedizin Minderheit zugänglich und die Wartezeiten im öffentlichen Gesundheitswesen
können unerträglich sein.
Vielleicht haben wir es doch nicht mit so einem ganz fortschrittlichen Land
zu tun, Das scheint ja auch eine historische Fehlspezifikation zu sein,
in dem Moment so ein Gesetz zu schreiben.
Nahezu alle Behindertenverbände des Landes haben sich gegen das neue Gesetz
ausgesprochen. Unerfolg. Die Regierung fand es ausnahmsweise einmal bequem,
diese ansonsten tadellos fortschrittlichen Gruppen zu ignorieren.
Seitdem ist es noch schlimmer geworden.
Man will weiter liberalisieren. Es gab im Frühjahr noch eine Bestrebung zur Liberalisierung.
Das ist jetzt erst mal vertagt, man weiß noch nicht, wohin es geht.
Vielleicht brauchen wir doch in Deutschland auch ein Moratorium an der Tafel.
Dürfen nicht gleichzeitig doppelt so viel anstehen, wenn im Bundestag darüber diskutiert wird.
Ja, Trudeau wurde 2016 damit konfrontiert, sorgt das nicht dafür,
dass da vielleicht Leute sagen, ich finde die soziale Situation für mich so unerträglich.
Und er sagte, das sei ein Ausrutscher-Argument. Das ist ein Ausrutscher-Argument,
das immer wieder ins Spiel gebracht wird, wenn von bestimmten Seiten über medizinische
Sterbehilfe gesprochen wird.
Aber wir haben sehr klare Studien aus der ganzen Welt gesehen,
die gesagt haben, dass das einfach nicht passieren wird. Das ist übrigens auch,
was man hier immer wieder hört. Die Realität ist anders.
Wir hören jetzt hier eine kurze Anhörung aus dem kanadischen Parlament zwischen,
ich glaube, Pierre Poullier-Weir ist, glaube ich, der Justizminister Und Carolee
Bennett ist von der Opposition, wenn ich es jetzt richtig in Erinnerung,
habe.
Manche von ihnen gehen in die Lebensmittelbanken und bitten um Hilfe,
um ihre Leben zu beenden.
Also es ist andersherum von der Opposition, wie man wohl hört.
Nicht weil sie krank sind, sondern weil das Leben so traurig geworden ist und
sie wollen ihre Leben alle zusammen beenden.
Dieses Regierung hat vorgeschlagen, dass Veteranen ihre Leben beenden sollten,
anstatt Hilfe zu bekommen, die sie brauchen. Und jetzt haben sie eröffnet,
dass sie ein Jahr von heute Maßnahmen vorlegen, um die Leben der betroffenen Menschen zu beenden.
Wir müssen Depressionen behandeln und Menschen Hoffnung für ein besseres Leben
geben, anstatt ihr Leben zu beenden. Der ehemalige Minister für Mental Gesundheit.
Herr Sprecher, ich denke, es ist völlig unverantwortlich, dass der Leader der
Opposition das, was das bedeutet, missrepräsentiert.
Alle Assessoren und Providierende von MAID sind verpflichtend trainiert,
Menschen, die suizidisch sind, zu verhindern.
Global News hat berichtet, wir hatten, glaube ich,
schon mal Ausschnitte davon, wie das Gesetz Menschen mit Behinderung unter Druck setzt,
beziehungsweise Menschen mit Behinderung plötzlich einen Ausweg daran sehen,
indem sie dieses Gesetz für sich in Anspruch nehmen. Wir hören einen Ausdruck aus Global News.
Wie viele behinderte Kanadierinnen und Kanadier, ist sie in einem Zyklus von
Pflege und Verzweiflung.
Es gibt keine Hoffnung für jemanden in Ontario. Das ist ein guter Junge.
Sie will also ihr Leben beenden, mit Hilfe der Regierung. Sie können mich 90
Tage lang sterben lassen, das wusste ich. In meinem Fall ist das Problem nicht
die Disziplin, es ist die Armut.
Les Landry ist in derselben Position. Er will leben, aber sieht keine andere
Option als Tod. Das hier ist für meinen Asthma, das hier für meinen COPD.
Seit wann haben wir auf die Werte der Menschenleben in diesem Land aufgehoben?
Es ist eine Frage, die Menschen mit Behinderungen und ihre Anwälte ständig fragen.
Wir können die medizinische Hilfe in etwa zwei Wochen in einer sehr organisierten
und effizienten Art organisieren.
Trotzdem ist es so schwierig, meine Patienten den sozialen Unterstützung,
den sie brauchen, um gut zu leben, zu bekommen. Das ist moralisch anstrengend.
Was ist denn da los in Kanada?
Ja, also man muss sagen, 3,3 Prozent aller Todesfälle gehen auf MAID zurück
und natürlich gibt es ganz viele Leute,
die sehr krank sind und die die letzten Monate nicht noch in Kauf nehmen wollen oder so.
Also das ist jetzt nicht flächendeckend, dass man da ab 70 nahegelegt bekommt
zu sterben oder sobald man eine Behinderung hat. Aber es ist akut so,
dass es aufgegriffen wird. Es gibt viele Geschichten.
Hier eine in The New Atlantis beschreibt Alexander Rakin den Fall von Rosina
Kammes, die an Fibromyalgie und chronischer Leukämie sowie an anderen psychischen
und physischen Krankheiten litt.
Sie legte diese Symptome den MAID-Gutachtern vor und ihr Tod wurde genehmigt.
Und nun, in der Zwischenzeit, schrieb sie in einer Notiz, die offensichtlich
für diejenigen bestimmt war, denen sie eine Vollmacht erteilt hatte,
bittet, halte das alles geheim, solange ich noch lebe, denn das Leiden,
das ich erlebe, ist ein geistiges Leiden, kein körperliches.
Ich denke, wenn sich mehr Menschen um mich kümmern würden, könnte ich das durch
meine körperlichen Krankheiten verursachte Leid allein bewältigen.
Oder hier in The Free Press berichtete Rupa Subramanya über den Fall eines 23-jährigen
Mannes namens Kiano Fabain,
der depressiv und arbeitslos war, außerdem an Diabetes litt und auf einem Auge erblindet war.
Sein Tod wurde genehmigt und für den 22. September 2022 angesetzt.
Der Arzt, der den Eingriff vornehmen sollte, schickte dem Patienten klare antiseptische Anweisungen.
Seien Sie um 8.30 Uhr da, ich werde um 8.45 Uhr nach der Krankenschwester fragen.
Um 9 Uhr kann der Eingriff beginnen. Also so war dann da die Konversation.
Es sind viele erschreckende Geschichten, die die nicht alle jetzt bringen.
Aber es ist natürlich interessant, wenn die in Deutschland so überzeugt sind,
nachdem man gesprungen ist, entscheidet man sich nochmal um.
Sagt man denen in Kanada, okay, dann bist du jetzt schon im Sprung, also du fällst schon.
Der Arzt schickt dir dann so, ja, 8.45 Uhr schlägst du unten auf.
Ja, wie wenn man sich zu einer OP anmeldet.
Genau, was das eigentlich dann im Denken macht, müsste man nochmal,
vielleicht braucht man da dann wieder Literatur oder sowas.
Ja, Raddatz hat da wohl über ihr Tagebuch geführt. Wir wissen ja,
Raddatz ist ja auch in die Schweiz gefahren. Ich hab da immer noch.
Schreibt dann ja darüber, aber Radaz hat natürlich einen hohen Alter und krank und neigen.
Also wir wollen jetzt ja nicht einzelne Fälle hier beurteilen in dem Sinne.
Aber ich glaube so diese gesellschaftliche Dimension und das Tor,
das man eröffnet, sollte klar sein. Noch einmal Global News.
Disability supports vary from province to province. On the low end,
imagine surviving on $705 a month, as people with disabilities do in New Brunswick.
Oder wie ist es, im Vancouver $1,358 pro Monat zu leben, wo die Miete für ein
Einbett-Apartment $2,500 ist?
Die neusten Zahlen aus Statistik Kanada zeigen, dass 41% der Kanadier,
die unter der Armutslinie leben, eine Disabilität haben.
Das sind mehr als 1,5 Millionen Menschen, in der Bevölkerung von Montreal.
Mir war diese extreme Armut überhaupt nicht klar für Kanada.
Man hat da immer tatsächlich so ein liberales Bild.
Noch ein letztes Beispiel, weil das wirklich auch für Furore sorgt in Kanada,
das ist jetzt aus der Anhörung Oktober 22, aber ist immer wieder in der Presse noch,
wie wird eigentlich mit Veteranen umgegangen und es gab tatsächlich den Fall,
dass man einem Veteranen, der sich gemeldet hat bei der Veterans Affair Kanada,
mit Problemen nahelegt.
Denn es gibt da noch andere Optionen.
And the one that we've done it for and has completed made, we are now supporting
his wife and two children.
This was his primary concern, to find out what in the heck are you talking about.
Now, the idea that just talking about services, his response to that was asking
about the legality of it.
First he asked, why are you asking me this?
Well, I just thought you should know, if up the road, but I'm in a good place right now.
He expressed that to me that things were sunshine and roses prior to this phone
call. He was feeling good about life.
Post phone call he left the country.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, das ist ja auch eigentlich nicht gestattet.
Wir haben es hier mit einem Soldaten zu tun, der unter posttraumatischem Stress leidet.
Und dann darf eigentlich laut Gesetz nicht etwas bereitgestellt werden für den Suizid.
Ich meine, gerade beim Thema Suizid sollte das ja vom Patienten ausgehen.
Und nicht mal offeriert, so wie wir haben hier noch ein anderes Nasenspray für Sie.
Und jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz diese Anhörung.
Und sie sagte, oh, nur um die Rechnung, wenn auf der Straße du selbstmordliche
Gedanken hast, und das hat er mir gesagt, sie said.
It's better than blowing your brains out against the wall.
Zu dieser Dimension sollte man sich bewusst sein. Wir schließen das ab mit kurzen
Clips von zwei Autoren, Anne Case und Angus Deaton.
Die haben das Buch geschrieben, Tod aus Verzweiflung, der Untergang der amerikanischen
Arbeiterklasse und das Ende des amerikanischen Traums. Ich will es jetzt noch
mal von dem Suizid ein wenig lösen, will noch mal stärker dieses Soziale machen.
Dieses Buch wollten wir sogar mal lesen, haben uns dann irgendwann,
weil andere Bücher kamen, dagegen entschieden. Es ist interessant,
es ist sehr erschütternd zu
lesen, was da los ist. 2017, schreiben sie zum Beispiel, starben 158.000,
Amerikaner an dem, was wir Tod aus Verzweiflung nennen.
Selbstmord, Überdosen und alkoholbedingte Leberkrankheiten und Zirrosen.
Das entspräche dem Absturz von täglich drei vollbesetzten Flugzeugen vom Typ
737 Max ohne Überlebende.
Das ist die Situation.
Und das sind ja nur die direkten Todesfälle. Es gibt ja diese indirekten,
hat sich nur noch zugefressen, nicht mehr bewegt und so weiter und deswegen.
Ja, also hier das sind noch wirkliche Alkohol und so. Das andere ist ja auch
dann wirklich ganz schwer messbar. Hier sind viele Statistiken.
Sie schreiben ja auch, die Selbstmordgefahr steigt mit der Verfügbarkeit der
entsprechenden Möglichkeiten. Also auch das wird hier deutlich gemacht.
Bevor in Großbritannien allgemein Nordseegas zur Verfügung stand,
wurde im Haushalt zum Kochen und Heizen Kohlegas genutzt, das Kohlenmonoxid
enthält und zum Selbstmord verwendet werden kann. Mit der Einführung von Kohlegas Ende des 19.
Jahrhunderts stieg die Zahl der damit verübten Selbstmorde stark an.
Also das spielt eine Rolle.
Und auch noch ganz wichtig.
Dass man eine Zeit lang davon ausging, Selbstmord ist eher ein Phänomen für
höhere Bildungsgruppen.
Also sehr reflektiert, melancholischer Charakter, was auch immer,
wie man das dann herleiten möchte.
Wenn man sich aber jetzt das für, die haben sich das nur für Amerika angesehen.
Wenn man sich das für Amerika ansieht, dann sind Menschen ohne BA,
also ohne Bachelorabschluss, die, da steigt die Rate.
Und bei Weißen steigt die Rate. Das erklären sie jetzt gleich noch.
Die schwarzen Männer haben den Abstieg schon voll erlebt, beziehungsweise sind
nie aufgestiegen, was auch noch mal psychologisch ein anderer Effekt ist, als wenn man absteigt.
Und dann heißt es hier, Arbeitslosigkeit, vielleicht auch die Angst davor,
ist ein nachweislicher Indikator für den Suizid. Wir hören jetzt mal rein,
Die waren im Chris Hayes Podcast kürzlich zu Gast und sprechen darüber.
Bei 25 Jahren, bei dem Zeitpunkt, in dem die meisten Leute ihre Bildung beendet
haben, dann hat es sich herausgestellt, dass die schlechten Dinge viel zuvor begonnen haben.
In der Tat gibt es seit 2009 keinen Erhöhung in der Lebenserwartung für Menschen
ohne BA, während diejenigen mit BA, die vorher ehrlich waren.
Also für Deutschland haben wir seit 2014 so eine stagnierende Lebenserwartung,
die aber auch irgendwie biologisch begründbar und so weiter.
Also man ist auch einfach in so ein, keine Ahnung, was geraten.
Amerika ist halt auch ein ganz spezieller Fall. Also das machen die Autoren auch klar.
Also da fällt es halt hart auseinander.
Das Buch ist übrigens vor Covid geschrieben, aber kann man natürlich dann da
nochmal anders lesen. Ich würde diesen Punkt nochmal machen wollen in Bezug
auf die Bundestagsdebatte.
Jetzt heißt es so, ja, das darf natürlich nicht passieren, das.
Und wir kennen alle diese Diskussion noch aus Corona.
Wir sitzen alle in einem Boot, wir dürfen niemanden hinter uns lassen.
Und dann saß man hier so, hat sich gewundert, die Zahlen sind dann doch hoch
und hat so über seine eigene Wirklichkeit nachgedacht, konnte sich damit nicht so erklären.
Und wir beiden haben ja dann doch mal überlegt, gut, ja, Homeoffice,
aber irgendwie so Produkte werden geliefert, wo werden die gefertigt und so weiter.
Und da war ja dann nicht nur Tönnies oder so, sondern wir haben uns andere Sachen
angesehen und da hat man gesagt, ach so gut, die hat man schon noch losgeschickt.
Also die mussten schon noch, die mussten schon dran glauben.
Und wenn die das Virus halt erwischt haben, das ist aber schade.
Und da sehe ich halt diese ganz große Gefahr drin. Man kann natürlich immer
versichern, wir nehmen alle mit und niemand soll sich so fühlen, dass.
Aber die Realität ist ja dann eine andere und die wird ja dann auch politisch lange totgeschwiegen.
Wie lange hat das gedauert, bis Lauterbach auch mal eingestanden hat?
Naja, es könnte vielleicht auch mit beengtem Wohnraum zusammenhängen,
mit Riesenfluren, durch die hunderte Leute durchgehen, aus der eher Infektionen
entstehen als irgendwo im Villenviertel in München.
Die Nachrichtenlage zum Thema Homeoffice ist ja gerade, dass sich die Homeoffice-Quote
seit Corona nicht wieder im großen Rahmen verändert hat.
Ah ja.
So, und während wir ja gerade gar keinen Corona-Druck und nichts haben,
sondern einfach nur Leute, bei denen sowieso möglich ist, das zu organisieren,
die das auch mit dem Arbeitgeber klären und so weiter, die sind halt jetzt im Homeoffice.
Das war während der Hochzeit-Corona genauso. Ja. Es gab gar nicht diesen großen,
jetzt geht mal alle nach Hause und schützt euch oder so, sondern die Wirtschaft
war so wichtig, dass man nur Betriebsstelligungen in diesem Dienstleitungsbereich
mit hohem Publikumsverkehr, also die Straßenszene.
Was wenig ausmacht für das BIP. Genau, was dann da kaum von Relevanz ist und
wo man auch, wenn man da nicht essen geht, esst man woanders.
Also es ist so eine Verlagerung in der Gesamtsumme kaum spürbar.
Aber das fand ich dann irgendwie, man kann es irgendwie kaum glauben,
aber dass dieser Druck damals,
der da also gemacht wurde, im Sinne von jetzt bleibt mal alle zu Hause und so
weiter, ökonomisch so eingefangen wurde von den Kräften, dass die Homeoffice-Quote
jetzt gerade, wo man es gar nicht fühlt, genauso ist wie damals.
Also da sieht man, wie sehr man die Leute dann doch im Stich lässt, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Jaja.
Er spricht,
eigentlich des Dieten von einer Epidemie.
Und das kann in guten Zeiten und in schlechten Zeiten passieren.
So wurde der Tod als Metapher für die anderen Dinge, weil alkoholische Leberkrankheit
etwas ist, was man selbst macht. Es ist nicht wie Covid, es ist nicht wie eine Pandemie.
Gleichzeitig ist es so bei Drogenverletzungen. Sie werden als unerlässliche
Verletzungen genannt, aber, wie jemand einmal sagte, es war kein Unfall,
dass die Nadel in deinem Arm kam.
In your arm. And so what you've got here is a social epidemic of self-destruction.
Und das kann man ja auf die Ernährung super erweitern.
Diese Döcke haben wir jetzt schon gesagt. Die Diskussion über den Suizid ist
die Diskussion über die Gesellschaft, die man aber vermeiden möchte,
weshalb man dann so extensiv über den Suizid redet und die anderen Sachen vermeidet, siehe AfD.
Das war eigentlich eine typische, deswegen finden wir die Rede so gut,
weil sie alles vermieden hat, worüber die AfD sonst ganz anders spricht oder schweigt.
Und das ist so erstaunlich, wenn man auch mal in diese Selbstdestruktion eingeht,
wenn wir über Ernährung nachdenken. Also wir haben jetzt ganz stark gehört,
Bildung, Aufklärung darüber wird dann vorgeschlagen.
Die Sache ist ja auch die, warum isst man eigentlich Dinge, die nicht gut sind?
Und ich kann die auch für mich so beantworten, ich rauche ja schon so zwei,
drei Zigaretten am Tag. Und da weiß ich ja auch, dass das nicht gut ist.
Aber ich sage, das ist so eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung für mich,
weil der Genuss, den es bringt, der ist dann doch irgendwie auch da.
Sonst würde ich es ja nicht tun. Also es ist ja keine Sucht bei zwei,
drei Zigaretten, dass man sagt, gut, kann leider nicht anders,
sondern es ist eine ziemlich bewusste Entscheidung, würde ich sagen.
Und ähnlich Und ähnlich würde ich das auch sagen bei ganz vielen Entscheidungen
für schlechte Ernährung, also für sehr süß oder viel Chips und dem ganzen Kram.
Und ich denke, dass dieser Akt des Genusses ja einer ist, den man,
da wenigstens unmittelbar und für relativ wenig Geld bekommt.
Macht umso mehr Spaß, je kalkulierter es ist.
Ja, aber in einer Gesellschaft, in der natürlich eine Vereinsamung groß ist
und auch andere Genüsse ja gar nicht so einfach sich zu beschaffen sind.
Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur Sexualität, sondern generell etwas kulturell Bereicherndes.
Wo kann man es erleben? Mit wem kann man es erleben?
Wie kann man einfach sich so ein bisschen was Gutes zuführen?
Und da ist wirklich das Einfachste, irgendeine Packung aufzureißen und was zu essen.
Und das ist wiederum eine ganz große gesamtgesellschaftliche Frage,
dass man sagen kann, na ja, wenn...
Christian Baron hatte ja in seinem Buch damals, warum die Linken die Arbeiter verachten,
provokanter Titel, oder die Arbeiterklasse verachten,
Dann hat er geschrieben, naja, das wird dann auch so von Linken immer so nase
rümpfend oder despektierlich draufgeblickt,
wenn man irgendwo vorbeigeht an der Imbissbude und man sieht dann halt typische
Imbissbudengänger, die sich dann so eine Pommes da reinziehen.
Und der Kraftriegel und dann sagt er und dann sagt er und dann sagt er bei Christian
Maron-Jabbert für für Leute, die Hartz 4 beziehen, ist das halt mal der Moment,
wo man mal ein bisschen sich was Schönes erleben kann.
Dann ist man die Zuckerwatte oder die Currywurst und wo die Alternativen nicht
da ist, wo man nicht sagen kann, na ja, gut, dann geht doch halt in die Oper.
Ja, ist das ein Genuss, auf den man zugreifen will, wenn man nicht völlig asketisch
leben will. Und das ist, diese Dimensionen sollte man glaube ich auch nochmal bedenken.
Und dann gibt es aber noch das, so wirklich, dass man sagt, ich bin so verzweifelt,
ich mache mich jetzt damit kaputt.
Also das kann man in The Whale natürlich in extremster Weise sehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du den gesehen hast mit Brendan Fraser, mit dem extremen
Übergewichtigen, der dann ja auch an diesem Übergewicht zugrunde geht.
Und da ist es ja tatsächlich exakt diese Selbstdestruktion.
Alten Boomern in dem Spiegeltext gelesen, wie die erst am Ende,
nach 30 Jahren Ernährungsbiografie feststellen, dass sie sich verirrt haben.
Ja, das natürlich.
Und das als kollektives Phänomen, inklusive des Textes, den wir da lasen aus
der FAZ zum Thema psychisches Wohlbefinden und was man so isst und da auch wieder
die verarbeiteten Lebensmittel, also Krebs und geistiges Unwohlsein.
Also Ernährung ist wirklich das Thema für Suizid. Ja, wir hören nochmal weiter.
Das war Anne Case, die Co-Autorin.
Wir hören jetzt nochmal Deaton.
In diesem cartesianen Weg, wenn ich meinen Fuß schmerze. Es ist eher so,
dass alles Schmerz im Gehirn ist, und es kann aus sozialer Exklusivität und
sozialer Zerstörung kommen, so viel, wie es von physischer Verletzung herkommt.
Und Sie schauen sich dann auch den Heiratsmarkt an? Diese Todesfälle von Alkohol
und Todesfälle von Selbstmord und Todesfälle von Drogen sind viel schlimmer
für die Geburtskohorten, die später aufwachsen.
Also sind die Menschen, die 1960 geboren wurden, zu höherem Risiko,
als die Menschen, die 1950 geboren wurden.
Und die, die 1970 geboren wurden, sind in schlimmer Form als die,
die 1960 geboren wurden, und so weiter.
Wir sehen also nicht, dass das zu einem Ende kommt. Was wir bisher in den Daten sehen,
ist, dass jüngere Menschen, die in den Arbeitsmarkt eintreten,
ohne viel Hoffnung, einen guten Job zu finden, ohne einen Vierjährigen,
Eine Sache, die ihnen passiert, ist, dass sie nicht mehr verheiratet werden können.
Die Menschen mit einer BA, die nicht mehr verheiratet werden können,
werden nicht mehr verheiratet. Von 1980 bis 1990 sind die Menschen mit und ohne
einen Hochschulabschluss verheiratet worden. Es war einfach so,
dass die Menschen nicht mehr verheiratet werden konnten.
Aber für Menschen mit einer BA ist es jetzt stabil. Für Menschen ohne eine BA
werden die Menschen nicht mehr verheiratet.
Also haben die Menschen keine stabile Heimleitung.
Also ich bin so gespannt auf dieses Buch von Scott Galloway,
der schreibt über die Maskulinity und da dieses demating inequality,
wo er nämlich fast in meinem, oder ich weiß nicht genau wie er es macht,
aber er hat ja auch dieses der Heiratsmarkt und dann auch diesen Marktbegriff
mal wirklich ernst nehmen und so, also das mal so ein bisschen abgleichen,
mal aus dieser Gefühlsecke raus, mal rein in diese sachliche Diskussion, das finde ich sehr gut.
Und die Religion ist auch im Schwinden begriffen, zumindest die institutionelle?
Sie haben sich auf eine organisierte Religion aufgenommen, die,
egal was man von einer organisierten Religion denkt, eine Institution ist,
die in diesem Land seit ihrem Gründungszeitpunkt wichtig ist.
Ja, und in der menschlichen Lebe.
Ja, es ist ein Ort, wo man geht und die Leute dich umbringen und man findet
dort eine gewisse Menge der Gemeinschaft.
Das ist weg, das Familienleben ist weg, man hat kein gutes Arbeitsleben.
Also, zurück zu Durkheim, das ist das, was uns zurückgebracht hat.
Das ist wie eine Rezepte für den Tod.
Ich fand das jetzt auch interessanter in den Interviews als das,
was ich dann so nenne. Man kann es hier nochmal in dem Buch nachlesen.
Das ist eben das Problem bei diesen Themen, man kann wirklich unendlich viel
Strecke machen als Buchautor.
Aber dann ist das Buch leider nicht gut verträglich.
Ja, sie gehen schon rein, bringen wirklich viele Statistiken,
Grafiken, all das an. Aber ich finde eigentlich das, wo hier fast essayistisch
über das Thema drüber geflogen wird, ist es am interessantesten.
Und auch jetzt nochmal diese Diagnose zur Arbeiterklasse.
Denn ich meine, die weiße Arbeiterklasse ist das Lieblingsding,
über das ich… Die Schwungmasse der Republikaner.
Ja, einmal das, aber es ist auch quasi so das Lieblingsfeindbild der Linksliberalen,
da kann man es noch mal lustig machen. Gerade beides, die Schwungmasse von Trump.
Ja, und jetzt zeigen wir nochmal denen, wie du und die sind und was weiß ich.
Und wie sehr man da eigentlich auch Leid produziert, sollte einem vielleicht
auch mal deutlich werden. Also hier nochmal N-Case.
Es ist ja eigentlich eine super Einladung für so eine Art Pointe zum Schluss,
weil wir so viel AfD-Klims gehört haben von Beatrix von Storch.
Es nützt eben nichts zu unterscheiden zwischen,
Naja, Hauptsache wir sind in Sicherheit, sollen die anderen mal an der Grenze
versackern, weil am Ende diese Probleme, die es gibt, holen dich immer ein.
Niklas, unser Künstlerkumpel, hat ja dieses Comic gemacht, der letzte Nazi,
genau mit dieser Pointe, also einfach 100 Seiten durchgestaltet.
Es beginnt mit dem Volk und endet eben mit dem letzten Nazi,
der noch den einen anderen, den es gab, aussortiert hat, weil er nicht ganz
der arischen, dann gerade gängigen Qualifikation entsprach. Und dann steht er halt alleine da, ja.
Und das ist im Grunde diese Pointe, die auch hier jetzt gilt,
die die NKs wirklich sehr gut gemacht haben.
Deswegen sind alle emanzipatorischen Bestrebungen, also man kann es ja noch mal umdrehen,
also klar, die AfD ist ja eh verloren, aber man kann es ja,
also man kann denen ja, wir machen ja keine Politikberatung mehr der AfD,
sondern wir können einfach nur hoffen, dass wir hier viele Argumente bringen,
die möglicherweise Leute, die Leute kennen, anbringen können,
wenn es mal darum geht, aber irgendwo hat die AfD doch recht und dann kann man
sagen, ja, die haben auch schon mal einen richtigen Satz gesagt, aber folgendes.
Die Unterscheidung hat immer zwei Seiten. Wenn die die gute Seite dessen betonen,
dann gibt es immer noch die negative Seite.
Aber worum es jetzt so gehen muss, also wenn man jetzt in progressiver Weise
darüber nachdenkt, dass eigentlich jede Bewegung nur funktionieren kann,
wenn sie auch gleichzeitig für alle Bewegungen etwas in Gang setzt.
Und dass man nicht sagt, jetzt haben die einen Oberwasser gehabt,
jetzt müssen mal die anderen.
Also dann macht man dann dann ertrinken alle.
Also das ist das ist ganz klar der Punkt. Und das sieht man ja in ganz vielen
Auseinandersetzungen so aus dem aus der der der der Hollywood Blase oder so.
Wo es einfach jetzt nur geht. Es ist immer die anderen dran.
Aber das führt nie dazu, dass es jetzt immer allgemein besser wird.
Ja, wir haben mit Oppenheimer begonnen und können hier noch mal Zwischenfazit ziehen.
Die allergrößte Katastrophe hat zu den dann größten universalistischen Versprechen
geführt, wie zum Beispiel, wir richten so eine UN für alle ein,
die eben genau diese Unterscheidung nicht mehr macht.
Gut, gleich reden wir über Aliens, also die Menschheit und die Aliens,
diese Unterscheidung kann man auch machen.
Oder eben diese dann auch in Deutschland, Und wie sagt man,
promoteten Sprüche, Freiheit und der Andere, also in der Freiheitsdiskussion
ist immer der Andere schon inbegriffen und so weiter und so fort,
das scheint immer wieder die wichtige Lehre zu sein.
Und dass wir diesen Bogen jetzt von Oppenheimer über Ernährung zum Suizid zu
Durkheims, aber der Suiziddiskurs ist immer nur ein Sozialpolitischer Diskurs
und so weiter, ist doch eigentlich ein ganz runder Bogen.
Als hätten wir es geplant.
Ja, also können wir die Menschheit jetzt verlassen und reden über Aliens.
Im amerikanischen Kongress gab es eine Anhörung und obwohl,
das hat mir Tilo geschickt, in der New York Times ein Opinion-Editorial,
also ein Op-Ed kam von Lindsay Graham und Elizabeth Warren.
Und man denkt, was haben die denn beide? Also es gibt große bipartisan Bemühungen.
Wenn es um Big Tech geht, enough is enough. So die Ansage und deren Vorschlag
ist ein Digital Consumer Protection Commission Act.
Also das hier eine digitale Verbraucherbehörde, damit hat ja Elisabeth Warren
sehr viel Erfahrung, weil die das damals ja auch schon unter.
Aber wir hatten doch Linsey Graham hier als Opponent eigentlich oder?
Ja, bei Lindsey Graham war es ja immer ganz irre, dass er auf der einen Seite so viel mit...
Wie heißt der alte Veteran, der gestorben ist, der gegen Obama damals antrat?
McCain. John McCain, genau. Das war eigentlich sein Buddy, die sind als Team aufgetreten.
Haben dann auch ... Er hat gegen Trump gekämpft bis hin zu dieser,
wir nehmen doch nicht die Krankenversicherung zurück. Da hat McCain dieses Daumen-runter-Ding
damals gemacht, was ja wirklich ein Spektakel war. Lohnt sich auch,
noch mal einen Film drüber zu machen.
Dann ist Graham plötzlich ohne John McCain auf diese Pro-Trump-Seite umgeswitcht.
Jetzt gibt's plötzlich dieses Bipartisan- ... aber ich hab's nur als Kulisse, dass es diesen Text gab.
Denn wir hören jetzt von einer Anhörung, von der die Protagonisten meinen,
dass es noch mehr Bipartisan als jemals was in Washington gab.
Es ist quasi wieder die alte gute Stimmung.
Republikaner und Demokraten vereint bei einem wichtigen Thema.
Na, siehste.
Dieses Thema lautet ... Aliens. Und ich sage konkret Aliens,
auch wenn die behaupten, es geht hier um UAP.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob es im ersten Clip erklärt wird, was das ist,
ansonsten erkläre ich's.
Also Sitzungseröffnung. So, die Sitzung kommt bitte mal zur Order.
Es geht um UAPs, also Unidentified Aerial Phenomenons.
Also Sachen, die durch die Luft fliegen und man weiß nicht so genau, was es ist.
Könnte natürlich einfach alles sein und ist in dem Falle, äh,
würd ich sagen, eine Chiffre für ... Eigentlich wollen wir über UFOs reden.
Es ist eine UFO-Anhörung.
Sachen, die darum fliegen, sind UFOs. Und es ist wirklich eine der Absurden,
ich konnt's gar nicht glauben. Ich hab das auch gestern erst geguckt,
gestern Abend, oder gehört.
Dacht mir, kann doch echt nicht wahr sein, deswegen gehen wir das mal durch
in 20 Clips, die aber alle recht kurz sind, aber uns einen guten Überblick geben.
Dass die Republikaner jetzt irgendwie meinen, das ist der große gemeinsame Aufschlag,
hier zeigen wir mal wieder Handlungsfähigkeit und setzen auch ein bisschen das
demokratische White House unter Druck. Das ist Herr Grotham.
Er hat den Vorsitz, eröffnet die Sitzung und legitimiert jetzt mal das Thema.
Wir überlassen es mal bei diesem Gestammel. Also er hat ein Buch gelesen,
damals als Teenager, da war was mit Aliens drin.
Und das ergänzte sich ganz wunderbar mit Geheimhaltungssachen der Regierung,
dass er dann eins und eins zusammengezählt hat, Politiker wurde und… Hat er
eh Richtung Demokraten damals schon geschrieben?
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Es muss auch aus dieser Richtung kommen. Und na gut, wir hatten ja damals wirklich
fantastische, also fantastische Autoren im Sinne von, die dann viele Politiker
wurden. Also viele von denen sind ja, es gibt ja recht viele,
die so, na ja, dieses Denken einfach mitgebracht haben.
Aber ich will gleich mal einwenden, bevor wir uns allzu lächerlich machen.
Wir hatten hier mal Clips von Thomas zu Buchen von der NASA,
der Forschungsdirektor, jetzt nicht mehr, aber war damals noch Forschungsdirektor
in Sternstunde Philosophie.
Und da wird er ja mit diesen Aufnahmen konfrontiert, die dann ja aus dem Archiv mal rauskamen.
Und da sagt er, ja, das sei sehr gut, dass darüber jetzt gesprochen wird.
Denn es gibt eine gewisse Scham, darüber zu reden. Ja, das stimmt.
Und das sei schon sehr wichtig. Und er hält auch, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
erinnere, es für durchaus möglich.
Also ich hätte gar nichts gegen so einen aufgeklärten Diskurs,
wo man mal die Möglichkeiten, wie wir sie heute kennen, zum Interstellaren reisen und was auch immer.
Man kann das ja durchaus mal durchgehen, ohne sich lächerlich zu machen.
Wir gucken ja auch alle gerne Star Trek, da wird das ja auch thematisiert.
Man braucht halt ein Warpcore, da muss man sich halt überlegen,
Warpcore, was heißt denn das? Da explodieren einfach dauernd so Wasserstoffbomben
und irgendwie, und es wird aber alles contained.
Warum nicht? Ich würde sagen, dieser Diskurs ist ja da und ist in der Literatur
auch nicht schlecht aufgehoben.
Über Aliens geschrieben, bis er dann Sprecher im Kongress wurde und so und da
gibt es aber so eine gewisse Themen...
Übersprünge über die Institutionsgrenzen und so, weißt du?
Plötzlich schleppen die da so Themen mit. Naja, also hier ist eine Kongressanhörung,
Herr Grothamon hat sie eröffnet mit dem Verweis auf, er selbst hat als Kind
dieses Buch gelesen und er kennt aber noch zwei andere ganz prominente,
die auch hier nochmal legitimieren, warum man jetzt auf politischer Ebene dieses
Thema endlich mal bespricht.
Jimmy Carter claimed to have seen a UFO.
So, das will ich ja niemandem absprechen. Ich habe auch schon mal Sachen am
Himmel gesehen, wo ich dachte, das ist bestimmt ein UFO und es wäre schade,
wenn nicht. Aber ich kann trotzdem damit umgehen, falls es dann doch nicht so ist.
Naja, also Thema ist gesetzt, Thema ist vor allem begründet.
Und jetzt fehlt ja die politische Dimension. Sie wird uns wie folgt weisgemacht.
Es ist im Grunde eine Kongressanhörung, die mal wieder das Weiße Haus unter Druck setzen will.
Ihr habt ein Thema, bei dem ihr nicht vorbereitet seid. Das Land ist nicht geschützt,
ihr seid nicht in der Lage.
Ihr wusstet schon nicht, wie mit dem weißen Ballon aus China umgehen.
Was ist, wenn jetzt die Aliens kommen? Was macht der dann?
Und da würde ich mal sagen, der weiße Ballon aus China, hat man ja dann irgendwann
festgestellt, naja, das war halt so low-tech.
Weil der bestand im Grunde nur aus dieser Hülle und diese Hülle war so dünn,
dass die Laserradarstrahlen da einfach durchgingen und ist deswegen nicht und so weiter.
Also ist jetzt High-Tech das Problem oder Low-Tech?
Ja, zumindest hat man sich blamiert.
Man hat sich blamiert, genau. Aber es war halt, wie wir heute wissen,
ein Wetterballon, der auch nichts konnte. Also da hing halt irgendeine Gerätschaft
dran, die den Wind gemessen hat oder was.
Wie auch immer. Naja. Nächster Sprecher, Mr. Borchett, war da wahrscheinlich ausgesprochen.
Er zeigt uns jetzt noch mal, wie groß das Thema ist.
Mein kleiner sechsjähriger Sohn, während wir ihn gerade noch im Auto sitzen
sehen, ist auf dem Weg in ein Pfadfinderlager.
Es ist weltweit, da kommen sogar Leute aus Australien. Das ist eine globale Angelegenheit.
Ja, das war aber großes Twitter-Thema.
Hier ist jemand aus Dänemark angereist, um bei dieser Anhörung zu sein, als Zuschauer.
Das zeigt, wie global.
Es ist global, worldwide. Also es ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Wir können auf alles gefasst sein. Man muss mit allem rechnen, außer...
Wir werden einfach nur zu den Fakten kommen.
Dies liegt vor allem an der Fehlertragung der Transparenz von unserem,
eigenen Regierung und der Fehler unserer gewählten Leader,
um ihre Versprechen gut zu machen, zu Erklärungen und Fotos und Mountains von
überklassifizierten Dokumenten, die von den amerikanischen Menschen immer noch versteckt werden.
Eine Polizei in bezeichnendem Fall fand heraus, dass 68 Prozent der Amerikaner glauben, dass,
die Regierung Informationen über UAPs versteckt und nicht ehrlich darüber ist,
was wir über Also man hatte jetzt auch noch so eine Verschwörungserzählung,
die schweigende Mehrheit, die läuft da mit und wir haben eh nicht alles gesagt
bekommen und jetzt hier Transparenz und die Republikaner präsentieren sich jetzt
als die, die Transparenz.
Meinst du, sowas droht uns auch noch, dass wir vielleicht im nächsten Jahr mal
so eine Bundestagsdebatte haben? Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch eine Partei bei
uns, die vielleicht da mal Ideen hätte.
Oder ist da vielleicht dann doch, naja, ich glaube, man kann sich in Deutschland
doch noch leichter damit lächerlich machen, oder?
Also selbst die AfD könnte da Hemmungen haben und sagen, gut,
das könnte nach hinten losgehen, könnte ein bisschen zu doof werden.
Während das hier, die sitzen ja hier wie gecastet von Steven Spielberg.
Absolut.
IT kommt zurück oder sowas.
Ja, das ist ganz verrückt. Ich glaube, in Deutschland sind wir ein bisschen
sicher, aber wir können es ja daran ermessen, die AfD darf jedes Thema als Antrag
in den Bundestag einwerfen und dann werden die Rederechte verteilt.
Keine Ahnung, mal sehen, ob sie sich das trauen. Ist Thema Rumor jedenfalls
und man wird dann auch behaupten können, das Thema ist weltweit,
selbst die Amerikaner haben schon und so.
Gut, Garcia. Nächster.
Das finde,
ich besonders gut. Er sagt, er ist ein Teacher, ein Lehrer und er möchte alles
für möglich halten. Er hat schon viel erlebt.
Er hat also Schüler vor sich gehabt. Und da würde ich sagen,
für Republikaner, die so alt sind, dass sie im Grunde nur noch,
handlungsunvermögend vor Publikum stehen wie Mitch McConnell gestern und so solche Sachen.
Für die sind ja Kinder geistig so weit entfernt wie Aliens.
Und wenn er sagt, ich habe mit Kindern zu tun gehabt, ich halte alles für möglich,
dann gilt das auch für Aliens.
Also man weiß nicht genau, wo man jetzt noch die...
Ich habe schon alles gesehen, ich habe schon mit Kindern zusammengearbeitet.
Das hat er gesagt. Und für alle, die keine Kinder vor sich haben,
die wissen ja zumindest, wo man sich Informationen holt, die hinter dem Horizont fast stattfinden.
Fox News, sagt uns Herr Moskowitz.
So, auch bei Fox News wird gesagt, dass die Regierung mehr über Aliens weiß, als sie sagt.
Hattest du gesehen, dass Fabio De Masi einen sehr langen Tweet dazu verfasst hat?
Hierzu?
Nein, hab ich nicht gesehen. Willst du den mal aufrufen? Fabio De Masi hat sich
zum Thema Aliens und Ufos geäußert. Ich habe ihn nicht gelesen.
Ich war nur überrascht. Ich musste dann los, dass das ein Thema für ihn ist.
Gut. Fabio?
Er hat da bei Twitter länger drüber geschrieben.
Geht die Twitter-Suche nicht mehr, wenn ich einfach so Fabio einschreibe?
Twitter, das haben wir jetzt ja gar nicht thematisiert, Twitter für die Leute,
die da nicht sind, ist jetzt X, also man hat nur noch so ein schwarzes X und
es ist nicht mehr dieser Vogel da.
Auch sonst funktioniert bei Twitter relativ wenig, würde ich sagen.
Ah, Fabio De Masi hat ein...
Flamingo und ein blaues, einen blauen Haken. Gut, ich guck mal,
ob ich hier was zum Finden habe.
Also heute oder gestern hat er es geschrieben. Sollten wir vielleicht noch rezipieren.
Vielleicht noch mal eine andere Betrachtungsweise.
Hier, ich hab's. Oh, das ist aber wirklich lang. Ich lese mal den Einstieg. So, cold.
Es gibt viele Spinner- und Rittbrettfahrer mit UFO-Geschichten.
Das hat bei aller gesunden Skepsis aber zumindest eine andere Qualität Und ist
in jeder Falle, ach so, in jedem Falle sehr faszinierend.
Doppelpunkt. Nachdem die USA bereits einen Kurswechsel einschlugen und einräumten,
dass etwa 5% der insbesondere von Militärpiloten gefilmten UFO-Sichtungen tatsächlich
technologisch unerklärliche Phänomene bzw.
Flugobjekte beinhalten, die erforscht werden müssen, hat gestern David Grush,
ein führender US-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter, der Unidentified Aerial Phenomena
Task Force die gibt es also auch,
unter strafbewährten Eid in einer öffentlichen Anhörung des US-Konkurses seine
Aufgespräche mit Unterlagen von ranghohen Geheimdienstmitarbeitern gestützten
Behauptungen wiederholt,
dass die USA über Überreste von Flugobjekten inklusive körperverunklickter Lebensformen,
Klammer auf, Ausrufezeichen, Klammer zu, einer technologisch überlegten Zivilisation
verfügen würden und es jenseits der parlamentarischen Kontrolle geheimen Programme
zur Also wir haben ja alle damals Independence Day gesehen, wie der Außenminister erfährt.
Achso, wir haben so ein Programm, wusste ich gar nicht. Jaja,
das macht nur das Weiße aus.
Also gut, er hat einen langen Tweet. Ich komme jetzt nicht bis zur Pointe.
Aber glaubst du denn, dass wir...
Ich meine, das hier ist eine Spaßveranstaltung, das ist ja offensichtlich,
was du uns hier präsentierst.
Und ich habe mich nie mit dem Thema UFO groß beschäftigt, außer wenn sie mir
in Filmen begegnet sind.
Okay, warte, pass auf, ich lese jetzt das Ende vor. Also Fabio De Masi schreibt,
in jedem Falle ein sehr faszinierendes Thema, nicht nur für Science-Fiction-Freunde.
Eigentlich gehört es vor die UNO, da die Implikationen sehr weitreichend wären.
Ich habe lange überlegt, ob ich dazu etwas schreiben soll, weil man schon durch
die Thematisierung schnell als irre gilt.
Aber meine Neugier war doch groß genug, um mir die Anhörung im US-Kongress anzusehen.
Es lohnt sich zumindest, das weiter zu verfolgen. Der Meinung bin ich leider nicht.
Aber UN?
Aber sozusagen, man macht da was Internationales, Sven.
Also das ist ja hier, also das sieht ja so aus, als würden die mal gucken,
ob die die kommen, die die Ufos freundlich oder feindlich gesinnt sind,
wenn die Aliens nicht den American Way of Life leben wollen,
dann schießen wir sie ab.
So sind die ja drauf hier, diese Gesellen.
Und wenn man das thematisierte, müsste man es wirklich auf so einer Weltebene thematisieren.
Und ich finde ja sowieso, wir haben ja bei dem Weltraumgesetz in den 70er Jahren
schon mal so geschaffen, so
eine Einheit schaffen können, wo man es gar nicht für Möglichkeiten hat.
Man kann ja schon nochmal, also wenn die, ich will es mal anders sagen,
wenn die Demokraten und die Republikaner jetzt auch doch nochmal so zusammen
sich einem Thema widmen,
Ist denn nicht auch noch mal so auf einer Weltebene so ein Thema zu setzen,
das tatsächlich sehr weit weg ist, aber dass man darüber noch mal eine Kooperation herstellen kann?
Ich sag mal so, die Gründung der Vereinten Nationen, die wir ja hier angesprochen
haben von Fabio De Masi, ist ja eine ganz konkrete,
Also auf eine ganz konkrete Bedrohungslage gemünzt, nämlich dass der dritte
Weltkrieg mit Atomwaffen geführt wird. Wir haben es ja mit Oppenheimer besprochen.
Also versucht man, das auf jeden Fall zu vermeiden und gründet,
auf Teufel komm raus, die größten Organisationen der Welt, zumindest was ihre
Spannweite, Tragweite und dann auch Eingriffstiefe und so angeht,
Völkerrecht und so. Alles ist geregelt.
Wir brauchen halt eine Bedrohungslage, wenn wir eine Diskussion haben,
von der wir, oder manche meint, sie sei wichtig, aber diejenigen dann selbst
schon antizipieren, dass man eigentlich nicht drüber reden kann,
weil man sich irgendwie lächerlich macht oder als irre gilt,
dann wird es ja nie gelingen.
Schon allein, weil du nicht unironisch, also es müsste schon in dieser Alien
auftauchen, aber dann wäre es halt auch zu spät oder so, ja.
Okay, also du meinst nicht, man kann präventiv.
Na, ich fände halt interessant, wir haben ja auch bei uns so in der Telefongruppe
so ein bisschen rumgescherzt. Ich habe dann auch so ein bisschen den Advocatus Diaboli gespielt.
Wenn jetzt irgendwer kommt und sagt, naja, aber die Lichtgeschwindigkeit limitiert
doch, dass hier irgendwer ankommt und so. Ich sage, naja, wieso?
Nur weil wir das so sehen.
Wir haben doch bei Oppenheimer erst gelernt, umso tiefer man reingeht,
umso religiöser wird man auch, weil man sich echt nicht vorstellen kann,
wie das sonst ohne Intelligent Design gestaltet werden soll.
Und wenn man nicht mal da Intelligenz ausschließen kann, warum sollte man dann
anderen Lebewesen das absprechen, dass sie in der Lage wären,
trotz hoher Distanz. Also was ist hohe Distanz schon für eine Hürde?
Wir haben ja auch immer gedacht, das ist aber ganz schön weit weg.
Und wenn man mehr als 30 km verlässt die Seele, den Körper und was auch immer.
Und jetzt düsen wir alle durch die Welt. Also in der Hinsicht würde ich die
Möglichkeiten gar nicht ausschließen.
Aber es ist halt ein bisschen Bis dann!
Wie damals bei Corona, während Dirk Brockmann sagt,
ich bin ein ganz toller Modellierer und einfach uns nur modelliert,
was Sache ist, anstatt einfach mal den unwahrscheinlichen Fall,
dass man vielleicht doch mal und wie sähe es denn aus, wenn wir so und so politisch
entscheiden, das auch mal modelliert, kam ja nie dazu.
Wir haben ja nie ein Modell gesehen im Sinne von, was hieße es jetzt,
die ganze Welt zu durchseuchten oder ein Lockdown für immer und so weiter.
Wir haben immer nur diese Verkehrsdaten.
Also machen wir jetzt ein Modell zu dem, wie es eigentlich ist.
Wir hatten aber nicht diesen fantastischen Ausbruch mit diesen Möglichkeiten, die wir da hatten.
Und das sehe ich halt hier auch nicht. Die laden ja niemanden ein,
der jetzt physikalisch dort mal vorrechnet, was vielleicht noch ginge,
aber immer mit dem Verweis auf, was absolut erst mal ausgeschlossen ist und so.
Die einfach, ja, ich habe schon mal ein UFO gesehen.
Und die ganz viele Berichte, die ich sammle, das so. Und meine Behördenchefs
haben mich auch schon diskreditiert und eigentlich, zum Glück darf ich hier noch mal reden.
Aber, und das sage ich jetzt auch nur dann, wenn wir im Hinterzimmer sind und
so, ja. Also die sozusagen selber für sich gehalten, in Anspruch nehmen.
Also so ehrenfreundlich denken. Ja, die ganze Zeugenschaft, also diese drei,
die hier, ich habe jetzt diese Vereidung von denen, ja, das war ja auch so ein kleiner Akt nochmal.
Okay, dann glaube ich können wir diese Anhörung doch nochmal anders kontextualisieren.
Du hattest damals den Text mal vorgestellt im Salon, ich weiß nicht mehr von
wem er war, über Verschwörungstheorien als Religionsersatz.
Und Fanfiction, genau.
Religionsherz und Fanfiction. Und das hier ist ja auch Fanfiction.
Es knüpft eigentlich nur daran an und es, wir haben es eben gehört von N.
Case und Angus Deaton, gibt diese,
Im Schwinden begriffene institutionelle Religion.
Aber die Sehnsucht nach dem Religiösen ist ja, wie wir auch wissen, nicht verpufft.
Sondern gestaltet sich anders aus. Und kann dann auch mit solchen Ideen von
Aliens, die kommen, zusammenhängen.
Die uns retten oder bedrohen.
Beides ist ja wiederum was, was einem, ob es einem Angst macht oder Hoffnung schöpft.
Und dafür sorgt, dass man sich damit ein bisschen beschäftigen kann.
Und dann ist ja schon wieder Sinnstiftung erlebt.
Ja, also ich würde immer sagen, das ist hier so eine Diskussion,
die will eigentlich einfach nur das Weiße Haus angreifen und so.
Da so politische Defizite vorwerfen, obwohl man eigentlich so große Fenster aufmachen müsste.
Naja, wir können ja mal die Zeugen hier reinhören. Ich habe mir ihre Namen nicht
notiert, maligen Militärs.
Also ja, da ist irgendwas und naja, wir können nicht drüber reden.
Also man macht dann dieses Fenster auf und zeigt diese Defizite auf breiter Front.
Und ganz witzig ist, wie sie hier dieses nochmal begründen, ist ja mal die Frage,
ist es nicht am Ende, wenn wir Alien sagen, der Russe oder der Chinese haben
die irgendwas entwickelt, was wir nicht haben und so. Und hier zeigen sie sich ganz begeistert.
In Kategorie 4, Hurrikanwind.
Diese selben Objekte werden dann zu supersonischen Geschwindigkeiten,
1,1, 1,2 Mach, Und sie tun das in sehr erratischen und schnellen Behavioren,
für die ich keine Erklärung habe.
Das metaphorisch verwendet wurde. Der Russe steht vor der Tür.
Ja, und das war dann das Alien und das muss bekämpft werden.
Und dann überlegt man ja irgendwann im Science Fiction Film,
ob man auch anders erzählt und eigentlich erleben wir dann im Science Fiction
Film die Annäherungspolitik,
die der Westen dann selbst auch betreibt Richtung China, Richtung Sowjetunion,
zum Beispiel das Ding aus der Begegnung der dritten Art, eine unheimliche Begegnung
der dritten Art von Steven Spielberg,
wo versucht wird, mit dem Alien zu kommunizieren und das wird dann über Musik
hergestellt oder dann nochmal in der infantilen Variante mit E.T.
Und dies zeigt ja jetzt wieder hier, wo wir so eine neue Blockbildung auch haben,
wo wir wieder dieses Freund-Feind-Schema so stark haben, eine Überlegung,
naja, welche Bedrohung ist da eigentlich?
Wofür werden wir nicht geschützt? Der Feind steht möglicherweise vor der Tür.
Biden hat es nur noch nicht gemerkt. Also das kann natürlich nochmal so eine
ganz neue Fiktionsproduktion im politischen Diskurs hervorbringen.
Man könnte auch so ein bisschen phänomenologisch vulgär sagen,
ohne den chinesischen Ballon hätte es die ganzen Aliens nie gegeben in Washington.
Also es geht so ein bisschen drunter und drüber und das hört man auch hier.
Der Borschett, der die Sitzung so ein bisschen mitleitet.
I noticed that in the TikTok video, it's TicTac like the candy,
not TikTok like the Chinese communist app.
That's correct. Yes, sir, I just want to make that ... Because my daughter corrected
me on that and called me a boomer and said, hey, boomer, and I said,
no, baby, it's TicTac like the candy.
You're gonna have to just look it up. benutzt, liebe Tochter.
Es gibt auch Tic-Tac und da habe ich meine UFO-Videos geguckt und jetzt fahre
ich nach Washington und leite die Sitzung.
Jetzt hat er schon über seine gesprochen. Er hat auch noch ein Wort übrig für seine liebe Ehefrau.
As she likes to say, this 9 years have been the best 2 years of her life.
So, thank you. Mr. Favre.
Ist das jetzt sowas Neues, dass man nur mal Grüße ausrichtet?
Möchtest du auch noch jedem einen gratulieren oder so, wo wir gerade hier zusammensitzen?
Es passt irgendwie zur Sendung, fand ich. Ja. Es ist einfach,
also zur Sendung sage ich schon, ja, es ist halt wirklich nur gemacht.
Eine Sendung, ja.
Es ist halt nicht eine ernsthafte Veranstaltung. Gut, wie sehen jetzt diese
außerirdischen Schiffe eigentlich aus?
Und du darfst kurz beschreiben, wie er aussieht.
Er trägt einen blauen Anzug und hat ein Tuch sich um den Kopf gewickelt,
oder es ist so ein Hütchen, ne?
Mit Mustern drauf.
Mit Mustern, mit blauen Mustern drauf. Also wenn er könnte jetzt auch erzählen,
ich bin ja schon entführt gewesen von Aliens und kommt gerade zurück.
Ist das nicht auch so ein, es gibt doch so einen Charakter dann auch bei Independence Day.
Es gibt immer so einen Irren, der irgendwo mit rumspringt, bei Terminator ja
auch und so überall, wo die Aliens auftauchen.
Immer einer, der schon mit denen mal ein paar Jahre unterwegs war.
Der hat irgendwie 20 Jahre Section 230 geleitet oder so und es ist alles verrückt.
Über fast acht Jahre. Und so weit ich weiß, ist es immer noch passiert.
Ja, alles recht obskur, ne?
Es ist wirklich ein bisschen komisch. Ein Zeuge berichtet nochmal,
wie man intern mit solchen Infos umgeht.
Ich habe das Wissen von aktiven, geplanten Verantwortungseffekten gegen mich
und andere Kollegen. Und das ist für mich sehr schrecklich. Woher kommt das?
Eine bestimmte Seniorenleitung in den vorherigen Agenzien, mit denen ich verabschiedet wurde. mit.
Und das ist alles, was ich öffentlich sage, aber ich kann mehr Details in einer
geschlossenen Umgebung geben.
Wenn mal was anderes wäre, oder?
Es ist ja das, was wir brauchen für den nächsten großen zivilisatorischen gemeinsamen Schritt nach vorne.
Diese Bedrohung von allem. Aber ja, ich halte.
Ich glaube, die Sehnsucht ist einfach gerade sehr hoch danach,
dass mal irgendjemand kommen würde von außerhalb und sagt, warum macht ihr das
eigentlich so komisch mit dem Klimawandel?
Ist das nicht so und so? Man geht ja davon aus, wenn jetzt hier jemand hinkommt,
die sind ja dann mit der fliegenden Untertasse unterwegs.
Aber die müssen ja uns in irgendeiner Weise überlegen sein, sonst hätten sie
die Reise nicht antreten können. Da ist dann schon dieses Versprechen, das da mitreißt.
Mensch, vielleicht könnten die uns mal so einen kleinen Schub geben,
in welche Richtung es jetzt geht.
Vielleicht können die Christian Lindner Also wir sind ja in die moderne Welt
gestartet mit dem Thomas-Theorem.
Man konnte sich den Gott nicht mehr erklären. Was hat es mit dem auf sich?
Und dann hat man gesagt, naja, aber wenn viele Leute irgendwo hin pilgern,
ist das ja nicht ohne Ursache, weil jede Wirkung hat eine Ursache.
Also muss es Gott auch geben. Und so ist das ja hier auch.
Wenn alle da zum Kongress gehen und über Aliens reden, machen die das ja nicht
ohne Ursache. Also gibt es auch Aliens.
Das ist die einfachste Erklärung, die man noch haben kann. Der Herr Moskowitz
will dem ein bisschen auf den Grund gehen.
Die Objekte zerstörten die Geräuschbarriere. Hatten sie einen sonarischen Boom?
Ich war im Jet, man hört nichts. Es ist ziemlich laut in der Luft.
Ja, man kann es nicht persönlich in dem Fahrzeug erkennen.
Ich würde sagen, die Objekte, die wir sahen, waren sphärisch.
Und sie wurden bis zu Mach 2 beobachtet, was eine sehr un-aerodynamische Form ist.
Was ist mit G-Forcen? Lass uns über G-Forcen in diesen Fahrzeugen reden.
Könnte ein Mensch mit der heutigen Technologie diese G-Forcen überleben?
Nein. Nein, nicht für die Geschwindigkeitsrate, die wir beobachtet haben.
Okay. Was ist mit dem, was sie aussehen? Wie nah kamen Sie? Hatten Sie ein Seem
oder einen Rippen oder eine Sektion?
Und was ich meine ist, dass die Jets, die Sie fliegen, all diese Dinge haben.
Haben diese Objekte das?
Ich hatte nicht die Details, um das zu sagen.
Fragt mal nach, ja sind uns die Aliens jetzt total überlegen und gefährlich
oder sind die total inkompetent und stürzen ja ständig ab.
Aber ich werde dir ein theoretisches Rahmen geben, zumindest für die Ausarbeitung,
um Verletzungen zu erheben.
Egal, ob du dein Level von Verletzungen, Flugzeuge verletzen,
Fahrzeuge verletzen, und die Zahl der Verletzungen, egal wie hoch,
eine kleine Prozente wird am Ende in der Missionsfehler, wie wir sagen, in der Luftwaffe enden.
Das finde ich eigentlich ein sehr interessantes Argument, denn zum einen sagen
die ja, die sind uns total überlegen.
Und zum anderen, die sind uns ja nur, wie soll man sagen, so strukturell inhaltlich,
aber nicht prinzipiell überlegen.
Auch Überlegenes kann ja kaputt gehen. Nur da würde ich halt sagen,
nee, da ist dann trotzdem irgendwo ...
Man kann ja schon Sachen so containen, dass selbst wenn sie kaputt gehen,
es irgendwie im Abseitigen, Unsichtbaren passiert.
Und diese Art von Inkompetenz wügelt er hier zu schnell ab, finde ich.
Denn die Frage ist ja irgendwie berechtigt.
Sind's jetzt superkompetenter oder bescheuerter Aliens? Das wär ja schon mal
nicht schlecht zu wissen.
Dass die hier noch mit irgendwelchen Waffen kommen, die nicht funktionieren
oder Ladehemmungen haben.
Das wäre ja alles blöd. Und einer darf nicht fehlen bei dieser Art Anhörung.
Matt Gaetz, der nimmt natürlich alles superernst.
Das ist unser junger Abgeordneter, der immer hin und her schwankt.
Ich mache jetzt die ganz große Show im Kongress und verhindere z.B.
McCarthys Stimmen, weil ich dann immer noch was rausholen kann und trete auch
öffentlich als der große Counterpart auf.
Oder nee, ich hab grad zu tun mit so einem Sex-Traffic-Irgendwas-Fall,
den ich da gestern, weil ich ein tolles Wochenende hatte und so.
Diese jungen Leute erst ...
Sein Highlight war, glaub ich, damals, als er während der Corona-Pandemie im
Kongress mit so einer fetten Gasmaske aufgetreten ist.
Um irgendwie so einen Punkt zu machen, jetzt sollen wir alle solche Gasmasken tragen und so.
Eure Art. in einer Testmission.
Also, ich denke, ich fange mit Also auch hier wieder,
die Sensoren haben nichts aufgenommen und das Foto gibt es auch nicht,
jedenfalls nicht im automatischen Ablauf, sondern das kann auch genauso gut
im Nachhinein irgendwie reingefügt sein,
weil dann sagt er, ne, seht ihr, die Aliens sind wirklich da,
sie sind nicht nur da, sondern sie sabotieren uns auch schon,
sie greifen uns schon an, sie schalten das Radar aus, sie schalten die Kameras
aus und die Fotos müssen dann manuell gemacht werden und manuell in die Datenbank eingepflegt werden.
Ja, wie jedes andere manipulierte Video, so würden wir sagen. Also.
Und sonst wird man geblitzt, denkst. Ja. Wie bei Men in Black.
Ja. Das sind die großen bipartisan Angelegenheiten, mit denen sich die amerikanische
Politik gerade beschäftigt. Es ist wirklich illustre.
Sollen wir noch nach England springen?
Na los.
Rishi Sunak ist.
Rishi.
Rishi Sunak, ein indischer Name. und dieser Regisseur ist ein,
Premierminister, der genau in der Tradition von Johnson steht.
Aber interessanterweise, seit Johnson nicht mehr Premier ist,
kommt Großbritannien viel seriöser in den Medien weg als vorher.
Obwohl Rishi Sunak mindestens genauso schlimme Politik macht wie Johnson.
Und nicht nur Politik. Nur wenn jemand nicht mehr so aussieht wie ein Clown, ist sofort seriös.
Genau, ich habe im Fernsehpodcast die Woche mit Thomas auch die britischen Nachrichten
geguckt und Annette Dittert, die ja für die ARD so ein bisschen Korrespondentenschef ist.
Ah ja, sie ist nämlich im Podcast der Blätter, auch kurz, und sagt dann so,
Rishi Sunak macht im Grunde genau das, was Boris Johnson macht,
er hat nur einen besseren Friseur.
Und deswegen sehen wir den einfach nur so.
Es ist exakt so und das ist in meinen Augen ein sehr großes Medienversagen und
hinzu kommt dann auch noch mit dem Krieg, weil Großbritannien sich ja da besonders
als Unterstützer der Ukraine hinstellt.
Außer bei der Streumunition. Außer bei der Streumunition,
aber sonst dann tatsächlich hat man ja das schon, also bei Johnson war es ja
schon so, dass dann von linksliberaler Seite plötzlich Johnson gelobt wurde,
weil Johnson dahin gereist ist. Und bei Rishi Sunak hat man das jetzt auch wieder.
Wir gehen jetzt erst mal, wir gehen jetzt durch die Monate durch,
wir gehen jetzt mal in Februar 23.
Die Deutsche Welle berichtet da über Streiks.
In Großbritannien stand das Leben heute größtenteils still.
Eine halbe Million Beschäftigte, darunter Lehrer, Zugführer und Mitarbeiter
des öffentlichen Dienstes, beteiligten sich am größten Streik seit Jahren.
Sie fordern höhere Löhne und bessere Arbeitsbedingungen angesichts steigender
Lebenshaltungskosten.
Die Unzufriedenheit in vielen Branchen ist enorm. Dazu kommt die schwierige
wirtschaftliche Lage, drei Jahre nach dem Austritt Großbritanniens aus der EU.
Laut der gerade veröffentlichten Prognose des Internationalen Währungsfonds
ist Großbritannien die einzige fortschrittliche Volkswirtschaft,
der in diesem Jahr einer Rezession bevorsteht.
Den Brexit halten mittlerweile fast 60% der Briten für falsch.
Ja, Brexit ein großer Fehler, schreibt, dann hat auch in den Blättern wird inzwischen
von sehr vielen so gesehen, die eins noch dafür waren.
Jetzt gibt es diese Streiks, diese Arbeitskämpfe seit Monaten in Großbritannien
und was macht Rishi Sunak? Er versucht diese Streiks zu unterminieren durch ein neues Gesetz.
Dieses Gesetz heißt Minimum Safety Legislation und beschließt und dieses ist
jetzt beschlossen worden dieses Gesetz.
Und das sieht vor, dass man gerade im öffentlichen Dienst das Streikrecht stark einschränkt.
Denn es sei ja sonst eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung, wenn gewisse Dinge nicht
mehr da sind, wenn man nicht mehr versorgt wird. Und das wäre ja doof,
also wenn ein Streik auch tatsächlich eine Wirkung hätte, das wäre dumm.
Aber wir machen jetzt erst mal einen Sprung dazu.
Also ich meine, man kann doch mal wissen, auch ohne einen Streik.
Sind da irgendwie sechs, acht Millionen Menschen auf einer Warteliste für ihre
Arztbesuche, brauchen Krankenwagen zwölf Stunden, bis sie bei einem Noteinsatz
sind. Also dafür muss nichts lahmgelegt werden durch Arbeitskampf.
Ja, also Bahn, Feuerwehr, Gesundheits- und Bildungswesen müssen weiterhin eine
Grundversorgung, das ist dann wieder Definitionssache, zur Verfügung stellen.
Und Großbritannien hatte ohnehin schon immer extrem restriktive Gesetze für
Gewerkschaften in puncto Streiks, denn die Thatcher-Jahre sind ja nicht spurlos
vorübergegangen und man hat ja das auch alles beibehalten.
Aber ich will jetzt erst einmal springen, um diesen Diskurs noch mal deutlich zu machen.
Rishi Sunak ist ein Premier, der mindestens genauso schlimme Politik macht wie
Johnson, wird aber völlig anders rezipiert, beziehungsweise man nimmt es einfach
nicht wahr. Also sobald man ein anderes Gesicht hat, funktioniert es nicht mehr.
Dann sind die Feindbilder nicht
mehr da. Und man kann sich da wirklich mustergültig mal den Comedian,
den ich wirklich hasse, Trevor Noah anhören, der ja vor einigen Monaten sich
auch zu Rishi Sunak äußerte, und zwar in dieser Form.
Ich habe ihn nicht auf dem Topf dieses Landes zu vertrauen.
Can you imagine him going to the Scottish Nationalists and being the Prime Minister
of the Scottish Nationalists?
Could you imagine me becoming the Prime Minister of Pakistan or Saudi Arabia? No!
These things matter! Sorry you don't like it, but this is predominantly,
we're talking about England, right?
85% of the English people, yes, are white English people and they want to see
a Prime Minister that reflects them.
Yeah, this guy has a good point. Can you imagine if white English people wanted
to rule countries where no one looked like them? That would never happen.
Can you imagine that world? What would that world be like?
Ja, das ist eine sehr billige Pointe. Du wirst immer jemanden finden,
der sich rassistisch zu Rishi Sunak äußert, aber das ist ja nicht die Mehrheitsbevölkerung,
die deshalb ein Problem mit Rishi Sunak hat.
Oder mit Sadiq Khan, der London regiert, also man ist ja mittlerweile,
also ist ein wichtiges Thema, aber eben so, man darf damit nicht alle anderen verdrängen.
Aber was er jetzt hier macht, er
knüpft das gleiche an den britischen Kolonialismus und geht dann weiter.
Das ist so witzig für mich. Es ist witzig, wie Rassisten immer sagen,
Kolonialisierung war gut, es war ein Geschäft, bis sie fühlen,
dass sie kolonisiert werden.
Dann ist es plötzlich so, etwas muss gemacht werden, etwas muss gemacht werden.
Du bist nicht einmal kolonisiert, der Typ ist Britischer. Was ist mit dir falsch?
Wenn du mich fragst, ob britische Rassisten das ganze Ding falsch sehen,
dann könnte das für dich gut sein. Nach 400 Jahren wirst du endlich legitimitiv
eine braune Person für deine Länderprobleme schulden.
Das Problem ist, wenn man alles nur in dieser Identitätslogik beobachten kann,
dann sieht man irgendwann nichts mehr. Hier ein letzter Clip.
Ich meine, es gibt einen Teil von mir, der für englische Rassisten ein bisschen schlecht fühlt.
Nein, weil, erinnert ihr euch, sie haben für den Brexit gewählt.
Spezifisch, um Britannien weiß zu halten. Und dieses Wahlen hat eine 7-jährige
Schiene von Dominoes gestartet, die jetzt direkt zu einem indischen Präsidenten führt.
Ja, das griechische Republikum ist natürlich entsetzlich und ich würde sagen,
ja, die Brexiteers haben dafür gewählt, dass Großbritannien vorzugsweise weiß
bleibt und ich kann gleich vorspielen, dass genau dafür Rishi Sunak mit seiner
Politik sorgt, dass es möglichst weiß bleibt.
Aber dazu kommen wir gleich erst mal zu den Vermögensverhältnissen.
Also der Premierminister ist ja auch verheiratet und diese Frau ist die Tochter
eines indischen Tech-Milliardärs.
Und sie verfügen gemeinsam über ein höheres Nettovermögen als King,
Charles.
Das Paar besitzt vier über Großbritannien und Kalifornien verteilte Häuser im
Wert von 18,3 Millionen Dollar.
Dann noch in Santa Monica sind sie auch vertreten.
Moorthy, heißt die Frau, wurde Anfang dieses Jahres wegen ihres Steuerstatus
unter die Lupe genommen.
Was ich nämlich nicht wusste, als indische Staatsbürgerin ist Moorthy in ihrem
Heimatland steuerlich ansässig.
Und sie bestätigte im April, dass sie in Großbritannien den Status eines Nicht-Domizils
hat, dass es sie ermöglicht, Dividenden und Kapitalertragssteuern in Großbritannien zu vermeiden.
Über eine Sprecherin teilte sie der BBC mit, dass sie etwa 34.000 Dollar pro
Jahr für die Aufrechterhaltung für dieses Status zahlt, eine Gebühr,
die erhoben wird, wenn eine Person mindestens sieben der letzten neun Jahre
in den Vereinigten Königreich lebte.
Forbes schätzt, dass Murti von 2015
bis 2022 17, 70 Millionen Dollar an Infosystemdividenden verdient hat.
Plus 17 Millionen Dollar aus Aktienverkäufen und da kommen Kapitalgewinn und alles hinzu.
Wird alles nicht in Großbritannien versteuert.
Also wir haben es hier mit extrem reichen Leuten zu tun und wenn das Trevonours
Antikolonialismus ist, nun ja. Wir kommen zurück zu den Streiks.
Rishi Sunak erklärt hier sein Vorhaben im Januar.
Und anderen, die sich dafür sorgen, dass wir Minimum-Levels von Sicherheit in
kritischen Bereichen, wie Feuer, wie Ambulanz, haben, damit,
auch wenn Streitungen stattfinden, ihr Wohlstand gesichert wird.
Ich denke, das ist völlig reasonabel. Und das ist, was unsere neuen Regeln tun
werden. Wir wollen eine gewöhnliche, ehrliche Konversation mit allen Union-Lehrern
über die Frage haben, was verantwortlich ist, was reasonabel ist und was für
unser Land bezahlbar ist, wenn es ums Geld geht.
Es geht eigentlich um die blanke Angst, denn tatsächlich sind zwischen Juni
22 bis April 23 durch die Streiks 3,7 Millionen Arbeitstage verloren gegangen.
Und die britische Wirtschaft rechnet ja damit, dass sie Einbußen hat durch den
Brexit allein von vier Prozent Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Was erstaunlich wenig ist, so ne?
Ja, das könnte noch höher werden, schreibt Anne Dittert. Es ist so, dass man also,
ist zugleich ja mit einer höheren Inflation als hier zu tun hat,
also da sprechen wir von zehn Prozent und die Zentralbankpolitik der Zinsanhebung
funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
Stephen Flynn von der Scottish National Party fragt dann mal im Parlament nach.
Sie können ihre Rechte haben, aber nur auf seinen Terminen.
Herr Speaker, es ist auch das Recht der britischen Bevölkerung,
ihren normalen Tag-zu-Tag-Leben ohne ungewöhnliche, seriöse Zerrückung zu verbringen.
Deshalb ist es richtig, dass die Polizei zusätzliche Macht hat.
Ich habe Respekt, dass der Herr Präsident das nicht stimmt. Aber wir glauben, dass es richtig ist.
Und die Leute werden jeden Tag, jeden Tag auf der TV sehen, dass ihre Leben zerstört werden.
Sie sind nicht in der Lage, nach der Schule, nach der Krankenversicherung und
in der Arbeit zu kommen. Das ist unglaublich.
Man will eigentlich die Effektivität von Streiks brechen und dann wird das als
Mindestdienstniveau oder so deklariert von Sunak und das führt dazu,
dass eigentlich dann ein Arbeitskampf fast nicht mehr möglich wird,
es sei denn man hat dann mit strafrechtlichen Konsequenzen zu rechnen und dem
werden sich die Gewerkschaften nicht aussetzen.
Das Problem Das Problem ist nur, dass die Labour-Party dem auch so gut wie nichts entgegenstellt.
Das ist diese Pointe. Ich kann diesen Artikel sehr empfehlen aus den Blättern
von Anette Dittlert. Dass tatsächlich die Labour-Party überhaupt nichts dagegen
macht, auch was die Migration anbelangt.
Eigentlich wissen die Labours, dass sie wahrscheinlich die Wahl die nächste
gewinnen werden, weil es um Sunak nicht gut bestellt ist. Aber es sieht nicht
danach aus, großartig verändern.
Austerität mit Staatsschulden, Abbau sogar. Mit Staatsschulden,
ja. Kleine Alternative.
Großes Thema im Unterhaus, aber jetzt erst noch mal Sunak diesem Minimum-Safety-Act.
Es ist absolut richtig, dass die Menschen auf die Notdruckservice aufhören, wenn sie sie brauchen.
Deshalb werden wir schnell Maßnahmen vornehmen, um die Ambulanzzeit und die
Notdruckservice zu verbessern.
Aber ich sage dem Ehrenamt, wenn er sich um die Notdruckservice kümmert,
warum unterstützt er nicht unsere Minimumsicherheitsgesetzes?
Ich finde, man sollte sich das sehr genau anhören. Wir hatten ja auch Streiks
vergleichsweise gering mit dem, was da in Großbritannien vor sich gegangen ist.
Und da hat man ja schon von Arbeitgeberseite, von FDP und CDU solche Sätze gehört
wie, ja, es darf ja nicht sein, dass die alles lahmlegen.
Und man müsste da auch mal ans Streikrecht ran.
Hier kann man dann irgendwann schon die Schablone sich abholen.
Ja, also es ist ja insbesondere perfide, wenn man das Argument machen möchte,
jeder Streik würde an der Grundversorgung rütteln, dann muss man ja das ganze
System erst mal runtergerockt haben auf Grundversorgung, sodass Streik überhaupt
immer nur noch Grundversorgung betrifft und das ist ja die Tory-Politik,
der ist ein Jahrzehnte gewesen.
Also haben sie sich quasi selber
dieses Argument, mit dem sie jetzt andere erpressen, so zurechtgelegt.
Ja, wir hören jetzt Long Bailey von der Labour-Party. Und leider,
denke ich, dass das Publikum das sehen kann, was es ist. Das Publikum ist hinter
streikenden Arbeitern. Sie wollen Negotiationen sehen. Und sie wollen,
dass unsere wichtigen Arbeitgeber respektiert und rechtlich bezahlt werden.
Im Guardian war zu lesen, die in dieser Woche im Parlament verabschiedete sekundäre
Gesetzgebung wird die Polizei ermächtigen,
Bedingungen für Proteste aufzuerlegen, von denen sie annimmt,
dass sie mehr als nur geringfügige Störungen verursachen können,
Einschließlich der Änderung von Zeiten, Orten und Routen sowie der Auferlegung
von Lärmbeschränkungen.
Also das ist so unglaublich.
Und stell dir mal vor, du würdest da jetzt leben.
Ich meine, wir föhnen ja hier auch und das ist ja nicht so, dass die das alles
nicht auch intellektuell durchdringen können, wenn sie wollen.
Die haben ja mit der BBC ein Angebot, dass sie ihnen da wirklich einen Spiegel vorhält.
Das ist wirklich, ich, also, keine Ahnung.
Und trotzdem diese, wir haben es ja jetzt erst wieder, ich habe ja diese ganzen
britischen Nachrichten und so wieder zwochenlang geguckt,
also so hintereinander weg einfach, dass ich so ein Bild, das ist wirklich erstaunlich,
wie wenig Politiker und wie wenig, also, dass sie einfach niemals Politiker
so im Abendfernsehen haben.
So wie wir, Gespräch mit Linder, Gespräch mit Habeck, alles mögliche findet einfach nicht statt.
Kirsten Dahmer kam da jetzt mal, weil die so in drei Nachwahlen für Parlamentssitze
eben einen Zweien abgeräumt haben, da war das so ein Thema.
Aber Politiker als Protagonisten des Geschehens finden da nicht statt.
Also man wüsste als Wähler so gar nicht richtig, wohin adressiert man denn jetzt überhaupt?
Wenn es dann thematisiert wird, hört man nur kein Gegenangebot.
Und Labour weiß so gar nicht, was sie machen sollen. Thomas hat das so verglichen
mit, die tragen so eine chinesische Vase gerade noch eineinhalb Jahre so durch
und wollen das gar nicht groß gefährden und so. Und dieser Brexit ist einfach das absolute Tabu.
Also findet einfach gar kein, es gibt mal so Halbsätze, wenn Gesprächspartner
da sind, so Gesprächsgäste oder so. Aber es ist einfach gar nichts.
Also es ist wirklich, dieses Land
ist auf so vielen Ebenen so heruntergewirtschaftet, es ist unglaublich.
Und so wie die Logik der Toys ist, braucht Sunak eigentlich eine Rezession,
so sagt es jemand im Podcast von The New Statesman.
To the Bank of England.
Will almost certainly drive the economy into recession and we've even had a
senior advisor to the treasury say in terms that the bank of England must now
drive Britain into a recession,
must create quotes the fragility and the uncertainty of a recession to stop
firms putting up prices and to stop workers asking for more money.
This is an absolutely extraordinary and in my view unprecedented situation.
Und die Hypotheken, die da auslaufen, also die ja quasi immer so die Idee waren von den Tories auch,
ja jeder hat dann so sein Eigenheim, hat sein Eigentum und all das,
da wurde ausgerechnet, dass aufgrund der hohen Zinsen dann plötzlich 7000 Pfund
pro Jahr mehr fällig werden.
Und das reißt natürlich einige in den absoluten Ruin.
Es ist so irre. Das hat sich ja in Deutschland, wir haben es ja schon mal an
Index-Beaten thematisiert, dass man da keine Sicherheit mehr findet.
Und bei den Häuskäufern war ja auch, dass die Banken dann irgendwann diese Angebote
gemacht haben, wir machen eine 10-jährige Zinsbindung, obwohl der Kredit aber
25 Jahre oder was auch immer läuft.
Und niemand hätte sich eine Zinswende vorstellen können, aber jetzt ist sie plötzlich da.
Und in Deutschland betrifft das so ein paar. Ich kenne sehr viele,
wir sind ja in dem Alter, wo die Leute so, wenn überhaupt, in den letzten fünf
bis zehn Jahren ihre Verträge da unterschrieben haben.
Und sehr viele Leute haben sich doch sehr abgesichert und gehen jetzt so ein
bisschen geruhsam in der sehr turbulenten Zeit, Zeit, zumindest was diese eigene,
also unmittelbare biografische Wohnsituation und so weiter angeht.
Aber in England ist es, gibt es das gar nicht, einen Vertrag mit Zinsbindung.
Das ist so irre, wenn man sich überlegt, selbst in der Bank of England müssen
sie doch da gesessen haben mit, okay, wenn die Zinswende kommt,
verdienen wir dann zwar mehr Geld, aber wir stürzen das ganze Land ins emotionale Chaos.
Und die haben es trotzdem gemacht einfach.
Weil sie dachten, das ist aber ganz gut, wenn wir dann nochmal den Banken ein
bisschen Profite verschaffen.
Wir können denen dann sagen, guck mal, durch die und die Politik könnt ihr dann
nächstes Jahr drei Milliarden verdienen statt einer Milliarde.
Aber dass das Geld Leuten weggenommen wird, wo es dann wirklich ans Eingemachte
geht, also ans Wohnen einfach und so.
Und man hat sich jetzt nur noch einigen können, dass es eine zwölfmonatige Schonfrist
vielleicht gibt. Das wird da noch ein bisschen aufgeschoben.
Das sind zwölf Monate geregelt.
Also das ist wirklich ein ökonomischer Klassenkampf von oben durchgeführt,
ein Eiskalt durchgezogen in einem Ausmaß, wie man es sich gar nicht vorstellen
kann hier in Deutschland.
Und selbstverständlich, die Kinder haben auch zu leiden. leiden.
Es geht jetzt hier im Unterhaus mal um kostenloses Mittagessen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Sprecher. Herr Präsident, wir haben in diesem Land 4 Millionen
Kinder, die in Pflege leben. Wir sind aber die fünfte reichste Ökonomie der
Welt. Warum würde der Herr Präsident nicht universelle Schulabschlüsse für alle
Kinder für die Endzeit der Kinderpflege unterstützen?
Herr Sprecher, die Zahlen sind tatsächlich so.
Seit 2010 leben 1,7 Millionen weniger Menschen in Pflege,
Result of the actions of this government and that includes hundreds of thousands
fewer children living in poverty and most importantly,
because like the Honourable Lady,
I do want to ensure that children don't grow up in poverty, but we know that
the best way to do that is start in life.
Ja, wir geben ihnen kein kostenloses Mittagessen, aber die Eltern sollen mal arbeiten.
Genau, dieses die Eltern sollen mal arbeiten, das ist so crazy.
Ich reproduziere, was wir erst Dienstag im Fernsehpodcast besprochen haben,
aber es ist so unfassbar.
Die Kirstamer quasi Regierung, so ein Schattenkabinett, was da schon fertig
bereitsteht, wurde so gefragt. Ja, wir haben jetzt diese Torie-Politik.
Es gibt überhaupt nur für zwei Kinder familienpolitische Maßnahmen.
Das dritte Kind musst du komplett selber finanzieren.
Und dann hat Starmer das so, ja, das ist okay, das machen wir dann auch so weiter.
Also wir legen da gar keine Bremse ein und korrigieren das wieder.
Und die Argumentation der Tories ist dieses, die Eltern sollen arbeiten.
Nur die Armut bringt die Eltern dazu, aktiv zu werden und zu arbeiten.
Wenn wir den Geld zahlen, liegen die zu Hause voll rum.
Also dieses Menschenbild dahinter, obwohl man, und das ist nicht anders als
in Deutschland, weiß, ja, wir haben so und so viel Hartz-IV-Bezieher,
aber die Hälfte davon sind Aufstocker, die arbeiten schon.
Und die arbeiten auch schon Vollzeit. Und es sind auch die alleinerziehenden
Mütter, die dann irgendwie, und das ist besonders crazy, der meist angenommene
Beruf alleinerziehender Mütter ist das Putzen. Das Putzen findet zu nicht...
Also das Kind ist in der Schule, dann ist die Mutter zu Hause.
Das Kind kommt nach Hause, dann sind auch die Büros leer und die Mutter fährt zum Putzen.
Da gibt's dann gar keine Familie, nicht mal zu zweit. Das ist so irre und das
ist ja in England genau dasselbe. Die Leute arbeiten ja alle schon.
Also diese ganze Argumentation und die wissen genau, dass es falsch ist.
Es fehlen ja Arbeitskräfte ohne Ende. Da gibt's ja Zahlen, die hab ich mir hier rausgesucht.
Wenn man Brexit macht und 300.000, 400.000 Polen rausschmeißt innerhalb von
drei Monaten und niemanden sonst mehr reinlässt.
Ja, Keir Starmer von der Labour Party spricht hier anekdotisch,
hat einen Polizisten getroffen.
Sie werden das nicht hören wollen. Er hat mir heute Morgen erzählt,
dass sie entschieden haben, ihr Haus zu verkaufen, um es zu reduzieren.
Und er hat seinen Kindern gerade erzählt, Sie werden ein Wohnzimmer teilen müssen.
Warum sollte James und seine Familie den Kosten der Fehler des Präsidenten bezahlen?
Herr Speaker, ich hoffe, dass, als der ehemalige Herr zu James gesprochen hat,
er erklärt hat, dass seine ökonomischen Politiken James' Situation schlimmer machen würden.
Und es ist nicht nur ich, der das sagt.
Das Independente Institut für Finanzielle Studien sagt,
dass seine Politik, die nie endliche Schulden und Zahlen zerstört,
James zerstört würde, Because it would increase inflation and drive up interest
rates, leaving James and everybody else in this country poorer.
Und deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt gesund sparen. Das ist dann Christian Lindner auf Englisch.
Kommen wir noch mit drei Clips zum Thema Migration. Es ist ganz grausam,
was da gemacht wird. Ich zitiere mal ganz kurz aus diesem Artikel von Annette
Dittert aus den Blättern.
Mit der von Johnson übernommenen Rwanda-Policy sollen sogenannte illegale Migranten,
die derzeit vermehrt in kleinen Booten an der britischen Küste landen,
ohne jede richterliche Überprüfung erst festgenommen und anschließend nach Rwanda ausgeflogen werden.
In ein Land, mit dem Großbritannien ein entsprechendes Abkommen hat.
De facto wird ihnen damit das
Recht genommen, Asyl auf britischem Boden überhaupt erst zu beantragen.
Dieser Ansatz ist weder mit der Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention noch mit den Prinzipien
der Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention vereinbar.
Nachdem das nationale Berufungsgericht den Gesetzentwurf jetzt als illegal ablehnte,
attackierte Sunak die Richter indirekt und ließ seine Innenministerin Braverman
die Klagen der Menschenrechtsorganisationen als phony humanitarianism beschimpfen.
Ganz in der Tradition.
Johnsons, der ihm nicht genehme Anwälte und Richter immer wieder als linke Aktivisten denunziert hatte.
Und was ich besonders verrückt fand war, also die jetzt da ausgeflogen werden,
was kostet das den Steuerzahler, also jeder Flüchtling, der da ankommt, was kostet das?
200.000 Euro pro Person muss ausgegeben werden für diese Aktion.
Und das war das große Versprechen von Sunak, stop the boats,
also die kleinen Boote. Es handelt sich da im Jan von um 40.000 Boote,
die da angekommen sind. A.
Doppelt so viel übrigens wie zuvor in dem Jahreszeitraum unter Johnson.
Also es hat sich gar nicht gerechnet. B.
Und dann sagt dann der Digital auch, naja bei 67 Millionen Einwohner müsste
man mit 40.000 Leuten ja noch so gerade zurückkommen, zumal ja einige fehlen.
Aber so hört sich das dann an. hier, ich hab das mal so zusammengeschnitten.
Ja, das war immer Sonac, das ist ein großer Slogan.
Wir haben ja damals schon gesehen, wie die in Calais in Frankreich leben und
dann da so weggekärchert werden, um diese französische Sprache zu verwenden.
Und wenn jetzt so von diesen kleinen Booten, es ist ja wirklich wie in Nolans
Dunkirk, es sind die kleinen Boote, die über den Ärmelkanal fahren und die Storys
sind genauso dramatisch wie mitten im Krieg sozusagen.
Das sind ja Leute, die sind schon hier angekommen in Europa,
die sind ja eigentlich schon in Europa und wollen aber noch nach England.
Also die muten sich ja selber noch etwas zu, was wirklich jenseits unseres Verständnisses liegt.
Also man kann es eigentlich gar nicht, man bräuchte da wirklich einen Film,
der uns das gefühlsmäßig noch mal sozusagen als aus der Ich-Perspektive irgendwie zeigt.
Aber ja, diese Art von Politik, also überhaupt dieses Thema so aufzugreifen
und diese unverständlichen, dramatischen, biografischen Storys so runter zu
kochen auf, wer stoppt the boat?
Ja. Das ist wirklich jenseits von.
Und auch in längerer Form wird das nicht besser.
Sein Regierungsgesetz, das Verpflichtungsschreiben des illegalen und immoralen
Flüchtlinge und die toxische Sprache, die aus dem Homeoffice kommt,
ist nicht einmal Dog-Whistle-Politik.
Es ist ein riesiger, hartgeprägter Vogthorn, der aus einem schmerzhaften Demenas-Narrativ ausbläst.
Und es hat letzte Woche neue Schmerzen gepflückt, als der Homeoffice-Minister
erklärte, dass die Menschen, die in den UK kommen wollen, und ich bezeichne
das, haben völlig andere Werte als diejenigen in den UK.
Können Sie erklären, was er so anders findet, die Werte der Leute im Sudan,
die durch die Kriege geführt wurden?
Und können Sie uns erzählen, welche Werte ihn von einem Sudaner-Familien-Visaschiff
wie er für die Leute in der Ukraine verhindern?
Herr Sprecher, dieses Land hat eine stolze Geschichte, fast eine halbe Million
Flüchtlinge in den letzten Jahren zu begrüßen. Und wir werden das immer weiter tun.
Aber unsere Möglichkeit, das zu tun, ist absolut unbequem, wenn wir Tausende
von Menschen haben, die jedes Jahr illegal den Kanal überbrechen.
Und das ist genau deshalb, dass wir die meisten Verletzten helfen wollen,
egal ob in Syrien, Afghanistan, Sudan oder wo auch immer.
Wir müssen uns an diesem Problem befassen, die Zyklen der Kriminellen-Gangs
brechen und unsere Ressourcen und Verzicht auf diejenigen, die es am meisten brauchen.
Wusstest du, dass es auch jetzt eine Chance gibt auf ein zweites Referendum,
dass man auch noch aus der europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention austreten will?
Auch das, also aus EU-Rat und so? Ja, das ist auch noch, da schreibt Annette
Dittert, ein Schritt, den bislang nur Russland und Weißrussland gegangen sind.
Es ist völlig unklar, was da passiert.
Ein zivilisatorisches Implodieren, das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
War im Handelsblatt jetzt gestern, 27.
Juli, wahltaktische Wende. Die Angst der Tories vor dem Machtverlust ist in
diesem Sommer größer als die Sorge vor der Klimakatastrophe.
Die Wirtschaft verlangt Klarheit und jetzt überlegt man, ob man nicht diese
Klimaziele, die Johnson gesetzt hat, doch lieber mal aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen
Lage sein lässt. Wir hören einen letzten Clip aktuell.
Ich habe ihn bei Twitter gefunden. Rishi Sunak spricht direkt in die Kamera.
Und richtet sich an die Leute in den Booten und es ist so unglaublich,
wir spielen es einfach nur noch ab und sagen, dann weiß ich nicht,
ob uns noch was einfällt.
Ja, like Rwanda. Und er strahlt dabei in die Kamera, als würde er einen Rabattcode
uns jetzt allen anbieten.
Ja, nicht ohne Grund kommt man da ja aus dieser Debattengeschichte in den Unis
und Schulen, einem das Thema hingewürfelt wird. Man muss debattieren,
unabhängig davon, welche Haltung man vertritt.
Und hier sieht man halt, wie er methodisch draufgecoacht ist,
das zu machen. Und inhaltlich wird halt diese Platte jetzt aufgelegt,
dass es da dann zu einem gewissen Mismatch kommt.
Das sieht ja dann auch keiner. Man weiß ja, wenn so ein Premierminister kommuniziert,
dann gucken da nochmal drei Agenturen drüber und man denkt, das wird das hat
sich irgendwie gemacht, aber das, ja.
Unklar was da abläuft.
Also keine, keine gute Stimmung in England.
Ich will zum Abschluss, ich habe noch so ein paar kleine Sachen,
aber die können wir uns auch aufheben.
GPT leitet an Demenz und so weiter, weil jetzt immer mehr synthetische Texte
als Grundlage mitverwendet werden und das User Feedback dann auch nicht so gut
ist, dass man daraus wohl viel lernen kann.
Also wir hatten irgendwie so Peak-GPT 2023 dann im Februar, als es kam oder März, oder so.
Und Stefan, hast du jetzt nicht mal gesehen, mit dem Nolan-Film,
wie richtige Menschen richtige Filme machen?
Ja, eben.
Rückst du jetzt mal ein bisschen ab von dieser Fantasterei, ab nächstes Jahr
bestücken wir Netflix nur noch mit generierten Filmen?
Naja, die algorithmische Durchseuchung der Skriptbildung haben wir ja schon,
die hast du ja auch schon kritisiert.
Ja, aber bei Nolen nicht.
Bei Nolen nicht.
Und das merkt man auch. Ich finde, es muss mehr solche Filme gehen oder man
sollte sich mehr solche guten Filme ansehen.
Es gibt die Filme ja. Damit man auch die Differenz klar erkennt. Wenn man nur diese ...
Wie heißt der, der jetzt so ganz viel kopiert wurde als AI-Musik?
Ist das der Rulo? Oder wer wurde für relativ viel ...
Wenn man sich nur diese doch sehr aseptisch klingende Musik den ganzen Tag anhört,
dann wird man auch tatsächlich nicht mit den großen Unterschied ausmachen können
zu dem, was da jetzt mit KI produziert werden kann.
Aber ich sag mal, wenn man dann nochmal so ein Orchester vor sich hat,
dann merkt man schon nochmal einen deutlichen Unterschied.
Und wenn man vielleicht dasselbe Stück dreimal von anderen interpretiert wird ebenso.
Und auch hier bei Christopher Nolan sieht man dann, warum so eine analoge Technik
uns ein Gesicht nochmal in einer Weise näher bringen kann, wie wir es nicht gedacht hätten.
Was ja auch bedeutet, ans Zimmer.
Es sind noch Instrumente, auch wenn sie versteckt werden, ja,
weil er mit Dune beschäftigt ist. Machen wir Dune 1, Dune 2 dafür.
Der Göransson oder wie er heißt, hat es perfekt gemacht. Es gibt diesen zweiten
Can You Hear The Music, heißt das sogar, der Titel.
Ist jetzt gar nicht, also schon so, aber es ist nicht die Trailer Musik oder
so, sondern wo einfach, also das ist wirklich, das ist so gut auf so vielen
Ebenen, dass man sich fast wünscht, sowas würde man auch noch mal in der Oper hören.
Also es ist wirklich einfach ein Spektakel.
Gut, genug Oppenheimer gelobt. Ich will zum Abschluss für uns einen Clip,
den man hätte auch ganz am Anfang spielen können, aber wir machen ihn jetzt,
denn es ist wirklich witzig. Es ist der 17. Juli, 23 Uhr.
Der Deutschlandfunk schwenkt um auf Das war der Tag. Gibt es ja auch als Podcast.
Es ist die Tageszusammenfassung, bevor die deutsche und die europäische Hymne gespielt werden.
Und Peter Zudeig eröffnet mal eine Minute lang diesen Nachrichtenüberblick zum Tage.
Und ich finde irgendwie, das ist wirklich beispielhaft. Wir sollten uns das...
Jürgen Zurheide?
Du hast Zudeig gesagt.
Zudeig. Ich verwechsel ihn mal mit Peter Zudeig, der hier H2,
der Tag ganz viel gemacht hat. Okay. Also in dem Fall Jürgen Zurheide.
Mit Jürgen Zurheide war ich in Berlin, hatte er ein Panel moderiert, mit dem ich zu Gast war.
Ah, siehste. Also ich, ganz herausragender Typ. Ja. Mit einer tollen Stimme.
Ja, das war auch, als Adam Toost da war, da ging es so.
Ah, ja, ja. Ah, sehr gut, sehr gut. Also Jürgen zur Heide, äh,
immer eine Freude, weil er halt ... Mhm, ja.
Ja, ja.
Weiß auch nicht, manchmal hab ich den Eindruck, die Redaktion,
die da so zuarbeitet, denkt, ah, Jürgen ist da.
Wir sagen nichts. Er macht das sowieso. Wir funken gar nicht mehr dazwischen.
Er hat sich da so Freiräume erarbeitet, wie auch immer. Also er nimmt sich ja
wirklich eine Minute Zeit für die Sendungseröffnung.
Ich finde es grandios und denke mir auch.
Wir sollen es als Paradigma für alles. Es ist auch für das heute-Journal oder
für die Tagesthemen, für die Tagesschau.
Man kann ruhig immer mal wieder darauf hinweisen, was eigentlich ist und dass es ist, wie es ist.
Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag. Und dazu begrüßt Sie Jürgen Zaheide.
Unsere Erde hat Probleme, man könnte auch sagen gewaltige Probleme.
Schauen Sie nur auf die Thermometer dieser Welt. In den USA gibt es Hitzerekorde,
in China gibt es Hitzerekorde, in Südeuropa überall.
Ja, selbst hier bei uns in Deutschland gibt es einen Hitzerekord nach dem anderen.
Und das alles ist kein Zufall mehr, wir wissen das.
Eigentlich müsste die Welt, die Regierungen, sie müssten zusammenstehen,
um zumindest zu versuchen zu retten, was möglicherweise noch zu retten ist.
Stattdessen, wenn ich auf das Programm heute Abend hier schaue,
Bomben in der Ukraine, Bomben auf die Brücke zur Krim und das Ende des Getreideabkommens.
Das sind alles keine Nachrichten, die irgendwie fröhlich stimmen können.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Vor allen Dingen angesichts der Herausforderungen,
die wir eigentlich haben, nehmen diese Nachrichten all unsere Interessen in Anspruch.
Wir werden Sie heute Abend, das ist unsere Pflicht, darüber informieren.
Sehr gut. Ja, also das ist genial. Richtig gut.
Es ist einfach eine tolle Minute, die er sich da rausgekämpft hat,
um einfach einen Fokus zu legen.
Wir verweisen zum Schluss noch auf den Salon.
Wir sprechen, wie schon gesagt, über zwei Bücher, die sich fragen, gibt es die Realität?
Wenn ja, wie sieht sie aus? Wie müssen wir sie erweitern? Es ist unsere Vorbereitung auf die Gamescom.
Einmal lesen wir...
Falls ihr fragt, wir sind an dem Sonntag, am allerletzten Gamescom-Tag,
oder sind wir am Samstag da? Am Sonntag. Also wir sind an diesem fünften Wochenendtag,
Sonntag sind wir auf der Gamescom.
Ja, also wir lesen einmal Realitätsverlust von Joachim Bauer und weil Joachim
Bauer das Buch kritisiert hat und ich das bei Amazon gelesen habe, lesen wir David J.
Schalmers Realität plus virtuelle Welten und die Probleme der Philosophie.
Bauer ist bei Heine erschienen, Schalmers bei Surkamp und ich werde über zwei
literarische Werke noch sprechen.
Und zwar will ich doch diesem Thema Sterben lernen, das Ende,
wie lebt man ist, noch mal literarisch nachgehen.
Helga Schubert, sie ist Jahrgang 1940 Schriftstellerin aus der DDR gewesen,
hat dann jetzt für Furore gesorgt, weil sie beim Bachmann-Preis dabei war.
Einmal durfte sie nicht hin, jetzt 2020 wurde sie wieder eingeladen.
Und sie hat sich jetzt ein Buch vorgelegt, der heutige Tag, ein Stundenbuch der Liebe.
Da heißt es auf dem Klappentext, über 50 Jahre lang teilten sie ihr Leben.
Doch nun ist der Mann schwer krank.
Das ist ein Buch, das gelesen werden muss, glaube ich, damit man in den aktuellen Debatten drin ist.
Und dann habe ich ein Buch gelesen, das für Furore schon vorab gesorgt hat.
Michelle Welbeck, einige Tage, einige Monate in meinem Leben.
Du hast es vielleicht ein bisschen mitbekommen. Einmal hat er ein islamfeindliches
Interview gegeben, das für Furore sorgte. Und dann gibt es einen merkwürdigen Trailer.
Welbeck hat in einem Porno mitgespielt oder wurde da überrumpelt.
Es gibt einen längeren Prozess, es ist völlig obskur.
Ich habe dieses Buch gelesen und ich kann mich noch nicht entscheiden,
ob es totaler Schrott oder genial ist. Die Entscheidung treffe ich dann im nächsten Salon.
Wolfgang sieht mich, wie ich euch jetzt beschreibe, wie man mich gerade sieht.
Ich habe meinen Kopf auf meine Faust gestützt und schüttel so den Kopf und denke mir, hold back.
Ich achte einfach darauf, wann das Gespräch zu hold back zu Ende ist und dann
steige ich wieder ein, weil ich verstehe es mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Das ist ein auf und ab und hin und her. Ich habe immer so gedacht,
soll ich es doch nochmal lesen? Soll ich mir nochmal irgendwas Und ich denke mir jetzt, nö.
Also ich lasse Ulbeck einfach an mir vorüberziehen.
Redet ihr auch in meiner Anwesenheit gerne über Ulbeck?
Das ist ein Fehler in Bezug auf seine literarischen Werke, ganz eindeutig.
Gut. Ich habe in der einen Kolumne, ich glaube bei Übermedien,
ich weiß nicht genau, bei Spiegel, das schreibt ja so viel, Samira,
hat ein Sammelband zu Westworld besprochen.
Das war, glaube ich, in der Süddeutschen Zeitung.
Deutschen, eine tausend Sassasarinnen oder wie man das dann nennt.
Den werde ich natürlich mit großem Interesse mir zurechtlegen,
je nachdem, ob ich neben den 600 Seiten abseits von Zeitungsartikeln noch was
schaffe, werde ich auf jeden Fall mir dieses Westworld-Ding mal anschauen.
Diesen oder nächsten Salon. Also in der Hinsicht möchte ich gerne grundsätzlich
teasen und gar nicht so sehr speziell.
Den Rest weiß ich noch nicht genau. Wie immer ist die Salonwoche für mich die
Woche, Bevor wir den Salon aufnehmen, ja genau.
Ja, wir freuen uns, wenn ihr uns im Salon besucht und auf diese Weise auch den Podcast unterstützt.
Am liebsten über Steady, die anderen Wege kennt ihr auch. Und dann wünschen
wir einen schönen Monat.
Haut rein!